In einer Welt der Unsicherheit, der Instabilität, alles, die Wirtschaft liegt am Boden.
Der Papst ist tot. Der Papst ist tot. Es ist alles.
Dem Untergang geweiht.
Donald ist immer noch da.
Gibt es denn noch Stabilität in dieser Welt? Und die Antwort lautet,
es gibt noch die Freakshow.
Und hier ist sie wieder für euch.
Und deswegen ist alles nicht so schlimm.
Weil ihr könnt euch jetzt einfach zurücklehnen und wieder Hoffnung schöpfen. Oder?
Was für ein Intro.
Ja. Man muss ja mal den Punkt machen.
Ja.
Okay, während die anderen beiden total fahren sind hier von meinem Einstieg,
sage ich erstmal herzlich willkommen zur Freakshow.
Ich bin's Tim, Tim Rittlaff und mir gegenüber sitzt Roddy. Hallo Roddy.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Ich bin etwas geschockt, der Scheitel sitzt auch nicht mehr ganz so sicher.
Naja.
Zu meiner Linken, der Ralf. Hallo Ralf.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend. Heute mal richtig gesund. Was? For the record.
Ich rede hier gerade über Stabilität und Kontinuität und jetzt bist du auf einmal gesund.
Ah, Rudi hat das übernommen, sehr schön. Alles klar.
Ja, man hört es vielleicht ein bisschen, dass ich leicht belegt bin im Hals.
Okay, gut. Dann muss ich dich jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendwo rausschneiden.
Ja, die Nachbearbeitung. Ganz wichtig. Ja, Freakshow-Nummer.
Was haben wir denn heute?
291.
Ist das so?
Das ist so. Das steht zumindest hier in unserem Pad.
Wenn es im Pad steht, dann muss es wahr sein. Genau. Manchmal komme ich dann
doch ein bisschen durcheinander mit den Nummern.
Die letzte war 290. Von daher stehen die Chancen hoch.
Ja, ich habe zum Beispiel jetzt diese Sendung.
Wie konfus ich manchmal bin. Die Sendung speichert gerade unter UKW 133 ab.
Keine Ahnung, wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin.
Na gut, dann reden wir halt über die Ukraine.
Zuletzt hatte ich das Thema Serbien, um mal ein bisschen Abwechslung in die
Sache reinzubringen. Da geht es ja auch rund.
Ja, aber wir machen heute keine Politik. Also zumindest keine,
über die wir ohne weiteres hinweg sehen können.
Also ja.
Das könnte sein, dass es noch welche gibt, die wir auch nicht ignorieren können,
aber ja, so weiß es aber nicht.
Ich bin jetzt final wieder da und das mal so ein bisschen for the record.
Final wieder da klingt wie ein Widerspruch.
Naja, letztes Mal war ich ja noch nicht ganz wieder da.
Da war ich zwar kurz wieder da, aber dann war ich ja auch gleich schon wieder
weg und ich habe nochmal eine kleine Reise, eine Doppelreise hinten angestellt
und ich war auf einer Elixierkonferenz.
Das war eine sehr gute Idee, dass ich auf einer Elixierkonferenz war.
Wo war die Elixierkonferenz?
Die Elixierkonferenz war in Braga.
Und wo ist Braga?
Das ist die drittgrößte Stadt welches Landes.
Wenn ich es wüsste, würde ich nicht fragen.
Ich weiß. Ich tue das jetzt trotzdem noch ein bisschen raus.
Ich versuche nicht zu googeln, es gelingt mir nicht.
Alle Hörerinnen und Hörer denken mit. Der Chat sagt, Portugal, 100 Punkte an Halifax.
Oh Gott, die Treppe bin ich schon mal hochgelaufen.
Welche Treppe? In Braga.
Sehr große, lange Treppe in Braga, wenn ich das so richtig sehe.
Du bist schon mal die Treppe in Braga hochgelaufen und weißt nicht, dass es Braga gibt.
Ich kann mir doch Namen nicht merken. Leider weder von Menschen,
was schwierig ist schon gar nicht von Stetten, aber auf diese Treppe bin ich hochgelaufen.
Das ist eine wirklich sehr, sehr lange Treppe. Wirst du die auch hochgelaufen?
Die zur Basilika unserer lieben Frau von Samero führt?
Exakt.
Tatsächlich nein, aber ich war im Stadion von Braga.
Tja, so sind unsere Prioritäten verteilt.
Das Stadion von Braga ist auch eine Erwähnung wert. Es ist tatsächlich eine,
jetzt kannst du wieder mal so einen, wie wir hier sehen, Moment einführen in diesem Podcast.
Und ja, das Stadion von Braga ist nämlich auch sehr speziell.
Roddy guckt schon wieder so. Ich werde jetzt das einfach mal hier kurz visualisieren.
Okay.
Oder muss man ganz schön für rechts, links gehen?
Achso, nee, das Stadion. Das Stadion ist jetzt...
Das Stadion ist an so einer Steilklippe gebaut und ist halt eines der wenigen
größeren Stadien, die tatsächlich nur aus zwei Tribünen besteht.
Also hinter den Toren jeweils ist nichts.
Auf der einen Seite ist halt diese Steilklippe,
und sozusagen die Anzeigetafel. Und auf der anderen Seite ist halt einfach das
auslaufende Tal, sodass man von der Tribüne nicht nur auf den Fußballplatz schauen
kann, sondern eben auch so in die Weite gucken kann, wenn es denn nicht schon
so spät ist, dass die Sonne untergegangen ist.
Also ich will nicht den Eindruck erwecken, ich würde mich mit Fußball auskennen,
weil so ist es nämlich auch nicht. Aber für mich scheint das jetzt keine so große Tribüne zu sein.
Das unterschätzt du maßlos, das geht acht Stockwerke hoch, das ist richtig hoch,
also bis man da ganz oben ankommt und ich musste das tun und es gibt keinen Fahrstuhl,
da kommt man ganz schön ins Keuchen und wenn du auch mal genau hinschaust, das Besondere ist,
dass die beiden Tribünendächer sich sozusagen gegenseitig festhalten,
das heißt sie sind mit so Kabeln überspannt,
Das heißt, es ist mehr oder weniger ein durchgehendes Dach in gewisser Hinsicht.
Nur in der Mitte sind halt nur die Kabel freilaufend.
Und das ist aber so eine hängende Hängekonstruktion.
Können die dann noch so Plane drüber ziehen, wenn es regnet?
Nein.
Weil es sieht so aus, als wäre es genau dafür gebaut.
Oder Abschattung oder irgendwas.
Ja, also das ist aber auch mal wieder ein interessantes Beispiel.
Also ich meine, das ist natürlich grandiose Architektur aus rein konstruktiver Sicht.
Also mich würde es nervös machen, wenn ich da jetzt erzähle.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Von wann ist das Stadion?
Das Stadion ist gebaut worden, schauen wir mal, 2003 ist es eingeweiht worden.
Das ist noch relativ neu und ist halt...
Nach Berliner Rechnung hat es dann noch 30 Jahre.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Berliner Rechnung so ist. Wenn du mal hier die Bilder vom
Bau anschaust, dann siehst du, dass es doch sehr hoch geht.
Die Tribüne zieht sich sehr nach oben und es liegt halt sehr malerisch.
Also gut, ich habe bewiesen, dass ich mich nicht auskenne. Sehr gut.
Genau. Und das ist, ich weiß gar nicht, was ist die Kapazität dieses Stadions?
Die ist gar nicht mal so groß.
Steht das hier irgendwo? Das muss ja irgendwo stehen. 30.000.
Was im Wesentlichen jetzt wiederum daran liegt, dass es quasi ja nur zwei Tribünen
sind, weil du eben hinter dem Tor und auch an den Ecken nichts hast.
So, sieht also toll aus, architektonisch alles ganz O und A und man muss das
irgendwie von allen Winkeln fotografieren, wenn man da ist und das machen sich
ja auch eine ganze Menge Leute, selbst die, die da nicht zum Fußball gehen,
weil es halt einfach so ein architektonisches Kleinod ist.
Es ist aber leider als Stadion ein bisschen scheiße,
weil durch diese offene Bauweise geht halt sozusagen jeder Gesang einfach in
der Ferne verloren und du hast halt irgendwie nicht so diese Dichtheit eines Hexenkessels.
Die Stimmung ist halt innerkur.
Hält die Atmo nicht?
Ja, ist mehr so eine Hexenpfanne.
Eine Hexenpfanne.
Ja. Aber mit Kessel willst du halt irgendwie, brauchst halt hohe Wände,
damit das irgendwie auch alles...
Bubble, bubble, toil and trouble.
Genau. Naja, auf jeden Fall ist Praga ein sehr netter Ort und Praga ist vor
allem auch ein sehr netter Ort, um dort eine Konferenz zu besuchen oder dort abzuhalten.
Denn da ist es halt,
Ende März auch schon sehr angenehm mit den Temperaturen. Das war jetzt nicht
super warm, aber es war auf jeden Fall so. Portugal eben.
War T-Shirt warm.
Genau, war T-Shirt warm und ist eine sehr hübsche Stadt, kann man sagen.
Also ich empfehle das sehr. Aber du warst ja schon da, Ralf.
Erinnerst du dich daran?
Ja, genau. Also ich bin mit Claudia mal zwei Wochen komplett durch Portugal durch mit dem Auto.
Ganz vom Südosten bis zum Nordwesten.
und hatten wir schon vorhin beim Essen so eine der wenigen Ausreiselocations,
die ich mir vorstellen kann.
Also Portugal finde ich ein ganz tolles Land und in Braga waren wir dann nur ein paar Stunden.
Diese Treppe hoch, das ist so ungefähr, wer das kennt, Kassel,
Wilhelmshöhe, wenn man da so hoch läuft, so ungefähr in der Größenordnung ist das.
Also da hat man dann schon ordentlich was getan, wenn man dann da oben ist.
Na, da habt ihr ja noch die wunderschöne Altstadt verpasst.
Ja, durch die sind wir auch durchgelaufen. Also wir haben das schon immer versucht.
Da hatten wir noch keine Kinder, da hatten wir für sowas noch Zeit.
Da konnte man noch irgendwie vernünftige Sightseeing machen.
Verstehe.
Und ansonsten aber, sobald es um Porto geht, besonders Portugal sage,
Portugal geht, sage ich das immer für das Protokoll.
Ja, vergesst hier Dingenskirchen, Hauptstadt.
Portugal?
Ja, Lissabon, genau, vergesst Lissabon, geht nach Porto.
Das ist die schönste Stadt Europas. Diese Brücke, ein Wahnsinn,
das ist von einem der Schüler, die mit am Eiffelturm gebastelt haben und recherchiert das mal.
Europas wird es schwierig, würde ich sagen.
Also ich war auch gerade in der Stadt, von der ich bisher immer behauptet habe,
dass es die schönste Stadt Europas ist, aber das liegt ja dann,
wie es so schön heißt, immer auch im Auge des Betrachters.
Die da wäre?
Edinburgh.
Edinburgh. Na mein Favorit wäre jetzt Barcelona.
Echt?
Ja.
Also Barcelona rangiert bei mir echt immer so als Betonwüste.
Ich finde, das ist irgendwie,
Schachbrett. Also klar, da gibt es auch andere Ecken.
Schachbrettig ist es ein bisschen. Aber ansonsten fand ich das ganz nett.
Also gut, wir sind in einer sehr subjektiven Diskussion angelangt.
Das tut ja auch alles nix zur Sache.
Man könnte in Europa, glaube ich, noch 10, 20 andere Städte reinwerfen und sagen,
hier, das ist ja auch irgendwie alles ganz schick.
Allerdings finde ich, dass Edinburgh so ein bisschen mit diesem Vulkanfelsen
mitten in der Stadt, auf dem so dieses kolossale Schloss ist,
wo sich dann so diese pittoreske Altstadt dran ansiedelt, hat auf jeden Fall schon mal,
spielt auf jeden Fall schon mal so in der Top Ten.
Ja, das kann man so sagen. Ich war vor 30 Jahren oder so mal in Edinburgh,
nee ist sogar noch länger her und da hatten wir eine Kameramagiker besucht.
Die Kamera Obscura.
Kamera Obscura, genau. Und das war schon sehr, sehr witzig, das zu sehen.
Das ist oben direkt am Schloss so ein dunkler Raum, wo man dann irgendwie durchs Loch gucken kann.
Nee, die haben einen Spiegel, einen drehbaren Hohlspiegel, der fokussiert und
dann sitzt du da im Kreis um so eine Art runden Tisch und dann wird das, was draußen ist,
auf den Tisch projiziert, dadurch, dass du diese Hohlspiegel-Lochkamera gedönst da hast.
Man braucht mal ein bisschen, damit sich die Augen irgendwie an die Dunkelheit
gewöhnen, aber dann ist es faszinierend anzugucken, weil du wie mit so einem
Teleobjektiv einmal durch die ganze Stadt gucken kannst.
Also das kann ich empfehlen, das ist ganz lustig.
Genau, das von oben sozusagen. Genau, schön schick.
Ja, ja, Europa hat einiges zu bieten. Kann ich sehr empfehlen,
falls ihr auch gerade dabei seid, eure USA-Reisen zu streichen.
Dann Ich hatte keine geplant.
Ja, ich auch nicht, aber vielleicht gibt es ja Hörerinnen und Hörer,
die das durchaus auf dem Zettel hatten und nach Alternativen sich sehen.
Also Braga und Edinburgh kann man auf jeden Fall mal so eben besuchen,
ohne dass man irgendwie groß was verpasst.
Ja, aber warum war ich denn jetzt eigentlich da? Ich war auf der Alchemie oder
sagt man Alchemie? Konf?
Es ging also um Alchemie.
Also in Berlin sagt man Alchemie. Woanders nicht, glaube ich.
Alchemie. Konf. Ja, da war ich. Und da bist du ja schon, worum es geht.
Um Elixier, hab ich gesagt.
Genau, hab ich schon gesagt, stimmt.
Schon gespoilert.
Schon gespoilert, genau. Das ist nämlich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen mein Kink.
Ich finde das irgendwie sehr angenehm, mal auf so super vertikalen Themen einzusteigen.
weil es ja dann sozusagen vollkommen klar ist, was das Interesse aller ist da
gibt es dann irgendwie relativ,
wenig Diversität also in dieser Elixierwelt teilt sich das sozusagen eigentlich
nur in zwei Teile also entweder sind das halt so alte Erlang-Graubärte,
denen das schon immer genug war und dieses neumodische Zeug,
das brauchen wir gar nicht und die anderen 95% das sind halt alles dann so die,
hippen Elixier-Web-Developer, die ganz beglückt sind, dass sie das Licht gesehen haben.
Ja, und so ist dann halt auch so ein bisschen die Stimmung dort.
Ich finde das immer ganz gut, wenn man sich dann so Communities aufhält, die so.
Die wissen, was sie daran haben, wo sie sich da sozusagen gerade befinden und
so ein bisschen so immer dieses Living the Future Moment quasi so mit leben.
Das war dann auch sehr purzig, ich will auch gar nicht so viel drüber erzählen,
es war halt einfach eine Konferenz, wo es uns poemieren ging und was sie aber
sehr lustig gemacht haben, war so die Eröffnungsveranstaltung,
wo sie mit so einer fast leeren Bühne gestartet sind und dann kam irgendwie
so einer auf die Bühne getrabt und dann so, oh ja, wir brauchen eine Eröffnungsveranstaltung
wir haben ja noch gar kein Konzept, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Und dann hat sich dann sozusagen so ein theatralischer Dialog mit einer AI sozusagen
auf dieser Bühne entwickelt also nicht live mit einer AI, sondern sozusagen
gespielt wir reden jetzt mit der AI.
Oh, liebe AI, wir brauchen jetzt hier ein bisschen Dekoration auf der Bühne.
Und dann kamen sie die ganzen Props auf die Bühne gefahren und das war alles
sehr unterhaltsam. Ja, ja.
Ja, und da war ich dann zwei Tage und dann habe ich noch eine Woche durch England
und Schottland gedüst und jetzt bin ich wieder hier.
Ja.
Sind wir dann fertig?
Das war die Sendung 291.
Kommen wir noch zu den Updates. Ralf, ich sehe gerade was. Du hast Severance geguckt. Wow.
Genau, Update zur letzten Sendung. Wir erinnern uns, da hast du ja ein großes,
wirklich hoch angehängtes Loblied gesungen.
Gekündet habe ich.
Und ich hatte ja so ein bisschen die Gegenposition so, irgendwann mal,
das ist ja wirklich schon drei Jahre her, dass die erste Season rauskam und
damals die ersten drei Folgen geguckt und hat nicht gezündet, wir erinnern uns.
Und wie versprochen, habe ich
jetzt also mit Claudia das Ganze mal gebingewatched über die Feiertage.
Beide Seasons durch und fühle mich jetzt also auskunftsfähig.
Roddy hat eben schon gesagt, er hat sich jetzt auch schon vorbereitet zum Schauen,
aber noch nicht geguckt.
Das heißt, ich werde jetzt versuchen, es wieder irgendwie hinlänglich spoilerfrei zu halten.
Das ist schwierig, ja.
Und trotzdem irgendwie eine gewisse argumentative Plausibilität jetzt irgendwie reinzubringen.
Was, Roddy?
Mal schauen, ob das läuft.
Musst du jetzt keinen abbrechen wegen mir?
Ja, aber es gibt ja draußen ja vielleicht noch andere Hörerinnen und Hörer,
die das noch vor sich haben.
Da ist immer die Frage, wann ist dann eigentlich so der Punkt, ab dem man,
spoilern darf.
Ab dem man sagen darf, dass Darth Vader der Vater von...
Nein!
Dumbledore dies on page 573. Habt ihr damals die T-Shirts gesehen?
Das war schon echt fies. Das war Harry Potter Band 6.
Es gab dann Dumbledore stirbt, die große Vaterfigur von Harry Potter.
Und dann gab es wirklich Arschlöcher, die mit T-Shirts rumgelaufen sind.
Dumbledore dies on page 573.
Das war schon gemein.
So, also wann ist der richtige Zeitpunkt? Also Season 2 ist ja jetzt noch relativ
frisch. Das heißt, die letzte Folge war glaube ich vor drei,
vier Wochen oder sowas. Noch gar nicht so lange her.
Oder? Ja.
Season Final wäre. Das ist definitiv zu frisch, um jetzt zu sagen.
Das ist schon, kann man hier schon als Gemeingut setzen, von daher.
Bemühe ich mich da jetzt nach Kräften, aber so ein paar Dinge muss man natürlich trotzdem ansprechen.
Ja, mal so, irgendeiner wird immer leiden. Also wenn man halt zu spät auf der
Party ankommt, dann Naja, dann ist halt irgendwie das eine oder andere gelaufen.
But ja, Hugs are available on request.
Genau, es gibt Kapitelmarken. Ihr könnt ja auch einfach vorspringen,
wenn ihr meint. Die Gefahr ist zu groß.
Also wo wir, glaube ich, sofort irgendwie diverse Haken hinter machen können,
ist das, was du letzte Sendung auch schon gesagt hast.
Also diese ganzen formalen Dinge, die Ästhetik, die Farbgebung,
die Kameraeinstellungen, die Musik, die Fonts.
Ich mag in der Tat diese Schrift sehr, sehr gerne. Also die Ikonografie und sowas.
Also vom Style-Faktor her würde ich mal sagen, ist das sicherlich totale Champions
League, die da abgeliefert wird. Gar keine Frage.
Und was ich auch durchaus gutieren kann, ist, dass sie in der zweiten Season
deutlich experimentierfreudiger werden. Ähm,
Also das ist erstmal eine Serie, die sich glaube ich sehr dafür anbietet,
dass man binge-watcht so und nicht jeweils irgendwie eine Woche oder länger
warten musste von Folge zu Folge und schon gar nicht nach dem Cliffhanger von
das Episode des Season 1 Finales drei Jahre warten muss, bis dann die Geschichte weitergeht.
Also das ist schon eine harte Strafe.
Und auch da kann man sicherlich einen Haken drunter machen. Das Season Final
von der ersten Season ist fantastisch.
Und ich würde sagen, das von der zweiten ist auch fantastisch.
Aus ganz unterschiedlichen Gründen. Aber das funktioniert beides schon sehr, sehr gut.
Und wie gesagt, dass sie in der zweiten Season sehr viel experimentierfreudiger sind.
Was erzählen wir jetzt gerade hier für eine Geschichte und welche Perspektive
haben wir jetzt hier und jetzt werden wir mal in einer ganzen Folge mal nur
dieser einen Perspektive und alles andere wird komplett ausgeblendet.
Das mag ich alles ganz gerne.
Jetzt gibt es aber drei Punkte, die mich dann jetzt auch nach komplett durchschauen
immer noch interessieren.
ziemlich stören, muss ich sagen.
Du hast nicht verstanden, worum es geht.
Nee, ich glaube, ich bin, ich habe jetzt nicht komplett Reddit geflutet,
aber ich habe nebenbei zwei Recap-Blogs durchgelesen.
Das hilft auf jeden Fall sehr.
Und hatte danach aber auch den Eindruck, okay, 80 Prozent hatte ich schon beim Schauen verstanden.
Aber es gibt so viele kleine Details. Es ist so reich an hier nochmal eine Andeutung
und da nochmal was. Das ist einfach irre.
Ja, aber da sind wir auch schon ein bisschen bei den Problemzonen des Ganzen.
Also das Erste, was mich schon rasend macht, ist wirklich diese Langsamheit.
Also ich bin ja jetzt nur auch ein älteres Remester und ich bin nun wahrlich
nicht auf, ich kann nur noch YouTubes Clips gucken, die sonst wie gecuttet sind.
Ja und 2001 habe ich null Schwierigkeiten, das mir zu geben.
Ich bin aber der festen Überzeugung, wenn man Severance sagen wir mal ein Drittel
schneller geschnitten hätte, wäre eine bessere Serie dabei rausgekommen.
Ich kann es einfach nicht über Gebühr feiern, wenn du eine 150-Sekunden-Einstellung
hast, wo jemand durch weiße Räume läuft.
Also gefühlt ist ein Viertel der ganzen Serie nur dadurch, dass Leute durch
diese weißen Gänge laufen.
Und das einfach ein Drittel einkürzen. Das hätte echt der Sache nichts weggenommen.
Musik-Video-Generation.
Ja, also wie gesagt, eigentlich bin ich da glaube ich unverdächtig.
Aber ich meine, die Bedrückung, die das auslöst, ist ja auch Teil der Erzählung.
Ja, ich verstehe das alles, aber...
Kann man so sehen, kann man anders sehen.
Mich hat es dann nicht so reingezogen, sondern ich fange dann an, auf die Uhr zu gucken.
Und dann ist das Wirkungsziel halt irgendwie nicht erreicht an der Stelle.
So, der zweite Punkt, das mag jetzt aber eine individuelle Geschichte sein.
ich konnte auch nach Season 2 mit den Charakteren nicht so richtig,
So und das tut mir ein bisschen leid. Das hätte ich gerne anders gehabt,
weil das, was ich da so lese, dass die Leute also Nervenzusammenbrüche bekommen
und in Tränen ausbrechen und sowas.
Ich war bis zum Schluss der ganzen Sache gegenüber relativ distanzlos.
Also ob sich da jetzt jemand kriegt oder ob sich jemand in die Haare bekommt
oder was dort irgendwie mit den Leuten passiert.
Das hat mich sehr interessiert. Ich fand das interessant und spannend,
aber es hat mich emotional nicht abgeholt.
Wer fängt da an zu weinen? Zuschauer.
Zuschauer, ja.
Es gibt ja hier Reacts to Videos und sowas alles, wo die Leute völlig durchdrehen bei diversen Szenen so.
Und das ist bei mir ungewöhnlich, weil ich normalerweise total dicht am Wasser gebaut bin.
Ich flenne sofort los, wenn irgendwo was einigermaßen melancholisch.
Emotional ist.
Das ist nicht so flennen, aber ich bin super Fan von Rome Cons,
Schmonzetten, Boy Meets Girl. Habt ihr mich sofort.
Ich feiere das.
Ich feiere genau, dass es das nicht ist.
Ja, aber solche Momente gibt es dann dort ja dann eben auch und die lösen dann
bei mir aber nichts aus und das ist ungewöhnlich für mich so.
Das kann ich jetzt erstmal nur beschreiben und habe noch gar nicht so im Detail
durchanalysiert, warum das eigentlich so ist.
So und der dritte Punkt und das ist aber eigentlich das Entscheidende und ich
glaube, da ist unsere Wahrnehmung dann wahrscheinlich am weitesten auseinander. Ich finde...
Bei allem, was sie so versuchen, an Plottwist und an originellen Ideen zu verbauen,
sind sie am Ende doch sehr konventionell unterwegs.
Also die Geschichte, die sie
da erzählen, ist erstmal von der Grundkonstruktion her super cool gebaut,
aber sie bleiben eigentlich immer innerhalb ihrer eigenen Erzählung und kommen
niemal auf so eine Meta-Ebene raus, um mal einen echten Perspektivwechsel irgendwo hinzulegen.
Das führte dann auch dazu, dass so von den drei, vier Big Reveals,
die das Ganze hat über die zweite Season, Claudia und ich, glaube ich,
mindestens drei vorher gesehen haben und gesagt haben, hier, das ist genau so.
Und dann zwei Folgen später kam es dann auch genau so. Also es ist.
Finde ich, vom ganzen Erzählen her nicht weder wirklich radikal,
noch, glaube ich, auch wirklich clever.
Und ich weiß, ich nerve da vielleicht einige draußen. Ich bin halt ein Lost-Kind.
So, ich halte also für, was Narrative angeht, für Erzählstrukturen halte ich
Lost für den heiligen Gral der Seriengeschichte.
Und es interessiert mich überhaupt nicht, ob das Finale gut war und ob die letzte
Season funktioniert hat.
Was die vorher machen. Nur mal ein Beispiel, was zwischen Season 1 und Season 2 in Lost passiert.
So, das ist lange genug abgehangen, dass man spoilern kann. So,
das Grundsetting von Season 1 Lost ist, Flugzeug bricht in der Luft auseinander.
Stürzt auf eine Insel ab, Leute müssen überleben.
So, da passieren dann Dinge, aber das ist das Grundsetting.
So und man kommt also super dicht an diese ganzen Figuren ran und hat dann viele
Rückblenden, lernt die kennen und lernt die lieben und mit jedem einzelnen aus
dem Cast habe ich super gebondet im Gegensatz hier zu Severance.
So, dann kommt Season 2, stellt sich hin und sagt, hm, habt ihr nicht eigentlich was vergessen?
Dieses Flugzeug ist in zwei Teile abgestürzt. Was ist eigentlich aus dem zweiten
Teil geworden? Interessiert euch das gar nicht?
So, hm, äh, okay. So, was passiert?
Season 2 bist du erstmal fünf oder sechs Folgen lang mit dem Trupp aus der hinteren
Hälfte des Flugzeugs unterwegs.
Du kennst keinen von denen. Das ist quasi eine komplett neue Serie,
die anfängt. Völlig neue Charaktere, die haben ganz andere Chemie, ganz andere Settings.
Und du bist total sauer, weil es ist nicht die Geschichte, die du sehen willst.
Du willst auch sehen, wie es mit deinen Helden aus der ersten Season weitergeht.
So, und dann, weil die aber einfach geil geschrieben ist, diese Serie,
lernst du die dann eben auch lieben.
So, und dann clashen diese beiden Trupps zusammen, treffen sich quasi in der
Mitte der Insel, jetzt vereinfacht gesprochen.
Und dann hast du plötzlich einen totalen Loyalitätskonflikt,
ja, weil du nämlich jetzt schon mit deinem eingetrübten Blick aus der zweiten
Crew auch wieder auf deine eigentlich geliebte erste Crew drauf guckst und siehst
so, okay, so ganz koscher ist das wirklich alles hier gar nicht.
So, und solche Konstruktion macht Lost bei jeder einzelnen Season.
Ja, dass sie also wirklich einen sehr radikalen Perspektivwechsel reingeben
und alles, was du quasi bisher glaubtest, was dort funktioniert und warum die
Sachen wie funktionieren, das habe ich bei keiner anderen Serie in der Güte gesehen.
Und demgegenüber ist Severance eigentlich dann sehr geradlinig.
Ja, eben gegenüber dem so, wie gehe ich mit den Charakteren um und das eine
oder andere Überraschende passiert, man kriegt ein bisschen Backstory und die
ganze Lore wird ein bisschen aufgebaut und so, aber das haben wir schon anders gesehen.
Ja gut, da hast du auch sechs Staffeln gesehen. Jetzt haben wir hier gerade mal zwei.
Das lässt ja noch Raum für Erweiterung.
Und ich habe schon so den einen oder anderen Konflikt jetzt auch gerade zum
Ende der zweiten Staffel entwickelt,
weil du ja auf einmal innerhalb derselben Person dich zwischen Inni und Auti
irgendwie entscheiden musst.
Also das sind schon so Elemente mit drin.
Aber man kann das jetzt bewerten, ich will das auch gar nicht groß diskutieren,
zumal es jetzt eh ein bisschen absurd ist, die ganze Zeit nur in Andeutungen
über so eine Serie zu reden.
Und alle, die wissen, was wir meinen, die mal mögen uns zustimmen und alle anderen
denken sich nur so, ist jetzt das, die Freakshow ist jetzt nur noch vier Stunden
rumgeeiert und wir kommen nicht mehr zum Punkt. Ja, kann schon sein.
Als ob es vorher anders gewesen wäre.
Du kannst ja mal sagen, wie das für dich ist. Hat das jetzt irgendein Interesse
erzeugt, dass du sowas sehen willst oder denkst du dir nur so,
ach diese Leute, die immer Fernsehserien gucken, ist doch irgendwie alles Quatsch.
Mein Problem ist, dass ich in die meisten Fernsehserien einfach nicht reinkomme.
Da gucke ich dann irgendwie drei Episoden oder auch nur anderthalb und dann
geht es mir auf den Sack und dann war es das irgendwie.
Ja, ich kann das auch nachvollziehen. Mir geht das mit manchen Serien halt auch so.
Ich hatte ja Severance deshalb ausgepickt, weil ich eben der Meinung bin, das ist jetzt mal,
Wirklich mal so eine Nummer, da sollte man die ersten drei Episoden dann vielleicht
doch mal auch durchhalten.
Und Ralf, du kannst mir jetzt nicht sagen, das hätte sich jetzt nicht gelohnt.
Es hat sich natürlich gelohnt. Es hat aber auch nicht diesen Effekt,
den ich hier bei, na wie hieß da die Mars-Serie, die ich da auch schon mal besprochen hatte.
Die Mars-Serie.
Hier diese Hard-Sci-Fi-Szene mit den Erden.
Ihr Chat hilft doch mal kurz hier. Die von allen Gehypte.
Nee, nicht For All Mankind älter.
Also ich kann nur über For All Mankind sprechen und da muss ich sagen,
dass ich echt zu viele Episoden gesehen habe, weil ich fand das richtig schlecht.
Irgendwie war das nur, Leute brüllen sich an. Mehr war es einfach nicht.
The Expanse, da hatte ich ja die These aufgestellt, man muss die ersten drei
Folgen durchhalten, weil dann ab Nummer vier bekommt man eine komplett andere Serie präsentiert.
Ich habe es glaube ich auch nur bis zur dritten geschafft.
Ja, ab der vier geht diese Serie wirklich los und das ist bei Severance anders.
Das heißt also, wenn man da schon mit den ersten zwei, drei Folgen überhaupt
nicht irgendwie connected, sollte man sich nicht zu viele Hoffnungen machen, dass es anders wird.
Also es passiert natürlich noch vieles und sie haben, glaube ich,
ich habe auch ein paar Interviews gelesen hier mit dem Writer, der hat ein totales...
Lost-Paranoia, das ihm hinterher vorgeworfen wird. Er hätte so viele Mysteries-Box
aufgemacht und dann nicht wieder geschlossen und Dinge nicht genug erklärt.
Und da würde ich mal sagen, das machen sie wirklich schon sehr gut.
Die erklären ja wirklich viel.
Also es sind immer noch nach Ende von Season 2 sind noch Sachen ungeklärt,
aber sehr vieles ist dann auch schon einigermaßen gut interpretierbar von dem,
was da so passiert ist. Das finde ich wieder auch ganz gut.
Aber ja, also es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall zu gucken.
alleine um irgendwie mitreden zu können muss man das glaube ich schon gesehen
haben und wie gesagt alleine von der ganzen Machart und Design her ist es natürlich
schon jetzt total stilbildend und Kult und es gibt auch wirklich sehr sehr viele kultige,
Einzelszenen, das muss man auch sagen, das ist ja auch ein riesiger Memengenerator
Absolut Es gibt wirklich Sequenzen, die sind natürlich wirklich zum Schreien
gut Also im Finale alleine die,
Elevator-Szene da habe ich mich echt eine Minute nicht eingekriegt vor Freude.
Das ist so eine lustige Idee, was sie da machen.
Also da passieren schon auch wirklich sehr, sehr schöne Dinge. Gar keine Frage.
Vor allem die musikalischen Einlagen sind immer sehr speziell.
Aber es ist kein zweites Twin Peaks und es ist kein zweites.
Es ist, naja, aber es ist auf jeden Fall, es ist es selbst, es ist Severance
und ich glaube, da werden sich so einige dran,
messen müssen. Und ich würde auch sagen, die T-Shirt-Qualität der Quotes ist sehr hoch.
Was mich ein bisschen gewundert hat, ich habe mal versucht rauszukriegen,
so der Writer, was das eigentlich für ein Typ ist, der hat ja vorher praktisch gar nichts gemacht.
Ist das eigentlich noch irgendein Meta-Hoax, der noch irgendwann mal aufgedeckt wird?
Also der hat wirklich nichts vorher im Bereich Serien, Film,
Writer auf dem Kerbholz gehabt. Das finde ich schon Denn irgendwas.
Ne?
Finde ich schon bemerkenswert.
Wie heißt der? Denn?
Nee.
Regie?
Regie ist ja Ben Stiller, der ist ja auch, also zumindest der meisten Folgen. Die haben glaube ich.
Im falschen Severance gerade gelandet.
So Dan Erickson.
Genau, Dan Erickson.
Die Bilder von ihm erlebt, aber er hat nichts getan.
Vorher. So und das dann so aus dem Start als Erstlingswerk, als Writer.
Na guter Start würde ich sagen.
Finde ich schon verdächtig, wenn es dann gleichzeitig um so ein Material geht.
Ja, ich meine, man hatte auch, glaube ich, Ben Stiller nicht unbedingt jetzt
so als Regisseur auf dem Schirm für so ein Ding, weil er ja dann eigentlich
eher aus diesem Comedy-Bereich kommt.
Und man, also auch wenn es durchaus lustige Szenen gibt in Serens,
aber unter Comedy läuft das nun wirklich mal gar nicht.
Naja, lassen wir uns überraschen.
Mal gucken, vielleicht wird das jetzt auch eher zu teuer in den USA,
alles irgendwie noch weiter zu produzieren und wir kriegen gar nichts mehr. Who knows?
Na gut, machen wir die Fernsehabteilung erstmal zu.
Das Einzige, was ich noch berichten kann, ich war mit meinen Kids in einen Minecraft-Film.
Oh ja, ich auch.
Ich fand den sehr lustig.
Du fandst den sehr lustig?
Ja, er war schön bunt, er war schön drüber.
Ich muss sagen, der Film, das ist die Kategorie, also dieser Film hat mir erstmal
gesagt, dass der Film war nicht für mich gemacht. Ganz offensichtlich.
Ja gut, das war er für mich auch nicht.
Ich habe im Nachhinein verstanden, für wen er gemacht ist. Ich kann das allerdings
nicht ausreichend als Entschuldigung annehmen.
Weil der Film ist ja an sich eine totale Beleidigung.
Also es ist ja einfach, man wird ja verhöhnt geradezu als Zuschauer.
Wieso? Ja, weil der so furchtbar schlecht ist.
Also das war wirklich der schlechteste Film, den ich.
Ich habe Schwierigkeiten, mich zurückzuerinnern an irgendetwas,
was mich so angekotzt hat die ganze Zeit. Der Film war einfach nur scheiße.
Er war laut, es war ein einziges Geschrei.
Die ganze Story wurde nur abgespult, da gab es überhaupt keinen Twist,
nichts hat sich irgendwie entwickelt.
alles wurde irgendwie einfach so runter erzählt und fand irgendwie statt und
im Nachhinein habe ich dann verstanden so dass der Joke ist,
dass er halt total überfüllt ist mit Anspielungen
auf irgendwelche Streamer die teilweise da auch in Persona in diesem Film auftreten
und dass die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Memes aus dieser Minecraft-Fan-Gemeinde
gemacht wird und die Kids drehen total durch und machen da jetzt so eine Rocky
Horror Picture Show-Geschichte draus und explodieren da und schmeißen mit Popcorn durch die Gegend,
weil es ist halt einfach so unglaublich finden und da muss ich sagen,
da habe ich dann auch glaube ich das Alter erreicht, wo ich mir denke,
die Jugend von heute weiß ja nicht mehr, was gut ist und das kann ja wohl nicht
euer Ernst sein und früher haben wir das noch anders gemacht.
Also ganz ehrlich, dieser Film hat mich in so einen totalen aggressiven Scheißezustand
gebracht und ich fand einfach alles katastrophal schlecht.
Also ich meine, handlungsmäßig war er jetzt tatsächlich nicht so,
das Größte der Welt. Aber ich fand erstens die Typen geil und zweitens mal fand
ich einfach schön, mit welcher Liebe diese Minecraft-Welt gemacht hat.
Also das fand ich, das hatte was.
Irgendwie die Piglins und einfach diese ganze Welt, die man sonst halt nur so
als blockige Welt kennt, so richtig in Kulisse gebaut zu sehen,
das fand ich schon sehr, sehr geil, muss ich sagen.
Ja, aber wie kann man in den ersten drei Minuten des Films im Prinzip schon die ganze...
Alles wegspoilern, es gibt keinerlei Entdeckungsmoment, keine Einführung,
kein grandioses, mysteriöses Herausfinden, dass es diese Welt überhaupt gibt.
Sondern nein, da kommt so ein Typ und so, ja, ich hab das und das gemacht und
dann war ich da, pling, plump und dann war ich auch auf dieser Welt und dann
irgendwie einmal alles durcherzählt.
Einfach um erstmal so ein bisschen Fakten zu schaffen. und dann finden Sachen
nur noch statt und es explodiert die ganze Zeit irgendwas und Leute rennen schreiend,
brüllen einen die ganze Zeit an.
Entschuldigung, ich bin wirklich vollkommen frustriert.
Das ist jetzt ungefähr so, als würdest du dich beschweren, wenn ein Film die
Schlümpfe heißt, das nicht großartig eingeführt wird, warum es da Schlümpfe gibt.
Tim, ich habe das alles vorher auch gelesen und mein Erwartungshorizont war
so auf minus 30 und entsprechend konnte ich da also nicht mehr so hart enttäuscht werden.
Weil ich das alles Ich bin da auch mit minus 30 rein, aber ich bin bei minus 100.
Rausgekommen Weil ich das also alles schon eingepreist hatte.
Also ich finde beide Ebenen haben recht. Wir spielen zu Hause wirklich sehr viel Minecraft.
Ich hatte es hier berichtet, wir haben eine eigene Welt und spielen da zu viert
auf unserer Familieninsel und bauen Kram und meine Kiddies gucken sehr viel
zu viel YouTube-Videos von Minecraft-Leuten, die dort also sonst was immer aushacken
und bauen das dann nach, was dann wiederum irgendwie ganz cool ist.
So, ich würde sagen, wir haben so 70 bis 80 Prozent der ganzen Anspielungen
haben wir live und in Echtzeit dechiffriert und auf der Ebene funktioniert dieser
Film wirklich ziemlich gut.
Das heißt also, es wird schon eine Menge gezeigt, womit man sofort weiß,
warum ist das jetzt da so und wie ist das da so.
Ich bin aber schon bei Tim, dass ich während des Filmes einen einen harten schmerz hatte,
Warum? Es wäre, glaube ich, nicht schwierig gewesen, daraus einfach mal einen
vernünftig brauchbaren, guten Film zu machen und all das andere trotzdem zu haben.
Die liebevolle 3D-Welt und die ganzen Anspielungen. Trotzdem,
ja und dieses Storytelling, da hat Tim einfach völlig recht.
Also dass da einfach die Exposition in den ersten zwei Minuten,
die ist so bescheuert, so eine Geschichte zu erzählen. Als Dr.
Herr der Ringe anfängst mit, so, also Frodo hat ja den Ring,
hat ja gewonnen und den Ring in den Vulkan geworfen und jetzt erzähle ich euch
nochmal ein bisschen die langweilige Geschichte davor.
Das hätte, und dann fangen vor
allem alle Echtzeit in der Echtwelt Geschichten waren dann viel zu lang.
Die ersten 20 Minuten ziehen sich da wirklich bescheuert hin.
Das hätte man irgendwie viel anders.
So, also da wäre, glaube ich, mit überschaubarem Aufwand mehr drin gewesen.
Ich möchte mal zwei vergleichbare Filme nennen, wo das viel besser funktioniert.
Das eine ist der Super Mario Film, habe ich auch schon mal kurz gesagt.
Mit dem können wir gleich nochmal separat besprechen, ja.
So, also der macht das nämlich auch mit diesen ganzen Insider-Geschichten,
ja, aber hat entwickelt einen ganz anderen Flow und eine ganz andere Dynamik
und trotzdem kannst du deine Haken dran machen, wie du alle Welten und alle Charaktere und,
mein totales und das zweite Beispiel sind die Lego-Movies die beiden,
die ich als Film selber eigentlich scheiße finde, die aber ein jeweils fantastisches Ende haben,
das heißt also wenn ihr irgendwie mal so Richtung Sixth Sense oder,
ähnliches mal wieder so einen richtigen What-the-Fuck-Moment haben wollt dann
müsst ihr euch die Lego-Movies angucken.
Die liefern da wirklich ab. Und zwar nicht nur in Bezug auf,
da passiert was Überraschendes und XY ist gar nicht der, die wir dachten,
sondern da wird das durchexerziert, was ich bei Severance eben eingefordert habe,
auf eine Meta-Ebene den Film hochzuholen, die so fantastisch und genial ist,
dass du dir denkst, boah, ihr seid so cool, Leute, was ihr hier gerade macht.
Was heißt denn die Lego-Movies?
Also es gibt Lego-Movie 1 und 2. Und die haben beide ja, da habe ich mir todsicher,
weil ich habe sie bestimmt 15 Mal mit meinen Kids gesehen.
Ich versuche das hier gerade nur in der Wikipedia nachzuvollziehen.
Lego The Movie Teil 1 und dann ein paar Jahre später kam Teil 2.
Und Teil 2 würde ich sagen, ist als Film sogar insgesamt besser als Teil 1.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich den gesehen habe, um ehrlich zu sein.
Die haben wiederum das andere Problem, dass die Filme dazwischen mich total
annerven, weil das viel zu hyperaktiv und alles gleichzeitig und laut und bunt und so.
Aber das Ende und die Grundgeschichte, die dann eigentlich erzählt wird,
die ist für so eine Art Film völlig fantastisch. Und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
auch sowas hätte man mit dem Thema Minecraft gut hinbekommen können.
Ja.
Und sie versuchen es ja dieses, es gibt ja quasi so eine Line,
die versucht das Ganze zusammenzuhalten.
Ja, erschaffen ist schwieriger als zerstören und darum sind das meistens auch
die Cleveren, die erschaffen und sowas.
Aus diesem Grundthema von Minecraft hätte man glaube ich einen sehr coolen Metaplot spinnen können.
Machen müssen hätte man das. Man hätte es tun müssen und es ist nicht getan
worden und ich empfinde das wirklich als eine Beleidigung und deswegen bin ich
auch gar nicht bereit, weiter über diesen Film zu reden, aber,
Special Mention nochmal.
Der Super Mario Film ist fantastisch.
Also wie du schon sagtest, das hat alles erfüllt, da bin ich mit plus 30 reingegangen
und mit plus 100 rausgegangen,
weil da, also abgesehen davon, dass es von der ganzen Zeichnung und so weiter
ist, es ist alles da und es wird einfach von Anfang an spannend,
eine schlüssige Herleitung, warum es überhaupt Super Mario gibt.
ja, diese Klempner-Existenz sein Bruder wo diese Welt auf einmal auftaucht und,
bim, bim, bim, jedes kleinste Detail, jeder Pixel irgendwie in deinem Spiel,
wird irgendwann poppt in diesem Film auf, aber nicht einfach mit so reinschmeißen
und dann liegt das da so rum sondern es ist eigentlich mit jedem Detail immer
so eine witzige, kleine Geschichte noch mit dran und so eine Erklärung und so eine Herleitung,
es ist einfach wahnsinnig gut.
Also wer den noch nicht gesehen hat, ja, also Minecraft Movie, spart es euch wirklich.
Auch nicht wegen ich muss mir das angucken, weil keine Ahnung,
Selbstkasteiung ist wieder angesagt oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
Oder ich werde ja gezwungen oder meine Kinder wollten das unbedingt.
Erspart das einfach euren Kindern.
Also meine Kinder fanden es super. So um sechs und acht Jahre und die sind da auch voll abgegangen.
Ja, meine Kids fanden es auch ziemlich gut, glaube ich.
Ja
Die Zielgruppe sind halt einfach
Kiddies, die den ganzen Tag diese YouTube-Videos zu Minecraft gucken.
Das ist die Hauptzielgruppe.
Das sind glaube ich nicht wenige.
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Der macht ja auch irgendwie riesen Umsatz,
aber es macht mich einfach fassungslos.
Da entfernt man sich einfach von der Welt und denkt sich so,
ja, okay, gut, das ist jetzt halt eine neue Welt, die hat mit mir nichts mehr zu tun.
Das ist ja so ein separates Universum, was sich abspaltet und wir können da
nicht dran teilnehmen. Aber es geht auch anders.
Es gibt sozusagen das große, einigende Projekt und das ist definitiv dieser
Super Mario Film, der einfach herzlich ist, geile Story hat,
spannend ist, die ganze Zeit lustig ist, alles erklärt, wunderbar gezeichnet ist,
wirklich toll, auch musikalisch alles aufnimmt, was sozusagen diese Mario-Welt
ausmacht, aber nie so billig, sondern immer nice.
Also es ist einfach toll.
Ich bin ein großer Fan von Super Mario und ich muss sagen, Minecraft,
sorry, vielleicht erklärt das auch, warum ich selbst Minecraft selber auch nie
so richtig einen Zugang gefunden habe.
Aber ich fremde immer noch mit Minecraft.
Ich habe es nie verstanden.
Würde ich sagen, ist nicht zu Unrecht das erfolgreichste Spiel aller Zeiten.
Ist es?
Ja. Bei far.
Bei what measure?
Bei measures of Szenapotenzen. Muss man eben gucken.
Was ist da die Einheit? Was ist denn erfolgreich?
Spieler pro Jahr? irgendwie sowas.
Ja, überhaupt auch Länge des Spiels an sich, wie lange es das gibt,
wie lange es tatsächlich auch die Leute bei der Stange hält und so weiter.
Ich meine, Minecraft ist halt das Spiel, was Lego hätte mal machen sollen.
Also das ist so.
Ja, okay, good point.
So, also es gibt einen Wikipedia-Artikel zur Liste der erfolgreichsten Computerspiele,
und da ist Minecraft auf Nummer 1 mit 300 Millionen verkauften Einheiten.
Okay, also Verkäufe.
Und Platz 2 ist GTA 5 mit 210.000.
Also ich habe die Größenordnung drunter und dann Tetris mit 100.000 und dann
sind wir schon bei unter 100.000. Also das ist schon...
Okay, verkaufte Einheiten ist natürlich ein brauchbarer Metrum,
solange man keine Free-to-Play-Spiele beguckt.
Oder so Service-Games oder sowas in der Art.
Aber ich glaube auch gegen viele Service-Games, die lange gelaufen sind.
Also ich meine, World of Warcraft gibt es wahrscheinlich immer noch, keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall auch nicht unerfolgreich.
Laut Halifax im Chat ist Chat-GPT der Meinung, dass das nicht bei World of Warcraft
so sei. Aber was weiß Chat-GPT schon?
Ja, Fakten, nicht Chat-GPT.
Ja, naja gut, also ist schwierig.
Also ich denke, man kann festhalten, dass Minecraft mit Sicherheit,
also wenn es nicht das populärste Spiel ist, dann ist es auf jeden Fall ein
Anwärter für das populärste Spiel.
Und populär würde ich halt jetzt auch wirklich festmachen an,
ist es so ein Forever Game? Also und das scheint es mir ja zu sein.
Also Minecraft findet immer wieder neue Kunden quasi.
Ja, ich denke schon. immer wieder neue Spieler und andere Spiele sind dann halt
auch irgendwann raus aus der Zeit.
Also diese Zeitlosigkeit, das ist da.
Und ich wollte das jetzt auch nicht, ich hab auch gar nichts gegen Minecraft,
das ist halt einfach nur, ihr kennst ja, meine Schwäche mit Spielen ist,
ich weiß nicht, mir fehlt da irgendein Gen, ich kann mich einfach mit Spielen
nicht so lange beschäftigen.
Also es kommt drauf an, für mich ist Minecraft auch kein Spiel.
Ich kann verstehen, was die Leute daran finden, die etwas daran finden,
das kann ich gut nachvollziehen, aber für mich ist es halt nix,
weil so Sandbox- Spiele sind sowieso nie so mein Ding gewesen.
Trotzdem, ich meine, man muss Minecraft mal zugutehalten, dass sie ein Genre
begründet haben und eigentlich immer noch der einzige Player in dem Genre sind.
Also das ist schon, das musst du mal hinkriegen.
Ja, also für mich ist es einfach das absolut perfekte Familienspiel.
Hatte ich ja schon vor anderthalb Jahren oder sowas mal ausführlich in der Sendung.
Ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal hier meinen Artikel Minecraft in der Familie spielen.
So, macht das überhaupt pädagogisch Sinn und was muss man technisch machen und
sowas. Habe ich mich immer ein bisschen länger zu ausgelassen.
Ja, also ich spiele das jetzt halt auch schon, glaube ich, zwei Jahre mit meiner kompletten Familie.
Und es ist halt wirklich so, du, morgens beim Frühstückstisch werden schon Ideen aus Baldowat,
was man dann abends nach der Schule und nach der Arbeit gemeinsam in der Welt
irgendwie bauen möchte und erforschen möchte.
Und Papa geht wieder auf Reise und nimmt seine Karten mit. Und die Jungs bleiben
zu Hause und zittern, ob er wohl Leben zurückkommt. und so.
Sowas hat einfach kein anderes Spiel da draußen, dass du also bis zu einem gewissen
Grad auch wirklich so einen,
Lebenssimulator irgendwo hast an der Stelle, wo du auch als Familie dich wohlfühlen
kannst und einen Modus findest, wo jeder irgendwie so seine Rolle hat und auch
der Kleinste kann schon irgendwie anfangen nach Gold zu schürfen und Dias zu meinen.
Wie ich gesagt habe, also ich kann das total gut nachvollziehen,
dass die Leute das geil finden. Für mich selber ist es nix.
Okay, halten wir fest, the game is mysterious and important.
Ja, ist it.
Alright.
Womit wollen wir denn mal weitermachen?
Ja.
Wo wir schon bei Super Mario und Klempnern waren.
Das ist jetzt eine sehr holprige Überleitung.
Gar nicht so, finde ich.
Guten Vorn.
Also, kleiner Nebenkriegsschauplatz. Bei mir wurde ja eine Wärmepumpe installiert.
Das haben die Jungs auch weitestgehend gut gemacht.
Haben ein bisschen Verwüstung im Garten hinterlassen.
Was wahrscheinlich nicht auf deren Kappe ging, aber trotzdem nicht mehr funktionierte,
als ich versucht habe, das wieder in Gang zu setzen.
Am Anfang der, wie soll ich sagen, Gartensaison ist das Hauswasserwerk, das ich im Keller habe.
Ich glaube, du musst da bei mir jetzt echt bei den Basics anfangen.
Was genau macht ein Hauswasserwerk?
Hauswasserwerk. Man stelle sich vor eine einigermaßen gute Pumpe,
die aus einem Brunnen oder aus einer anderen, aus einer Zisterne oder so Wasser hochpumpen kann.
Wo ist dieser Brunnen bei dir?
Der Brunnen ist bei mir im Prinzip ein Loch unter dem Haus.
Dafür gegraben oder war es schon vorher da?
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen, weil ich habe das so gebraucht.
Entweder du hast es gegraben oder es war schon da.
Es war schon da, als ich das Haus erworben habe. Um...
Dazu kommt ein Druckausgleichstank, sowas, was auch so ein normaler Heizkreislauf hat.
Das ist so ein pillenförmiges, größeres Ding mit einer Gummiwand in der Mitte
und auf der einen Seite ist ein Ventil,
wo man Pressluft reindrücken kann und dann kann dieses Gerät einen Wasserdruck halten.
Dadurch.
Dass da quasi Luftdruck in die Gummiwand….
Um das Wasser aus dem Keller eben auch in den zweiten Stock irgendwie hochzukriegen.
Und der Trick am Hauswasserwerk ist, die dritte Komponente ist ein Druckfühler,
der die Pumpe ein- und ausschalten kann.
So, wenn man die drei Dinge kombiniert, dann bekommt man ein Gerät, was in der Lage ist,
wenn du da sagen wir, du schließt deinen Wasserhahn an und schaltest das Ding
ein, dann pumpt das Wasser, bis das Wasser einen bestimmten Druck hat.
Und dann schaltet es sich wieder aus. Jetzt kannst du an den Wasserhahn gehen,
Wasser zapfen und sobald der Druck zu weit sinkt, pumpt das Teil nach.
Aber auch nur so lange, bis es wieder seinen Zieldruck erreicht hat.
Genau und diese Konstruktion nennt man Hauswasserwerk, sowas kann man für gar
nicht so viel Geld im Baumarkt oder bei den Hersteinern halt dann kaufen.
Aber da ist jetzt keine Wiederaufbereitung drin, so wie bei Dune und den Fremen,
dass du deinen eigenen Urin durchfilterst.
Ich sag mal so, wenn ich jetzt in den Garten pinkeln würde, dann hätte ich das
irgendwann auch im Wasser, nehme ich mal an.
Es ist keine Kläranlage, es ist ein Pumpwerk.
Es ist nur die Pumpe. Also die Pumpe enthält noch einen kleinen Filter,
der verhindert, dass größere Steinchen irgendwie ins Pumpwerk gehen und das zerstören.
Aber ansonsten macht das Ding nichts mit dem Wasser, auch bereitungsmäßig.
Musst du die irgendwie genehmigen lassen?
Also im Sinne von Wasserqualität, Messung, irgendwann sind da mal die Stadtwerke
beigegangen und haben gesagt, jawohl, da ist Prüfsiegel drauf.
Nee, das ist ja nur Gartenwasser. Also ich pumpe das ja nur hoch,
um es den Pflänzchen dann vor die Füße zu kippen.
Ah, weil du hast gerade eben von Wasser hin und so. Also das nimmst du jetzt,
okay, also ist das jetzt nicht dein Kochwasser?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, ich bin ganz normal an das Wassernetz der Stadt Berlin angeschlossen.
Könntest du es denn als auch normales Wasser nehmen oder ist das dann verboten?
Du trinkst, ist ja deine Sache. Also die Vorschriften gelten ja nur für das
Wasser, was dir sozusagen von außen zugestellt wird.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob der Konsum safe ist und ich würde es auch nicht ausprobieren wollen.
Aber ich wüsste jetzt auch niemanden, der es mir verbieten will.
Also was man genehmigen lassen muss, ist den Brunnen bohren.
Ja, genau, schreibt Zielheit hier auch gerade.
Wenn er schon da ist, dann hat hoffentlich der Vorbesitzer oder der Vorvorbesitzer
da eine Genehmigung für gehabt, ansonsten Pech.
Ja, und da ist quasi eine Gartenbewässerungsanlage,
dran, so eine komische Zeituhr, die dann Ventile freischaltet und dann läuft
das durch so Plastikrohre und in so Regnern und so ein Kram. Ähm,
Sagen wir mal so, das hat vorher schon nicht so richtig geil funktioniert.
Vor allen Dingen, weil, glaube ich, eins der Ventile nicht so richtig in Ordnung
ist und nicht so richtig zumacht.
Aber nach der Wärmepumpenaktion funktionieren jetzt von den vier Strängen nur
noch zwei. Aus dem einen kommt gar nichts raus und aus dem anderen entsteht
ein großer See an einer Stelle.
Das heißt, da muss ich wieder ausbuddeln und gucken, was sie da gemacht haben,
um das wieder ans Laufen zu kriegen.
Aber das, ja. Und ja, jetzt habe ich, also nachdem das kaputt war, halt ein neues gekauft.
Das hat mir das schicken lassen und bin dann zweimal in den Baumarkt,
also erst bin ich in den Baumarkt, um eine größere Rohrzange zu kaufen, weil dieses Ding,
um von dem Brunnenrohr das abzuschrauben, der saß so fest und meine bisherige
Rohrzange war einfach zu klein.
Das Ding hatte irgendwie sieben Zentimeter Durchmesser, so eine Maulweite von
sieben Zentimetern, das hast du nicht mal eben zu Hause.
Hat aber dann funktioniert und dann habe ich gemerkt, was sind da alles für
Teile, es war ewig, bis ich die Pumpe weg hatte, was sind da so für Teile und
welche Adapter und so weiter, bin ich nochmal in den Baumarkt gefahren.
Dank des Adapters.
Genau, habe,
Adapter Mario Edition gemacht und ja, jetzt funktioniert es wieder.
Also dieses Gerät, was ich da gekauft habe, das schlechtest ablesbare Display,
das ich jetzt zu Hause habe, das ist echt ganz schlimm. Aber ansonsten tut es.
Zeigt es denn an, welchen Druck es liefert?
Also meine Frage ist eigentlich eher, was ist denn eigentlich der Druck, den man haben will?
Oder ab wann ist ein Wasserdruck ausreichend?
Ich glaube, das ist ein richtiges, kommt darauf an.
Also normalerweise, wenn du so eine Pumpe oder so ein Hauswasserwerk kaufst,
dann sagt er dir, wie viel Förderhöhe er schafft.
Jetzt ist es aber so, also wenn du mehr Druck haben willst, dann hast du auch
eine geringere Fördermenge.
Und wenn du aber eine höhere Fördermenge haben willst, hast du auch weniger Druck.
Keine Ahnung, die Pumpe zeigt an, was für eine Fadermenge sie gerade macht.
Das Maximum sind wohl, was war das, 4800 Liter in der Stunde,
aber gesehen habe ich bisher nur 2000. Aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran,
was da hinten dran hängt.
Also kein Display, irgendwo wie viel Bar Druck.
Also da ist noch so ein Analog-Anzeiger, aber da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nicht drauf geguckt, sondern ich hatte nur geguckt, wie viel Durchsatz macht das Ding jetzt.
da die Werte auf der alten Pumpe irgendwie nicht so ganz klar waren,
habe ich halt eine gekauft und gehofft, das funktioniert und siehe da,
es funktioniert auch ansonsten.
Ja
Wenn du damit fertig bist, hätte ich nämlich gleich ein passendes Anschluss Thema.
Anschluss, ja, dann schließ mal an Ja.
Wo wir gerade beim Anschließen auch sind.
Ihr nun wieder.
Ralf hat mich ja in der letzten Sendung auch gefragt gefragt,
nachdem ich meine Asienreise hinter mich gebracht habe, ob ich denn irgendwas
rausgefunden habe, was die anderen alle richtig machen.
Und man kommt so nach Hause und denkt sich, warum machen wir denn das nicht
schon längst so? Und da hatte ich in dem Moment so recht keine Antwort drauf.
Ich habe dabei nochmal drüber nachgedacht und ja, da gibt es tatsächlich etwas
und das ist dann quasi jetzt auch eine Fortsetzung meines beliebten Blogs in
der Frischung. Das Scheißthema.
Ja, also wir müssen mal wieder,
über solche Themen reden.
Was war das größte Problem, als wir irgendwie die Corona- Covid-Krise hatten? Gleich zu Beginn.
Toilettenpapier.
Toilettenpapier. Alle schrien irgendwie von ihrem Donnerbalken,
die Gestalten, schrien sie nach Klopapier.
Ja, weil aber die Hamster auch echt gehamstert haben.
Die Hamster haben eigentlich gar nicht so richtig gehamstert,
sondern das ist halt einfach ein fragiles Lieferkettensystem,
was dort einfach aus seiner Frequenz, aus seiner normalen Betriebsfrequenz herausgepusht wurde.
Ja, aber weil Leute mehr gekauft haben, als sie gebraucht haben eigentlich.
Ja, du wusstest ja aber nicht, wie lange das denn nun alles irgendwie mit man
kann nirgendwo mehr hin und was kaufen anhält.
Ja, aber es ist ja eigentlich kein Problem, wenn sich jetzt jemand entscheidet,
nochmal ein Paket Klopapier zu kaufen.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass alle in den Supermarkt gegangen sind und zehn Pakete gekauft haben.
Naja, aber es reicht ja einer, damit es leer ist.
Es reicht halt einer mehr als sonst, damit es irgendwie aus dem Tritt kommt,
dann sind halt mal auch für einen Tag die Regale leer und das führt dann wiederum
dazu, dass alle losrennen und sagen, oh Gott, es gibt kein Klopapier mehr,
während es halt Hallen tonnenweise voll, es gab genug Klopapier,
dass sich irgendwie Deutschland hätte sich noch 10 Jahre den Arsch abwischen
können mit dem, was bis dahin produziert war und schon irgendwie auf Halle lag,
aber naja, Wir wissen ja alle, wie es gelaufen ist.
Wisst ihr übrigens, was das zweite Gut war, was nicht zu kriegen war? Hefe.
Stimmt.
Und Nudeln waren auch eine Weile lang aus.
Nie wieder werden wir zum Bäcker können. Wir müssen selber backen.
Okay, aber bleiben wir mal beim Klo. Weil das ist halt auch so etwas,
wo die Leute sehr sensibel sind. Man sehnt sich ja nach Hygiene.
Da muss es schon laufen.
Und der Gedanke, in so einer Krise zu Hause festzusitzen, in der eigenen Scheiße sozusagen.
Das hat den Leuten auch das nochmal besonders unangenehm gemacht.
Und das hat dann auch diese Nachfrage nach Toilettenpapier nochmal verstärkt.
Und ich sag dir mal eins, in Asien gab es dieses Problem auf gar keinen Fall,
weil die einfach mit dem Thema ganz anders umgehen.
Und das ist mir tatsächlich auch schon auf meiner Reise vorher aufgefallen,
als ich irgendwie in den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten war und da irgendwie
auch mal auf so ein Dubai auf so ein,
Restaurantklo ging.
Und dann dachte so, hier gibt es ja gar kein Klopapier. Was ist das denn?
Ich denke, ich bin hier gerade in Dubai, in diesem Luxusding,
wo alles mal auf so einem Minimalstandard ist.
Und dann bin ich irgendwie in einem Restaurantklo und es gibt noch nicht mal Klopapier.
Ja, die haben diese Brause, ne?
Die haben diese Brause.
Die gab es in Indien auch überall.
Und das ist halt einfach mal der Standard in Asien.
und das macht auch einfach mal so viel Sinn.
Wir reden also über Reinigungsbrausen. Vielleicht könnte man auch BD-Brause sagen oder so.
Da gibt es diese verschiedensten Begriffe. Ich glaube bei Amazon läuft es unter,
Reinigungsbrause. Ganz dezent.
Kann man aber wahrscheinlich über tausend Namen suchen.
Brause kommt Wasser raus.
Ja, Brause kommt Wasser raus und es ist halt einfach mal also nachdem ich dann
da war, habe ich das irgendwie bei mir auch installiert.
Die Meta-Ebene ist sozusagen mit einer Reinigungsbrowser ausgestattet.
Und wenn man die mal konsequent zum Einsatz bringt, dann hat das irgendwie zwei Effekte.
Erstens, damit wird einfach auch mal wirklich alles sauber und zweitens,
man verbraucht überhaupt kein Klopapier mehr.
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern, als ich das letzte Mal Klopapier
gekauft habe, weil das Thema einfach weg ist.
So, jetzt bin ich aber gerade dabei, in eine neue Wohnung einzuziehen,
beziehungsweise habe das jetzt gerade getan und diese Wohnung verfügt nicht
über Reinigungsbrausen.
Also musst du die jetzt auch nachrüsten?
Selbstverständlich muss ich die nachrüsten und jetzt entwerfe ich natürlich schon Pläne dafür.
Die Wohnung ist aber relativ hoch gelegen, also vom Stockwerk her relativ hoch gelegen.
Und ich habe so ein bisschen Bedenken, was den Wasserdruck betrifft.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt gerade mal gefragt, was eigentlich so der Wasserdruck
ist, der so als der normale Wasserdruck gilt.
Da werde ich einfach mal einen Manometer besorgen müssen, um da mal entsprechende Tests zu machen.
Ich möchte euch aber generell einfach dazu ermutigen, eure Heime,
wenn ihr sowieso schon in so einem Handwerkerwaren seid, dann doch auch einfach
nochmal mit Reinigungsbrausen auszustatten.
Das ist nämlich in der Regel relativ einfach.
Wenn man so einen Spülkasten hat, so einen externen Spülkasten,
also klassisches WC mit Spülkasten extern und man kann oben so einen Deckel
abnehmen und so, dann ist ja meistens auch die Wasserzuführung von der Seite.
Das heißt, dann geht dann ohnehin irgendwie schon mal ein Rohr rein.
Da gibt es dann tausend Anschlussmöglichkeiten, um mal eben nochmal so einen
Abzweig ranzubammeln und schon ist man irgendwie dabei.
Knifflig wird es halt nur, wenn man so komische integrierte Spülkastensysteme
hat. Das ist ja so ein bisschen so ein Trend.
Also so Spülkasten ist ja irgendwie hässlich.
Dann hast du heute in die Wand eingebaut.
Genau. Und total zugekachelt.
Ja, hab ich.
Und das ist ja dann mal, ich frage mich ja, wie man sowas servist.
Also wie baut man denn das um? Muss man dann sozusagen...
Na, wie so ein Gynäkologe, alles durch die gleiche Öffnung.
Nee, es gibt normalerweise ein, zwei Kacheln, die öffnenbar sind.
Meinst du?
Ja, das meine ich nicht, zumindest bei uns ist das so. Weil wenn da nämlich
mal was klemmt, dann mache ich die auf und komme dann an die Innereien dran.
Es ist ein bisschen fruckelig, das schon, aber es geht.
Die Kacheln sind nicht das, was sie schicken.
Genau, Revisionsöffnung wird hier im Chat geschrieben.
Eine Revisionsöffnung, naja okay, aber wenn die Revisionsöffnung aber sozusagen
nur für das Servicen der Spülkastenmechanik gemacht ist,
erlaubt es ja immer noch nicht eine problemlose Ergänzung des Systems um einen
weiteren Wasserabzweig, die man unter Umständen nicht hat.
Naja, dann müsstest du halt durchbohren, um da einen Abzweig hinzumachen und
dann alles intern verdrahten.
Ja, die Frage ist, ob man die Fliesen auch so entfernen kann,
dass man sie wieder ranbambeln kann.
Eher nicht.
Das ist aber doof.
Also gut, ich weiß nicht, moderner Fliesenkleber ist jetzt nicht mehr eine gemörtelte
Fliese, aber der hält also in der Regel schon sehr gut, sodass du wahrscheinlich,
wenn du versuchst, die Fliesen abzumachen, sie dann auch kaputt machst.
Kann man die nicht mit so einer kleinen Säge aufsägen, so wie man so einen Gips
aufsägt, mit so einem Frequenzsäger?
Ja.
Mit so einem Multitool?
Naja, aber die Fliese ist ja in ihrer Fläche hinten festgeklebt an der Wand
oder an der Trockenbauwand.
Das ist ja die Umbauung eines Spülkasten, das ist ja ein Hohlraum.
Richtig, aber das sind ja so Trockenbauwände, so Rigipskram und da wird dann
die Fliese draufgeklebt mit sogenanntem Fliesenkleber und das Zeug ist relativ
fieses Zeug. Wenn das einmal abgebunden ist, hält es schon ganz gut.
Und zwar wahrscheinlich so gut, dass du die Fliese nicht abkriegst.
Okay, gut. Das ist ja auch nur mein privates Problem. Ich wollte sozusagen Reinigungsbrausen
mal in euer Bewusstsein werfen und ich kann euch sagen,
was euch diese Sendung jetzt einfach schon an Klopapierkosten erspart hat durch
diese Maßnahme, das lässt sich kaum beziffern.
Naja, wann sich das amortisiert. Ich meine, so teuer ist Klopapier jetzt nun auch nicht.
Man kauft das aber relativ oft.
Ja nun, hilft ja nichts.
Man muss da auch immer hinfahren und das holen und es braucht relativ viel Volumen.
Ja, aber das tut man ja, wenn man andere Dinge auch kauft.
Ich finde einfach diesen Gedanken, dass ja die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Bäume
zusammengepresst werden und gebleicht werden,
nur damit man sich damit irgendwie den Arsch abwischt, um es dann einfach sofort
wieder wegzuschmeißen und dann auch noch die Klärung dieses Wassers zu erschweren,
weil das ja dann alles sich darin auflösen muss und so weiter,
finde ich ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen kontraproduktiv.
Also wenn man mal so ein bisschen drüber nachdenkt, wie die Welt halt eigentlich
sein sollte, ist Klopapier irgendwie eine Scheißidee.
Also, um jetzt mal wieder in meiner Lieblingsrolle des besorgten Vaters aufzutreten.
Bitteschön.
So, nehmen wir mal an, wir hätten das jetzt also alles so umgebaut und müssten
kein Klopapier mehr kaufen.
Wie genau lernen dann deine Kinder den sachgemäßen Umgang mit Klopapier,
was kein einfacher Skill ist? auch je nachdem, wie die verdaust.
Wie lernen deine Kinder den sachgemäßen Umgang mit einer Reinigungsbrause?
Ja, und in der Schule und in der Kita, da haben die das auch alles?
Nein, aber dann muss es sein.
Ach so, Tim.
Ja, heute schon an morgen denken. Das ist ein zukunftsorientierter Podcast.
Aber du siehst meinen Punkt, ja?
Naja, klar, mit der Realität muss man sich schon vertraut machen,
aber nur, weil man jetzt irgendwie diesen Skill lernt, den man da draußen braucht,
heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass man das in den eigenen Wänden genauso machen muss.
Du lernst ja auch Französisch, aber du quatschst ja nicht die ganze Zeit zu Hause.
Das ist ja nur, um den Kontakt der Außenwelt in irgendeiner Form zu ermöglichen.
Das verstehe ich schon, dass Klopapier manchmal die einzige Option ist.
Eigentlich immer außer bei dir zu Hause.
Ja, oder in Asien oder in Arabien oder halt irgendwie in all diesen,
ich meine, diese Länder tendieren ja dazu, manche Dinge auch wirklich besser
zu machen als wir. Und das gehört definitiv dazu.
Es ist gerade im Chat hier auch eine ganz lustige Debatte über die Schambehaftigkeit
von Klopapierkaufen, die so knapp unterhalb von Kondomekaufen rangiert.
Echt?
Ich finde, da ist nochmal ein bisschen Luft.
Ja, gut, also wie so häufig, im Prinzip bin ich bei dir. Also ich glaube auch,
diese Gesellschaft wäre eine bessere, wenn wir das alle umgestellt hätten.
Hier wird noch gefragt, wie hat man den sachgemäßen Umgang mit einer Reisungsbrause?
Also man muss das Thema ja noch ein bisschen erweitern. Es gibt auch noch eine
andere Option und das ist halt sozusagen, wenn man ganz bis ans Ende von Asien fährt.
Wo ist denn das Ende von Asien?
Das Ende von Asien ist Japan.
Okay.
Und die Japaner waren schon immer ganz weit vorne, was das Scheißthema betrifft.
Da ist ein Klo nicht ein Loch mit Wasser, sondern so eine Art Wellness Center.
Wellness Center, das trifft es glaube ich ganz gut.
Und die haben ja schon ganz früh angefangen, also bei denen ist es natürlich
auch so ein bisschen schambehaftet.
Das japanische Klo hat ja oft so Features wie,
dass du so Meeresrauschen abspielen kannst, weil es dann den Japanern peinlich
ist, wenn ihre Pullerei irgendwie akustisch zu hören ist und so weiter oder
vielleicht auch um sie auch selber zu besänftigen.
Da kann man halt also wirklich drüber diskutieren.
Aber, was sie auf jeden Fall auch mit auf den Markt gebracht haben,
und das kann man auch hier in Deutschland erwerben, und da kann man auch einfach
seine Kloschüssel austauschen, wenn man die gerade sowieso austauschen muss,
die halt einfach direkt eine Reinigungsbrause sozusagen ausfahrbar fest installiert haben.
Und dann kommt dann einfach von hinten der Strahl direkt schön warm reingeschossen.
Ja, und je nach Ausführung, also je nach Modell, also ich hatte da jetzt auch
gerade verschiedenste Varianten am Start auf meiner Fahrt, gibt es dann so Tasten,
die dann so einen Wiggle-Mode auch noch machen, ja, also,
dann geht das Wasser auch so richtig schön so vor zurück, vor zurück,
vor zurück und es ist einfach so angenehm, ja, also da kannst du also wirklich
mal so, ich meine, die Puperze ist ja auch ein erotischer Ort.
Ja, das bringen wir jetzt so normalerweise mit dem Abortieren nicht so ohne
weiteres zusammen, aber das kann halt auch einfach ein Übergang sein,
was eben noch eine Beschwernis war und du denkst jetzt schon wieder so,
wie viele Blätter Klopapier werde ich jetzt verwenden müssen?
Nehme ich drei, nehme ich vier, bin ich ein Knüller oder bin ich ein Falter?
Das sind alles so Fragen, die einem jedes Mal wieder durch den Kopf gehen und
du bist ja irgendwie nie sicher.
Und dann hast du irgendwie schon so mehrere Kilogramm Papier in dieses Klo reingebracht,
nur weil du dir irgendwie eigentlich nicht so richtig sicher bist,
ob du dich jetzt schon ausreichend hygienisiert fühlst.
Dieses Problem existiert nicht, wenn du das Ganze mit Wasser,
aber schon gar nicht mit warmem Wasser machst.
Und wenn du dann auch noch so eine Maschine hast, die dann so noch verschiedene
Wiggle-Modes unterstützt, und Brauseprofile und wie breit jetzt sozusagen,
also du kannst ja auswählen,
ob du sozusagen so gezielt jetzt nur am Ortsgeschehens arbeiten willst oder
ob du nicht vielleicht mal den ganzen Arsch abspülen möchtest.
Alles ist möglich mit japanischer Technologie.
Haben die dann auch so einen Side-Stick wie im Airbus?
Zum Steuern? Nö, das ist gar nicht nötig irgendwie. Das ist auf jeden Fall ausgereifte Technologie.
Also zu dem Thema fällt mir immer wieder die Story ein, die mir eine Bekannte
vor Jahren mal erzählt hat.
Und zwar ist die halbe Japanerin und ihre Tante. Also dazu muss man sagen,
in Japan gibt es ja beheizbare Badewannen.
Also du sitzt in der Badewanne und das Wasser wird nicht kalt,
weil es von der Badewanne nachgeheizt wird.
Und ihre Tante ist in so einer beheizbaren Badewanne gestorben und erst Wochen
später gefunden worden. und die Badewanne war immer noch warm.
Immer noch warm. Jetzt mal wieder irgendwie die kritische Perspektive eingenommen.
Wie verhält sich das auf den Wasserverbrauch? So Stichwort Dürre und Wassersparen.
Und können wir uns das dann leisten.
Tim? Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Naja, also ich meine...
Das ist äquivalent zu Händewaschen.
Du musst fairerweise musst du natürlich die Wassergestehungskosten einer Rolle
Klopapier gegenrechnen Ja.
Die aber nicht unbedingt bei uns anfällt sondern irgendwo wo es Grundwasser noch im Überfluss gibt.
Ist ja egal wo das anfällt, fällt ja an Also ich meine auf Klopapierproduktion
komplett zu verzichten würde auf jeden Fall mehr bringen als jetzt abzurechnen ob meine drei Spritzer,
die ich hier sozusagen vor dem Spülen von mehreren Litern Wasser im Klo noch zusätzlich nutze,
um irgendwie gezielten Reinigungen herbeizuführen.
Das fällt jetzt also wirklich nicht mehr groß ins Klo.
Ja, vermutlich nicht.
Nun denn, du hast alles versucht.
Ich meine, man kann natürlich darüber diskutieren, ob eine Toilette auch einen
Stromanschluss braucht, aber ich glaube da, that ship has sailed.
Also wir haben irgendwie schon alles unter Strom, wenn es das Klo auch noch dazu kommt.
Die viel interessantere Frage ist, ob das Klo auch einen Internetanschluss braucht.
Also naja, also tatsächlich geht das ja bei den Japanern schon auch wirklich
in die Richtung, dass die Klos noch mehr tun, ja, also die messen dann auch
noch deine Temperatur und das ist dann sozusagen auch noch so ein Analysezentrum.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob dir dann auch schon.
So die Apple Watch am Arsch?
Naja, also ich meine, ich weiß nicht, inwiefern sie das schon ab Wasser untersuchen,
aber denkbar wäre das natürlich.
Braucht es denn da eigentlich zwingend Strom für?
Na, wenn du da so ein User-Interface hast und da hinten dieser Apparat ausfährt mit einem Motor.
Ja, man könnte das natürlich auch mechanisch bauen. Ich weiß nicht,
ob es sowas gibt mit so einem Hebel oder so, meinst du?
Ja, also da könnte man doch Abstriche machen an der Stelle.
Ja, das wäre natürlich ganz gut, dass man sozusagen...
Ganz falscher Ausdruck in dem Zusammenhang.
Nicht ausgerechnet, wenn sozusagen jetzt Stromausfall ist, wie jetzt gerade
in Spanien, dass dann auf einmal alle wieder nach Klopapier schreien.
weil ihre BD-Brause nicht funktioniert. Aber da reicht ja normalerweise eben
der normale Wasserdruck, wenn der halt da ist. Dann brauchst du ja eigentlich nur einen Wasserturm.
Tja.
Wie kommen wir aus diesem Thema wieder raus?
Naja, also ich meine das sind Dinge, die sind einfach auch irgendwo wichtig.
Vielleicht bleiben wir auch einfach gleich beim Ort des Geschehens.
weil direkt neben der Toilette bei mir ist meine Badewanne und da habe ich drin
gesessen wie ich das, ich bade gerne Aha.
In der Badewanne.
Baden aber dann über Wasserverbrauch diskutieren Ich bade oder dusche aber so
lange dass sich das glaube ich wieder egalisiert vom Verbrauch her.
Ach du duscht erst so lange dass du denkst, jetzt kann ich doch auch gleich das baden?
Genau, es würde eine sehr lange Dusch-Session kompensiert.
So und ihr kennt das sicher, sowohl unter der Dusche als auch in der Badewanne
macht man sich dann ja immer so tiefe Gedanken über die letzten Fragen des Lebens.
Zumindest hat er dann immer das Gefühl, es wäre so.
Soll ich Severance gucken?
Und,
So ein Thema, was mich wirklich schon seit vielen Jahren umtreibt,
ist Zukunftsgläubigkeit und die feste Gewissheit, dass es immer noch irgendwo
besser geht und die Leute einfach noch nicht lange genug nachgedacht haben.
Ich ahne, dass ihr beide da vielleicht auch ein klein bisschen ähnlich gepolt sind,
weil ich auch einfach wahrnehme, so in meinem Alltag, ständig werden nochmal
Dinge optimiert und das kommt völlig aus der Kalten, wo man dachte,
das Thema ist völlig auserzählt und dann kommt jemand daher mit einer pfiffigen
Idee und macht das einfach mal viel besser und man fragt sich,
warum nicht 40 Jahre vorher, die Komponenten waren alle da.
Beispiel hier meine Fahrradtasche, die ich mit einem Handgriff in den Rucksack
umbauen kann. So hatte ich in der vorherigen Sendung auch schon mal gebracht.
Super Sache, funktioniert einfach.
So und mein Ansatz war jetzt, okay, jetzt leben wir ja im Zeitalter der KI und
wo wir Dinge jetzt einfach mit unglaublicher Computing-Power auch einfach mal durchrechnen können.
Gibt es eigentlich so Alltagsprobleme oder Weltprobleme, wo man einfach mal
jetzt eine KI draufsetzen kann nach dem Thema,
löst mir das mal und gib mal einen völlig frischen Ansatz dazu, wie man das machen kann.
Und ich war ja in meinem früheren Leben mal Wissenschaftler.
Ich habe dann überlegt, was wäre denn aber ein gutes Setup, um das dann auch
irgendwie benchmarken zu können, ob das denn wirklich jetzt eine gute,
praktikable Idee ist. Und worüber ich schon seit Wochen nachgegrübelt habe,
ist die Schiffsschraube.
Und wer sagt uns eigentlich, dass eine Schiffsschraube die beste denkbare Form
hat, um ein Schiff durch Wasser anzutreiben?
Du meinst, welche Form die beste ist, um einen damit anzutreiben oder ob eine
Schiffsschraube an sich die beste Methode ist?
Vielleicht ist ja auch irgendeine andere Form noch denkbar, die sich um eine
Achse dreht, die einfach nochmal 20% mehr Hub produziert.
Du weißt, dass es sowas wie CFD gibt und Leute, die sowas schon seit Jahren machen.
Es wird gleich alles sehr peinlich für mich, das kann ich schon mal versprechen.
Aber den Hergang fand ich für mich ganz hilfreich, das mal durchgespielt zu haben.
Gut, also war da also in der Badewanne und dachte mir, okay,
wie benchmarkst du das jetzt aber?
Und das Setup, was ich mir überlegt hatte, war, okay, wir machen einfach einen
Brute-Force-Ansatz versus einen KI-generierten Ansatz.
Das heißt, Brute-Force, erstelle einfach ein Modell,
das sämtliche denkbaren Formen durchrechnet in Bezug auf ihre Antriebsfähigkeit
und dann Benchmarke gegen das, was eine KI quasi als optimale Form rausbringen würde.
soweit verständlich das Grundsetup also alle denkbaren Möglichkeiten durchgerechnet
versus okay KI streng dich mal an, was glaubst du, was ist die optimale Form
und dann kann man gucken, wie dicht ist sie denn Ich frage mich gerade.
Was für eine KI du da fragst, die bitteschön mit welchen Daten gefüttert wurde ChatGPT oder was.
Es wird vielleicht einfacher, wenn ich jetzt mal das Modell als solches erkläre
Ich habe mir gedacht, okay, wir machen es jetzt erstmal ganz ganz simpel Wir nehmen einen 10er Kubus,
Das heißt, eine Kantenlänge von 10 und das als Würfel.
Also wie so ein quasi Rubik's Cube, nur dass er nicht drei, zehn Punkte.
10 mal 10 mal 10, 1000 Zellen.
Genau, Zellen. Also quadratische kleine Zellen.
Orte.
Orte, so. Ist natürlich viel zu wenig, um jetzt irgendwie stromlinienförmig
was Elegantes zu machen, aber ich wollte erstmal so ein Grundmodell haben,
um überhaupt erstmal irgendwo anzufangen.
So, das heißt also 10 mal 10 mal 10 Kantenlänge und eben tausend verschiedene
Punkte, in denen man da drin ist.
Das finde ich schon mal intuitiv, als jemand, der irgendwie denkt,
so mit exponentiellen Geschichten kommen wir nach Corona alle viel besser klar
als vorher, finde ich das schon mal verstörend, dass in so einer kleinen Form
wirklich schon mal tausend Elemente drin sind.
Aber ist so, kann man einfach durchrechnen, 10 mal 10 mal 10 halt.
Das Kubik ist gemein.
Mathematik für Anfänger.
Mathematik für Anfänger, genau. Und dann kam aber der nächste Schritt und dass
ich halt dann gefragt habe, okay, und das habe ich dann in der Tat Chat-GPT
gefragt, irgendwie die aktuelles O1 irgendwas Modell.
So, berechne doch jetzt mal, wie viele mögliche Formen kann ich denn jetzt eigentlich
in diesem Kubus abbilden?
Du meinst jetzt so quasi binär, hier ist was und hier ist nichts.
Genau, exakt so. an, aus. Das heißt also, jede dieser tausend Positionen kann
jetzt genau zwei Zustände haben, nämlich entweder null, dann ist da nix,
oder eins, dann ist da ein Element, was theoretisch irgendein Schuh produzieren kann.
Aber muss schon irgendwie miteinander verbunden sein, dann die Pixel sozusagen.
Genau.
Zwei hoch tausend?
Genau, zwei hoch tausend, völlig richtig, Roddy.
Das ist viel.
Wenn du erstmal gar keine wenn du erstmal gar keine weiteren Bedingungen reingibst,
hast du ein Modell mit zwei hoch tausend Optionen.
Das ist mal ganz schön viel.
Sondern hat ChatGPT auch schon gemeint, das ist eine verdammt hohe Zahl mit
wirklich, wirklich vielen Nullen dahinter.
Da habe ich gesagt, ja, aber ganz so kompliziert brauchen wir es ja nicht.
Wir haben ja Zusatzbedingungen. Ich brauche also einen Antriegspunkt.
Das heißt, es ist schon mal nur noch die Hälfte, weil es ja ein 0-1-er-Zustand
schon gesetzt ist, wo nämlich quasi die Kurbelwelle irgendwie dran liegt.
Und dann kannst du noch alle Modelle rausrechnen, die keinen Nachbarn haben,
weil das sind ja quasi tote Punkte. Die fallen dann ja zu Boden und sind nicht
Teil eines irgendwie gearteten Antriebs.
Versteht ihr? Es muss eine zusammenhängende Form sein.
Da hat er dann eine Hochrechnung gemacht. Ja, dadurch fallen nochmal irgendwie
40.000 raus, aber es wird halt nicht signifikant viel kleiner,
diese Zahl, die da rauskommt.
Das waren immer noch irgendwie 2 hoch 300 irgendwas. was.
So, dann dachte ich, naja, aber ich habe jetzt hier ja MacBook Pro,
Apple Silicon und so. Wird schon gehen.
Mach doch jetzt mal eine Hochrechnung, wie lange das denn jetzt dauern würde,
diese ganzen Varianten jetzt einfach mal durchzurechnen in Bezug auf Schubkraft,
wenn sich das Ganze irgendwie dreht.
Du hast nicht mehr den Speicher dafür, oder?
Nicht nur das. So, und dann fing er schon schwer an zu nölen und Und meinte
so, jetzt müssen wir erst mal gucken, was für eine Schubformel nehmen wir da überhaupt?
Wie kompliziert soll es denn irgendwie sein? Ich habe immer gesagt,
nimm das Einfachste, was du irgendwie findest.
Hat dann irgendwie vier, fünf verschiedene physikalische Modelle mir hingeworfen,
welches ich denn jetzt haben wollte.
Da habe ich gesagt, nimm das, was am wenigsten Computing Power braucht und das
nimm dann mal entsprechend.
So und das habe ich dann in der Tat getan und dann hat er dann einen Wert rausgeworfen,
wie lange denn jetzt die Berechnung dauern würde, um dieses kleine Problem zu brute forcen.
Und die Antwort werfe ich dann mal eben in den Chat rein hier.
Die Berechnung würde also ungefähr
10 hoch 283 mal länger dauern als das bisherige Alter des Universums.
Naja, aber das ist ja auch gerade mal 15 Milliarden Jahre alt. 13.
Ja, 13. Ich habe das jetzt aufgerundet, aber ist egal. Also ich meine, aufgerundet.
Das ist, sagen wir mal, die Krise der Kosmologie, die machst du dann doch viel schlimmer.
So, und ja, die Mathematiker und Physiker da draußen mögen jetzt schwer mit
den Augen rollen, ich kann das gut verstehen, aber ich finde das in der Sache
irgendwie frustrierend,
dass du also so ein kleines Modell hast, 10 mal 10 mal 10 und nicht ansatzweise
haben wir irgendeine Computing Power, um nur diesen kleinen Witzel durchzuberechnen.
Ergo, da hast du dich aber natürlich auch maximal blöd angestellt.
Du kannst es halt weiter vereinfachen, aber mit dem Blutforts-Ansatz kommst
du irgendwann einfach nicht. Ich habe nur noch gefragt, was ist denn,
wenn wir jetzt einen Quantencomputer haben und so.
Ja, ist halt nur ein bedingt gutes Problem dafür und sparst du vielleicht nochmal
Faktor 4 ein, aber mehr geht da nicht und es ist deprimierend.
Damit du jetzt nicht frustriert rausgehst, wenn du Zugriff zu einem 3D-Drucker
hast, dann kann ich dir folgendes empfehlen, was ich neulich gerade erst gedruckt habe.
Und zwar handelt es sich um den Hochgeschwindigkeitspropellerwerfer eines gewissen Lukas Hannert.
Ein wunderschönes Gerät. Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine größere Pfeffermühle.
Hat drei Planetengetriebe drin.
Alter.
Und du drehst unten und dann dreht sich das oben extrem schnell und dieses Propeller-Ding,
was da oben drauf ist, das fliegt dann weg.
Ich habe das tatsächlich gedruckt und zusammengebaut. Funktioniert auch relativ gut.
Wie weit fliegt das denn?
Naja, sagen wir mal so.
Also er macht hier 18.000 Umdrehungen pro Minute.
Wir wollten ja eigentlich jetzt nicht über die Easter Hack reden,
aber bei der Easter Hack hatte jemand so ein Teil.
Und wir haben es dann in der Halle fliegen lassen und das fliegt ganz locker bis an die Decke.
Also so dritter Stock, vierter Stock oder so.
Das fliegt weit. Weil da ist, also die Übersetzung, was sagt er,
1 zu 64 steht da, die führt schon dazu, dass dieser Propeller sehr stark beschleunigt
wird und ordentlich Lift macht.
Ich habe die Propeller extra in orange gedruckt.
Ich habe mich gewundert, dass die Dinger die ganze Zeit oben an der Decke hängen
geblieben sind, so hoch sind die geflogen.
Okay, gut, aber bist du denn jetzt sozusagen, also war das jetzt schon das Ende deiner Forschung?
Das war das traurige Ende meiner Forschung.
Aber hast du denn schon von dem toroidalen Propeller gehört,
der vor kurzem erfunden wurde und der sozusagen in dieser Schiffswelt diese
selbe Frage auch neu aufgebracht hat, ob wir denn jetzt sozusagen den neuen
heiligen Gral der Schiffsschraube gefunden haben.
Nee, aber erzähle.
Also der toroidale Propeller ist ein Ergebnis von irgendeiner Universität aus
den USA und das ist quasi eine andere Form,
eines Antriebs und das ist halt nicht nur fürs Wasser, sondern sozusagen,
theoretisch halt glaube ich auch für Luft, ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher.
Sie haben es vor allen Dingen erstmal für Luft gemacht.
Sicher?
Ja, ich weiß schon.
Ich dachte es ist erstmal für Wasser.
Diese solche Formen wollte ich...
Beides.
Weil das sieht so kontraintuitiv aus.
Ja und Naja, normalerweise hast du am Ende des Propellerblatts einen fürchterlich großen Wirbel,
und Wirbel kostet immer Energie, deswegen hast du ja an modernen Verkehrsflugzeugen auch diese Winglets,
diese komischen hochstehenden Dinger, die viel stärker verhindern,
dass sich ein riesiger Wirbel bildet und wenn du jetzt aber gar kein Ende des
Propellerblatts hast, dann kannst du da auch keinen Wirbel haben und insofern
ist, wenn man das Ding ordentlich,
optimiert, völlig klar, dass der effektiver ist als ein Propeller, der eben Enden hat.
Wobei jetzt hier in einem Wikipedia-Artikel steht, dass deren Hauptvorteil die
Geräuschlosigkeit ist, dass die weniger Krach machen, aber nicht mehr Antrieb.
Ja, aber warum machen sie weniger Krach? Wegen weniger Wirbel.
Wirbel ist immer das, was Krach macht. Das hast du auch bei so Windkraftanlagen.
Je effektiver die sind und je weniger Wirbel die machen, desto leiser sind sie auch.
Also ich habe das, das ist irgendwie, wann wurde das Ding, also es mag schon
mal vorher gemacht worden, aber das Thema kam vor ein paar Jahren neu auf.
Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, also
der Wikipedia-Artikel hat jetzt hier so verschiedenste Zeitmarken, 2010.
Was mich jetzt hier bei dem Bild auf Wikipedia verstört, ist,
dass zwar, also wir können mal versuchen zu beschreiben.
Also in dem Wikipedia-Artikel habe ich quasi drei Kreise, die sich so scheinbar
so ein bisschen überschneiden, aber halt doch irgendwie so aneinander geflanscht
sind, in einem Dreieck mehr oder weniger.
Und zwei dieser Kreise sind quasi so angeschrägt, dass man sofort erkennt,
ja da wird irgendwie einen Schub mit erzeugt.
Und der dritte Kreis sieht aber irgendwie komplett anders aus.
Ist das jetzt, weil es doof fotografiert ist auf Wikipedia?
Das ist die Perspektive, glaube ich. Weil die ja alle schräg sind, die Flächen.
Ja.
Glaube ich auch.
Deswegen sieht der eine dünner aus.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Meines Wissens sind die alle drei. Der ist nicht asymmetrisch im eigentlichen Sinne.
Nee, es geht einfach darum, dass es quasi nicht offen ist, sondern geschlossen.
Es gibt also verschiedenste Ansätze.
Genau, der Chat füllt sich jetzt auch schon mit diversen YouTube-Material.
Ich habe mir mal ein paar davon angeschaut, weil als das so rauskam als Paper,
war das halt so, ja, hier, die neue Form, alles wird besser.
Und ich habe diverse Tests gesehen, wo Leute sich die dann halt 3D geprintet
haben und gegen ihre Standardpropeller verglichen haben und es war nicht effektiv.
Generell so, dass die Dinger mehr Schub oder weniger Verbrauch an Energie gehabt hätten oder so.
Die sind jetzt auch nicht so nennenswert viel schlechter, aber sie sind auch
nicht zwangsläufig jetzt durch die Bank besser und die Methode.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist, du hast da schon so einen Punkt,
also man kann über das Motor- und Propeller-Design ein paar interessante Aspekte noch verbessern.
Mir fällt zum Beispiel der Motor ein, den Candela verwendet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir überhaupt über Candela hier schon mal gesprochen haben.
Glaub nicht.
Candela ist so quasi, in Anführungsstrichen, verzeiht mir den Vergleich,
ist nicht mehr so opportun, quasi das Tesla der Bootswelt.
Das ist eine schwedische Company und Candela baut Tragflächenboote mit Elektromotor.
Das sind also komplett elektrische Boote, die bemerkenswert leise sind,
weil sie halt Tragflächenboote sind und das heißt ab einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit
hebt sich das ganze Boot sozusagen aus dem Wasser.
Das sind so Katamaran-Konstruktionen und andere und die haben mittlerweile glaube
ich auch drei oder vier verschiedene Modelle.
Das ursprüngliche war halt so ein Luxussportboot und dann haben sie kürzlich
auch so ein mittelgroßes Passagierboot gebaut, was insofern bemerkenswert ist,
als dass es eben jetzt auch zugelassen ist im schwedischen, im Stockholmer Hafengebiet.
dort fahren zu dürfen und es fährt halt sehr viel schneller als ein normales
Boot mit sehr viel weniger Energiebedarf.
Unendlich elektrisch und ganz leise.
Also Tragflächenboote sind ja insofern genial, als dass sie ja im Prinzip den
gesamten Rumpf aus dem Wasser...
holen und dann nur diese Tragfläche unter Wasser ist und deswegen deutlich weniger Widerstand hat.
Ich glaube, dass das mit Elektromotoren deutlich besser geht, weil die einen höheren,
Drehzahlumfang haben als ein Verbrennungsmotor. Du müsstest wahrscheinlich,
wenn du das mit einem Verbrennungsmotor betreiben willst, ein Getriebe haben,
wo du dann schaltest und so.
aber ja klar also aber die gibt es auch es gibt die auch glaube ich zum Treten
und so also da gibt es auch interessante Dinge wo du halt dann wie auf so einem
Fahrrad aber dann ist es so ein Tragflächendings Konstruktion sieht auch total geil aus.
Kurz noch zu den Booten und dann vor allem noch zu dem Motor also gerade dieses
Passagierschiff hat also dreht also in Stockholm sozusagen da diesen Transport
also das ist ja eine relativ wenn ihr
euch mal Stockholm von oben anschaut Hafengebiete, es gibt da sehr viel.
Wasserkanäle und Seen und so weiter.
Das heißt, die Verbindung mit Passagierschiffen ist ein wichtiger Teil des ÖPNV.
Ich war noch nicht da, aber ich habe das irgendwie alles so gelesen.
Und das Problem ist, dass du aber in diesem Hafengebiet natürlich wegen des
Wellengangs auch eine bestimmte Geschwindigkeit bisher nicht überschreiten durftest.
Durch dieses Tragflächenprinzip machen die Dinge halt auch noch deutlich weniger
Wellengang und können von daher auch sehr viel schneller fahren.
Also sie sind billiger im Betrieb, sie sind leise, Sie haben halt keinen Öl-Scheiß,
den sie ins Wasser lassen können und sind halt dabei auch noch viel schneller.
Aber das Besondere ist halt dieser Motor und der Motor ist halt so eine Art Kiel, der...
Also es ist nicht am Schiff direkt dran hinten wie so eine Schraube,
also es hat natürlich auch Schrauben, aber es sieht mehr aus wie so ein kleiner
Torpedo, der so unten am Kiel hängt und der vorne und hinten solche Propeller hat.
Also er hat sozusagen so zwei gegeneinander laufende Propeller.
Ich suche hier gerade ein gutes Bild, das hat sich irgendwie alles ein bisschen
verändert, die Webseite, seitdem ich das letzte Mal geschaut habe.
Es gibt hier auf jeden Fall eine ausführliche Dokumentation über ihre Pott-Elektromotoren
und die entsprechende Propeller, die sie dann halt dort haben.
Also Candela, das sind so Boote, die man eigentlich haben will, aber es ist halt teuer.
Aber genauso wie bei Motorrädern muss ich sagen, also auch Boote finde ich ja
irgendwie ganz nett, aber ich hasse Boote für ihren Lärm.
Und so Elektroboot, da wird das Thema für mich dann auch mal interessant,
aber vorher irgendwie nicht.
In Deutschland müssen die wahrscheinlich dann extra Geräusch machen,
damit sie nicht zu leise sind.
Ja, genau. Also es ist schon ein interessantes Thema, gar keine Frage.
Da tut sich auf jeden Fall so einiges.
Ja, die KI. Jetzt bist du ja schon so ein bisschen hier wieder in die Wissenschaft,
abgeglitten. Ich wollte,
ja, das können wir auch später machen. Wollen wir uns über AI unterhalten?
Ja.
Ja, also ich finde das ja ganz interessant, diese Wahrnehmung,
wie so dieses Vibe-Coding gerade so reflektiert wird.
Du bist ja jetzt Botschafter, Roddy. Du bist jetzt AI-Botschafter.
So genau weiß ich das noch nicht.
Aber,
Ja, sprich dich aus.
Nee, ich will dazu eigentlich gar nicht so richtig viel sagen.
Okay, aber auf jeden Fall, ich mache nach wie vor gute Erfahrungen damit und
will auch nochmal kurz betonen,
dass meine Darstellung davon jetzt nicht heißt,
dass das bedeutet, dass jetzt alle Menschen programmieren können,
die es vorher nicht konnten.
Sondern es ist nach wie vor auf einem Level,
wo wir im Wesentlichen ein Werkzeug in die Hände legen können für Leute,
die eigentlich schon im Wesentlichen wissen, was sie tun und jetzt so ein bisschen
diesen Turbo noch zugeschaltet bekommen.
Also auch auf dieser Konferenz, wo ich war, also wenn du mal so ein bisschen
rumfragst und so, wie haltet ihr das so?
Irgendwie arbeitet ihr mit Claude und so? Und dann kriegst du einfach nur so
ein so ein Nicken und so ein, ja, weißt du noch damals irgendwie der ganze Boilerplate.
So, das ist jetzt irgendwie alles vorbei.
Ja, mein Lieblingstool Cursor macht weitere Fortschritte.
Also fast in jeder Sendung können wir ein neues Release berichten.
Das ist jetzt wieder der Fall.
Cursor 4.9 und man kann eigentlich sagen, die Truppe hört gut zu.
Wir werden da gleich nochmal ins Detail gehen.
Ja, aber man merkt, sie lernen.
Also ich habe immer wieder diesen Effekt, sie machen so ein Update und dann
ist wieder irgendwas gefixt, was mich wirklich sehr genervt hat.
Und mittlerweile bauen sie auch so Sachen ein, über die ich hier schon zuletzt
als Erfahrung berichtet hatte.
Also zum Beispiel das so, wenn man halt sozusagen damit sich Code erzeugen lässt,
dass man sich nicht nur den Code erzeugen lässt, sondern es auch ganz praktisch
ist, sich dabei Dokumentationen zu machen.
Mittlerweile gibt es hier richtig eingebaute Funktionalitäten und Automatiken,
dass wenn du jetzt eine längere Konversation hast und der Cursor dann selber
auch irgendwann meint so.
Das wird jetzt hier ein bisschen zu lang mit deinem Thread, weil dann hast du
zu viel Blabla drin und dann kannst du so einer LLM halt auch nichts Neues mehr,
abverlangen. Das kennen wir ja alle.
Sodass das Ding sich irgendwann nicht mehr groß bewegen lässt und sich einfach
so ein bisschen so angedickt hat mit dem ganzen Kontext, den man erschaffen hat.
Und dann gibt es jetzt zum Beispiel eine Funktion, wo du sagen kannst,
so ja, okay, ich schließe jetzt diese Konversation ab, aber die Essenz dieser
Konversation, also das, was wir so gelernt haben, das, was wir jetzt hier quasi
gemeinsam beschlossen und festgestellt haben.
Das kann dann sozusagen in ein Textdokument abgelegt werden und als Rule festgelegt werden.
Und auch das ganze Rule Management ist jetzt etwas selektiver,
dass man die Dinger ablegt und genau für jede Rule sagen kann,
gilt die immer, gilt die manchmal.
Wird die automatisch bei bestimmten Dateitypen nur dazu geschaltet und so weiter.
Weil du musst ja auch dein Kontext dann auch irgendwie nicht immer von vornherein
mit den Rules aufblähen. Das ist auch ein Problem.
Genau und jetzt kann man dann eben sich auch explizit auf solche Sachen beziehen,
das heißt du legst deinen Rules sozusagen einfach fest, wie du es gerne haben
möchtest, was du sicherstellen möchtest,
worum es in deinem Projekt geht oder was auch immer, wie dein Datenbankdesign
ist, wie du irgendwie generell mit deiner Programmiersprache arbeiten willst
oder welche Funktionalitäten du vielleicht irgendwie gar nicht haben willst,
was es auch immer ist und du kannst dich dann in deinem Dialog auch selektiv
auf einzelne Regelwerke beziehen und sagen so, das ist jetzt hier relevant für
diese Konversation. Das machen wir damit weiter.
Also entwickelt sich und es bleibt spannend und ich finde, die Ergebnisse werden
eigentlich immer besser.
Meistens wird es dann auch beachtet, was da in den Rules drin steht, aber auch nicht immer.
Also ich hatte auch Fälle, wo
ich dachte so, okay, das hatte ich doch aber eigentlich alles in der Art.
Hast du dir ins richtige Format gebracht? Weil den Fehler habe ich nämlich am
Anfang gemacht. Ich dachte nämlich am Anfang, es reicht einfach Textfiles reinzulegen.
Ja, sondern?
.mdc müssen diese Dateien heißen und dann kriegen die auch einen entsprechenden
Header und wenn du sie in .mdc umbenennst,
dann erscheint automatisch im Editor oben eine Liste von Optionen,
die du einstellen kannst für diese Rule und dadurch wird die eigentlich erst so richtig eine Rule.
Also ich habe das einfach in den Settings gemacht, wo es ja den eigenen Reiter
Rules gibt, sowohl für User Rules als auch Project Rules.
Ich meinte jetzt so per, achso in den Settings User Rules ähm achso hier Project Rules.
Live-Vibe-Coding mit der Freakshow.
Achso, ja, das habe ich da, habe ich das mal gemacht? Sie haben ja irgendwann
dieses Punkt Cursor-Rolls eingeführt und dann, oder jetzt Punkt Cursor-Rolls,
und dann habe ich eigentlich nur noch das verwendet.
Ich dachte, das wäre hier gar nicht mehr drin in den Settings, aber ist es wohl noch.
Ja, aber ich würde dir empfehlen, das sozusagen in das Projekt zu verlegen.
Naja, interessiert ja jetzt vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt alle,
Aber wir müssen jetzt nochmal über den Support-Fail diskutieren und vielleicht
auch nochmal so ein paar andere Security-Aspekte, die jetzt hier mit dem ganzen
Vibe-Coding neu aufs Tablett kommen.
Genau, es begab sich vor zwei Wochen ungefähr, dass Nutzer von Cursor in ein
Problem reingelaufen sind,
wo ich lustigerweise eine Woche vorher auch reingelaufen bin,
nämlich, dass so von einem Moment auf dem nächsten es nicht mehr ging,
Cursor auf verschiedenen Plattformen zu betreiben.
Ich hatte das Problem, hatte ich auch schon mal erzählt in einer frägerigen
Show, ich habe das mal so als Experiment bei uns in der Bibliothek gemacht,
mit Laien Vibe Coding ausprobiert und hatte dann insgesamt acht Laptops am Start
mit also quasi acht Teams, die dann einfach ein bisschen rumexperimentiert hatten
und dann sind auch coole Sachen bei rausgekommen.
und als ich das abends vorher vorbereitet hatte, hat er plötzlich so ab dem
siebten Laptop angefangen zu meckern und gesagt so, ich bin gerade auf ganz
schön vielen Plattformen gleichzeitig unterwegs.
Ich schalte jetzt mal deine Lizenz ab.
Das ist nicht das, was man haben will, wenn man am nächsten Tag einen Workshop
darauf irgendwie aufbaut.
Hat das dann technisch umgangen. Das war jetzt aber noch nicht die Dimension,
die es vor zwei Wochen hatte, wo es nämlich schon quasi bei dem zweiten Gerät
nicht mehr funktionierte. und die Lizenz irgendwo stillgelegt wurde.
Und das führte dann doch nachweislich zu einigen Chaos und Aufschrei in der
Community und Leute haben angefangen sich zu beschweren, weil also,
dass man noch nichtmals auf zwei Geräten das machen kann, das ist dann schon
von heute auf morgen, ohne das irgendwie mal mit ein bisschen Vorlauf zu kommunizieren,
ja schon ein wilder Ritt.
Und dann haben die Leute halt angefangen, an die Support-E-Mail zu schreiben
und bekamen dann eine Antwort auch schnell.
Ja, das sei jetzt Ausdruck von einer neuen Policy, wie jetzt eben hier mit den
Lizenzen umgegangen wäre.
Und Leute haben angefangen zu kündigen und Aufruhr auf Reddit und das Übliche.
Und dann kam raus, dass diese Support-E-Mails von der KI geschrieben worden
sind und überhaupt nicht von irgendeinem Support-Team von Cursor.
Ja, so grundsätzlich finde ich ja Eat Your Own Dog Food immer erst schon mal gut.
Das heißt also Dinge, die ich verkaufe, die muss ich auch täglich selber nutzen,
ansonsten habe ich keine Ahnung von dem, was ich da eigentlich irgendwie mache.
Wenn ich Ultraschall promote, dann muss ich es auch selber nutzen,
wenn ich einen Podcast mache. Das geht, finde ich, nicht anders.
Aber jetzt die Support-Schiene darüber LLM regeln zu lassen,
nach dem Motto, wir sind jetzt hier die Experten in Sachen KI und wir wissen,
dass das funktioniert, das ist schon risky.
Und hier ist es einfach denen mal so richtig ins Gesicht geflogen.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass sie da einen langfristigen Schaden jetzt raus davonziehen.
Klar, irgendwie Hacker News ist irgendwie heiß gelaufen und alle regen sich
auf und wir haben es schon immer gesagt und dieses KI-Zeug und Untergang des Abendlandes. aber.
Also ich finde es ist jetzt so ein schönes Anekdötchen, was man wieder dranhängen kann so dass,
auch die in Anführungszeichen Profis nicht davor gefeilt sind,
sich da mal über den Fuß zu schießen, aber ich glaube nicht dass es langfristig
jetzt an der Reputation von Cursor viel drehen wird vielleicht bin ich da auch naiv.
Aber das zeigt wie viel Feuer immer noch in diesem,
empfundene neuen Technologie, die man jetzt unbedingt einsetzen muss,
um Geld zu sparen, wie viel in dieser Hype-Curve noch drin ist,
dass Leute das tatsächlich auf die Idee kommen, das wäre eine gute Idee.
Also in der Sache ist die offizielle Erzählung, dass es halt einfach ein Konfigurationsfehler
war und dass es diese Policy nie gegeben hat.
Ja, Severance lässt grüßen, wir wissen es natürlich jetzt auch nicht.
Vielleicht war es auch irgendwie ein Experiment und Versuchsballon,
um zu gucken, okay, können wir noch die Monetarisierung ein bisschen hochschrauben,
indem wir mehr Lizenzen für mehr Devices verkaufen und sowas. Ist ja auch das denkbar.
Das ist auch immer wieder gerne bei den Usern.
Genau, ein Drittel der User schalten wir es ab, dem anderen nicht. Wir wissen es nicht.
Also ich glaube, Cursor ist definitiv noch nicht in der In-Shitification-Phase.
Also dafür wächst das ganze Projekt derzeit noch viel zu sehr.
Also die können jetzt einfach noch punkten, indem die Sache besser wird.
Deswegen glaube ich, ist das halt einfach nur ein bekloppter Fail gewesen.
Und dieses, wir probieren jetzt mal hier eine LLM bei Support-Mails aus.
Okay, ich würde sagen, so zum Filtern und zum Verstehen und zum Zuleiten vielleicht
eine gute Idee, automatische Antworten damit generieren, keine gute Idee.
Und das dürfen sich dann da in der Abteilung wahrscheinlich auch rumgesprochen
haben, dass sie sich damit halt mal schnell ihren ganzen Laden dicht machen können.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, es ist natürlich schon so, dass du mit einer LLM da
deutlich Geld sparst, weil wenn du da so ein Heer von Menschen ransetzt,
denen du dann auch irgendwie überhaupt erstmal kommunizieren musst, was sind die Fehler,
was sind die Policies der Company,
wenn sich jemand über das und das beschwert, kriegt er einen Refund oder kriegt
er dies oder kriegt er jenes, das ist schon,
es kostet schon eine Menge Geld, wenn man sowas unterhalten will, also insofern.
Also es ist ja ein ewiges Thema hier in dem ATP-Podcast der Apple Support und
das nicht existierende Bug-System,
wo immer gesagt wird, ja es ist halt einfach für eine Firma wie Apple auch einfach
ein Skalierungsproblem mit zig Milliarden Nutzern.
kannst du gar nicht genug Supporter auf die andere Seite stellen,
um irgendwie das Ganze irgendwie aufzufangen.
Also dass da alle hinterher sind, dort irgendwie Effizienzgewinne einzufahren,
das kann ich schon nachvollziehen.
Aber wie Tim sagt, du kannst es glaube ich gut machen für Klassifizierung,
dafür sind diese Dinge einfach ziemlich gut geeignet.
Da experimentieren wir auch in die eine oder andere Richtung.
Aber wenn es dann darum geht, konkrete Lösungen anzubieten, merkst du eben dann
doch so, ja das wird in 80% der Fälle funktionieren, aber die anderen 20% sind kritisch.
Dass das ursprüngliche Problem ein Konfigurationsfehler war,
das glaube ich Ihnen auch.
Solche Sachen passieren einfach. Aber,
hinterher das Support mit einer LLM, das war kein Konfigurationsfehler.
Das haben die doch absichtlich gemacht, oder?
Das haben sie mit Sicherheit, natürlich, klar.
Das ist halt peinlich, dass der Bruder das passiert.
Schon. Wir können ja mal so eine Zeitkapsel jetzt auch auswerten.
Also bei Microsoft wäre es jetzt keine Erwähnung wert.
Wir können ja mal jetzt hier an die Hörerinnen und Hörer eine Zeitkapsel.
In drei Jahren erinnert ihr uns daran, wie gang und gäbe ist dann eigentlich
schon, dass Support durch LLMs nur noch abgeliefert werden.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wir in genau so einer Welt landen,
weil die Firmen sagen, 80-20 reicht uns und Menschen im Support machen auch
Fehler und es ist so schwierig, gute Leute zu finden und alles schwierig.
Ich glaube, dass du einen First-Level-Support damit tatsächlich halbwegs abgebügelt
bekommst, das ist halt eine Risikofrage.
Weil dann die LLM entscheidet, ist die Frage eine First-Level-Frage oder eine Second-Level-Frage.
Also das ist so, naja.
Ja, anderes Problem, was diese ganze Vibe-Code-Reihe jetzt auch noch mit sich bringt,
ist, dass natürlich jetzt wieder die Bösewichte versuchen alles auszunutzen,
was irgendwie schief gehen kann und da ja wir es hier mit einem sehr diffusen
Werkzeug zu tun haben, tun sich dort auch eine ganze Menge neue Möglichkeiten
auf, Leute über den Tisch zu ziehen.
Neuester Trend, Slop-Squatting.
Wenn ich das gelesen habe, dachte ich so, meine Herren.
Habe ich in der Tat noch nicht von gehört und bin es gespannt.
Gut, Slop ist ja so der mittlerweile etablierte Begriff für Dreck,
den die AI rausschmeißt.
Eigentlich halt mehr in dem Sinne, dass man das Internet damit zu ballert,
um was weiß ich, Fake News zu verbreiten etc.
oder Suchindizes umzulenken und so weiter, der SEO-Kram.
Und das ist sozusagen der eigentliche Slop, also so Zeug, was halt irgendwie
in Massenhaft rausgeneriert wird und so tut, als wäre es irgendwie echt,
um andere Systeme dazu zu bringen, hier irgendwie das Falsche zu tun.
Und jetzt kennt man das auch, wenn man mit diesen Assistenten,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie man die nennen soll,
arbeitet und sagt so, was weiß ich, jetzt möchte ich jetzt hier irgendwie so ein Problem lösen.
Sagen wir mal, ja, ich möchte jetzt hier gerne in meiner Lieblingsprogrammiersprache,
möchte ich jetzt gerne MIDI-Daten versenden, um mal so ein Beispiel zu nennen.
JavaScript.
Gibt es denn da schon irgendwie eine Library dafür, die ich da verwenden kann?
Oder muss ich dafür eine verwenden?
Grübel, grübel, ja, alles kein Problem, dann musst du nur hier irgendwie das
inkluden, dann nimmst du hier so lib midi x und alles gar kein Problem und dann,
ich erzeug dir schon mal den Code und...
Package-Manager lädt dann diese Library auch automatisch runter.
Problem ist nur, LibMidiX gibt es gar nicht.
LibMidiX hat sich halt die LLM in dem Moment einfach ausgedacht,
weil bei Python gab es das. Ja, halluziniert.
Bei mir sprache nicht. Da bin ich also gerade am Anfang mit Elixir laufend reingefallen.
Wie geil, echt wirklich sowas gibt es? Und dann haben wir so nachgeguckt und
dann Github, Nix, Hex, irgendwie ganzen Package-Manager alle nur im Kopf geschüttelt.
Naja, das haben aber jetzt sozusagen Leute für sich nützbar gemacht,
weil die halt auch dieselben Prompts abwerfen und merken,
welche Library-Namen sie sich ausdenken und jetzt werden sozusagen von Malicious
Hackers genau diese fehlenden Libraries in die entsprechenden Repositories hochgeladen.
Dann gibt es nämlich auf einmal LibMediX, aber LibMediX macht halt nicht unbedingt
das, was die AI gesagt hat, was BDX macht, sondern irgendwelches andere böse Zeug.
Ein Supply Chain Attack nennt man sowas.
Eine Supply Chain Attack, genau. Das ist, glaube ich, das Richtige.
Und das führt natürlich dann dazu, dass wir jetzt so eine neue Generation von
Slop haben, also Code, der keiner ist.
Der nur dafür generiert wird und unter sozusagen Platzhalternamen platziert
wird, damit du dann irgendwie drauf trittst auf diese Tretmine und das benutzt.
Es gab auch, glaube ich, schon mal so einen ähnlichen Fall, der jetzt nicht
so AI-related war, wo genau dieses Problem auch war. Das war doch mit irgendeiner.
Bitcoin-spezifischen Library, die auch jemand, nee, es war eine,
nee, stimmt, das war auch aus der LLM.
Da hat die LLM gesagt, ja hier, du musst irgendwie, genau, du musst diese Web-API
benutzen und das war dann irgendwie,
Bitcoin-Plattform XY-API.com,
Ja, die es aber nicht gab, sondern die quasi von jemandem, der LLM so zugedichtet
wurde mit entsprechendem Slop.
Also sie haben es halt sozusagen im Web gehabt und irgendwie dafür gesorgt,
dass auch diese LLM das irgendwie ordentlich gepasst hat, weil da ganz viel
Dokumentation dabei ist und dann steht das da drin.
da schickst du dann deine Wallet irgendwie hin weg war die Wallet also it's
a real thing und da muss man natürlich super aufpassen aber das ist halt wieder
dieses selbe Ding wenn man halt einfach so,
ja so blander ans Internet herantritt und sagt so ja gib her ich lade mir alles
runter ich benutze jede API, jede Webseite ich gucke mir.
Nichts einmal an aber das ist ja ein allgemeines LLM Problem Also LLM ist ja
im Prinzip Quelle Internet und du weißt nicht, was dahinter steckt.
Ja, genau.
Und ob das jetzt stimmt, was dir die LLM erzählt hat oder ob das halt nur irgendein
Wacko auf irgendeiner Webseite behauptet hat?
Das ist sehr schwierig nachzuvollziehen und deswegen brauchst du andere Verifikationsmaßnahmen.
Und da muss man natürlich dann als agierender und Profiteur solcher Systeme
auch ein wenig Eigenaktivität entwickeln, weil noch, denke ich mal,
ist es absolut zumutbar,
dass man eben auch hier, wie auch bei Nachrichten, eine Verifikation betreibt,
speziell wenn man programmiert.
weil das ne, with the great programming languages comes great power und auch,
mit great power hat man auch große Verantwortung für sich und andere so,
wenn man solche Systeme baut und dann muss man schon ein bisschen aufpassen
Gelernt bei Spiderman, ja,
Oder wie Hollywood uns,
moralisch auf Vordermann bringt Ja, ja So ist das.
Wo wir schon bei Dingen, die im Internet schief gehen, sind,
wollte ich kurz über Spiele sprechen.
Und zwar, das habe ich wirklich nur sehr am Rande gefunden, es gibt etwas,
das nennt sich der Digital Fairness Act.
Da hat also tatsächlich Leute in der EU angefangen, sich mal Gedanken darüber
zu machen, was denn Spiele bitteschön nicht machen sollen.
Und da steht eigentlich alles drin, was man an modernen Spielen so nicht mag.
Also Dark Patterns in Interfaces, Addictive Design, Personalized Targeting,
bla bla bla, diesen ganzen Kram.
Witzigerweise, ich habe nicht so ganz verstanden, ob das schon eine Richtlinie
ist oder ob die noch nicht durch ist,
aber in Schweden wurde tatsächlich schon eine Firma verknackt,
deswegen und zwar Star Stable heißen die.
irgendwas mit Pferden, also nee, das Spiel heißt Star Stable,
irgendwas mit Pferden, aber da ist es, ähm, da ist es tatsächlich auch so,
dass man so von der Lootbox über,
äh, irgendwie, äh, man muss in-Game-Währung kaufen, um irgendwelche Dinge,
digitale Dinge in dem Spiel zu kaufen, aber die Pakete sind so geschnürt,
dass du dann hinterher Coins über hast, Die du aber trotzdem bezahlen musst
und so weiter und so weiter.
Und also wenn das noch weitergeht, kann ich jetzt auch nicht so richtig viel
dazu sagen, wie der Fall jetzt weiterläuft,
dann wird es großen Einfluss auf die Spieleindustrie haben und zwar vor allen
Dingen auf die, würde ich mal sagen, Mobile Games, die wirklich mit all diesen
miesen Tricks arbeiten,
um die Leute abhängig zu machen und ihnen dann mit.
Anderen Sachen irgendwie das Geld aus der Tasche zu ziehen da ist die EU mal
wieder Vorreiter darin die Amis einzugrenzen in dem was die Firmen dort machen dürfen,
gibt so viele Leute, die sich über die DSGVO aufregen, aber ich finde es ja nach wie vor sehr gut,
was da passiert ja, ich wollte es nur mal erwähnt haben.
Also diese Webseite, die du da gerade gepostet hast, bist du sicher,
also das ist ja von einer deutschen Firma gepostet.
Der Digital Fairness Act?
Ja, das ist die Cyber Risk GmbH und ich versuche gerade so aus diesem Text ein
wenig herauszulesen, was es denn jetzt vor sich hat, also es gab wohl ein Digital Fairness,
Fitness-Check, der von der europäischen Kommission oder im Auftrage derselben durchgeführt wurde.
Aber von einem Act in dem Sinne ist jetzt hier glaube ich noch nicht so richtig die Rede.
Okay, also es wird diskutiert, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Es wird, ja, ja genau, es wird diskutiert. Genau, ist noch kein ist noch keine echte Sache im.
Mitte,
2026 kann man frühestens mit einem Vorschlag rechnen für einen solchen Act.
Richtig, aber trotzdem sind sie schon gegen diese Star Stable Entertainment
AB vorgegangen und wenn sie damit auch ohne diesen Act durchkommen,
dann wird es natürlich relativ knapp gegenüber Firmen.
Also ich meine, die Sache mit den Lootboxes, ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, Lootboxes sind ja im Prinzip Kisten,
die man kaufen kann, wo dann irgendwas drin ist.
Per Zufall bekommt man da gute Items oder auch schlechte Items.
Also meinst du so zurückgesendete oder nicht zugestellte Pakete oder nicht angenommene Pakete?
Nee, Lootboxen ist in einem Spiel.
Ach so, innerhalb eines Spiels.
Kannst du eine Kiste mit Dingen kaufen, die spielerelevant sind und das sind
entweder bessere Dinge, also
Rare Items oder Legendary Items oder halt irgendwelches nutzloser Tant.
Und da hat ja schon, haben EU-Gerichte ja schon entschieden, dass das,
Glücksspiel wäre und dass die entsprechenden Spiele, die sowas anbieten,
dann ab 18 bitte sein müssen und dann ging es plötzlich ganz schnell Und dann
haben die Firmen sich gegen die Lootboxen entschieden, zumindest im europäischen Markt.
Allerdings scheint diese Idee von der Lootbox immer noch nicht so ganz raus
zu sein aus den Köpfen derer, die da in Spieleindustrie größere Menschen sind.
aber,
also da tut sich was ich finde das sollte man auf jeden Fall mal weiter begucken
ich kann ja jetzt auch so viel nicht mehr zu sagen aber ich fand es ganz interessant
dass das tatsächlich auch dieses,
die Leute über den Tisch ziehen mit solchen kleinen Spielen dass das tatsächlich
inzwischen auch bei der Legislative angekommen ist und sich da was bewegt,
All right.
So, ich habe dann noch eine Frage. Und zwar, ich habe mich ja irgendwie in meiner,
wie nennt man das, Karriere?
Nee, in meinem digitalen Leben.
Karriere, scheiß Wort.
Seit ich mich also mit Computern beschäftige, habe ich immer mal so Phasen gehabt,
wo ich mich so intensiv mit einem bestimmten Genre von Software auseinandergesetzt
habe, um dann, sagen wir mal, so ein bisschen meinen Führerschein darin zu machen.
Also nicht wirklich, dass mir jetzt jemand abnimmt, aber ich habe mich so intensiv
zum Beispiel mit Textverarbeitung mal beschäftigt, dass ich irgendwie mich berufen
fühle, darüber qualifiziert abzuranden,
was ich irgendwie gut oder schlecht finde an Textverarbeitungssystemen.
Hörer der Freakshow wissen Bescheid.
Ich bin einfach in der Lage, große Dokumente zu erstellen und ich weiß,
was man so erwarten kann von seiner Textverarbeitung.
Also das habe ich zum Beispiel intensiv betrieben.
Ich habe auch mit so Photoshop ähnlichen Programmen sehr viel Erfahrung gesammelt.
Ich hatte mal eine sehr intensive Auseinandersetzung mit Freehand,
sodass ich auch über Vektorprogramme weitgehend Bescheid weiß.
Ich habe, glaube ich, auch mich genug in Typografie eintauchen lassen,
um richtig einschätzen zu können, was ist und auch in der Lage zu sein,
immer das richtige Werkzeug zu wählen, um in irgendeiner Form digitale Inhalte zu erstellen.
Wo ich eigentlich immer einen großen Bogen drumherum gemacht habe, ist 3D-Software.
Und ich habe da einfach keinerlei, mit 3D-Software ist so ein bisschen wie mit
Spielen, also da habe ich irgendwie so,
keine Ahnung, nie eine Anwendung für gefunden und das hat mich irgendwie alles
nicht so beschäftigt, sodass ich da jetzt relativ unbelesen bin in diesem Bereich.
Und jetzt würde ich aber ganz gerne,
weil wir jetzt dann doch langsam vor zunehmendem Maße in die Situation kommen,
dass so dreidimensionale Planung ein Ding ist,
gerne da ein bisschen mehr Tuchfüllung aufnehmen.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich so die absoluten Mega-Profi-Tools, keine Ahnung,
so AutoCAD und die ganze Architektur-Kram oder was ihr verwendet für eure 3D-Drucker
zum Beispiel, verschiedene Tools.
Naja, das sind ja CAD-Software im Allgemeinen.
Also ich persönlich bin jetzt ein bisschen auf dem Fusion 360-Trip,
also wahrscheinlich wird die Hälfte der Hörerschaft jetzt die Hände über dem
Kopf zusammenschlagen, aber für mich funktioniert es halbwegs.
Ja, weil es halt Autodesk ist halt seit AutoCAD eigentlich seit den 80er Jahren schon dabei.
Man merkt es der Software auch irgendwie recht stark an und dann haben die halt
auch so, du musst dich immer einloggen, wenn du diese Software benutzen willst und so weiter.
Das ist alles nur so mittelgeil, aber für mich funktioniert sie halbwegs gut.
Okay, aber das ist natürlich so Software, um dreidimensionale Objekte zu erzeugen Primär.
Engineering aller Art, ja.
Genau.
Also mein erster Ansatz war halt, da brauchst du eine Gaming Engine.
Also jetzt gar nicht im Profi.
Ich habe ja noch gar nicht gesagt, was ich halt machen will.
Achso, ja genau, dann erzähl doch was.
Und mir geht es ja weniger jetzt um, ich will irgendein Objekt erzeugen,
sondern mir geht es eigentlich mehr so um so Raumplanung.
Also sozusagen Modellierung großer Räume oder um es mal anders auszudrücken
oder konkreter zu werden vielmehr.
Wenn ich jetzt solche Sachen mache wie Blinkenlights, also solche Lichtinstallationen
im Raum in einem beliebigen Space, das kann ein Platz sein, ein Haus sein,
eine freie Fläche sein, dann ist es jetzt ein bisschen verlockend mit all diesen
Möglichkeiten und insbesondere natürlich auch als Besitzer einer Apple Vision Pro.
Weil es jetzt wirklich die Möglichkeit gibt, diesen 3D-Kram sich auch mal dreidimensional
anzuschauen und so zu erfahren, um dann eben auch zu testen,
okay, habe ich jetzt hier die richtigen Dimensionen gewählt?
Habe ich die richtigen Abstände gewählt? Wie wirkt das im Kontext von irgendwas anderem?
Also wäre es schön, ein Modellierungs-Environment zu haben, was einem jetzt
nicht zu viel abverlangt,
um solche Szenerien einerseits zu erschaffen,
Auch auf einem zweidimensionalen Screen schon mal leidlich zu modellieren und
dann eben im Idealfall auch dreidimensional sich zu visualisieren.
Ja, und da habe ich jetzt gar keine richtige Antwort drauf. Das ist auch ein relativ neuer Gedanke.
Tatsächlich, ich habe da jetzt noch nicht viel Zeit mit verbracht,
aber das wäre natürlich schon ganz interessant und die Frage ist halt auch,
muss es dann auch so ein Stück Software sein in dem Sinne oder geht man da nicht
vielleicht am besten sogar gleich programmatisch ran?
weil während jetzt 3D-Programmierung außerhalb meines Scopes war bisher,
würde ich halt sagen mit Vibe-Coding werden halt auch solche Sachen auf einmal
ganz interessant, weil mir geht
es ja mehr so eine, ich will ja kein Game entwickeln, sondern ich will ja,
prototypisch eine relativ einfache Szene machen,
aber wenn man dann eben so ein Runtime-Environment bespielt wo man Dinge platzieren
kann und Und dann kann man sich das irgendwie halt dynamisch anschauen und sich
da drin bewegen, um mal zu gucken, wie sieht es denn aus.
Wäre das ja unter Umständen auch eine Anstrengung wert.
Also meine Meinung nach ist, probiere eine Game Engine aus.
Also Unreal Engine ist sehr full-featured.
Also du hast hinterher, wenn du die richtigen Assets einsetzt,
fasst einen fotorealistischen Blick auf die Welt.
Unity ist, jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass es um die Lizenz ganz fürchterlich
Streit gab, eigentlich auch ein Blick wert.
Dazu kann ich ja nichts sagen, weil ich das noch nicht mal runtergeladen habe irgendwo.
Genau und als Open Source gibt es noch Godot 4.
Stimmt, Godot wurde immer als der Nachfolger von Unity gehandelt,
besonders für kleinere Spiele.
Godot ist tatsächlich insofern interessant, dass das jetzt sogar durchgesickert
ist, dass Apple die Godot Entwicklung fördern möchte für die Apple Vision Pro.
Genau, mein Hauptpunkt war halt so, wie du es vorhin erzählt hast,
sind halt vor allen Dingen so eben Landschaftssachen irgendwie jetzt dein Fokus.
Also sprich ein kleines Wäldchen, in dem irgendwas passiert oder ähnliches,
also irgendwas Outdoor.
Und da ist man, glaube ich, dann bei den Gaming-Engines einfach grundsätzlich
schon mal richtig aufgehoben, weil das halt deren Home-Turf ist.
Ja, besonders wenn du es schaffst, irgendwo eine Terrain-Map runterzuladen,
so ein Höhenprofil, da setzt du ein paar Bäume rein und dann hast du schon relativ
gute Vorstellungen, wie das Ding tatsächlich ist.
Genau, also all diese drei, die wir jetzt hier hatten, Unity,
Unreal und Codo, die haben alle drei halt so einen Terrain-Editor,
wo du einfach erstmal so Parameter reingibst.
So und so ist das Höhenprofil, so und so viel Prozent ist der Bewuchs und baue
mal und dann kriegst du schon eigentlich eine perfekte Szene und dann musst
du nur noch deine im Assets-Store nachgucken, was sieht so aus wie das Element,
was ich eigentlich habe, was kommt dem möglichst ähnlich und dann platzierst
du die rein und dann bist du ehrlich gesagt wahrscheinlich in sehr kurzer Zeit schon fertig.
Und dann hast du natürlich keinerlei jetzt irgendwie Logik drin,
ja, so, wenn dies, dann tue das, aber auch den Pfad hast du ja auch noch offen.
Das heißt also, wenn du dann so kommen willst, okay, du willst dann auch wirklich
eine Animation drin abspielen oder es soll interaktiv sein oder sowas,
das nimmt dir dann auch keiner weg, sondern dafür sind die Game Engines natürlich
dann auch ganz hervorragend geeignet.
Ja, das stimmt.
Die Frage ist halt, wie ist die Lernkurve dieser Engines, das kann ich überhaupt nicht einschätzen.
Ja, die Frage ist eher, was wissen die LLMs über diese Engines?
Könnte ich mir vorstellen eine Menge, weil es natürlich total Middle-of-the-Road-Technik
ist seit Jahrzehnten ja fast abgehängt ich meine Unity oder hier Unreal,
das da haben wir vor 25 Jahren schon bei den Medienwissenschaften mit rumgeprockelt Naja.
Sowohl Unreal als auch Unity haben wir sehr sehr viel Energie da reingelegt
dass das das Erstellen von Spielen und Modellen und Umgebungen und so weiter gut zu machen ist.
Also es ist nicht einfach nur ein Stück Technik, was hinterher ein fertiges
Modell gut rendert, sondern es ist tatsächlich auch ein Authoring-Tool.
Also beide eigentlich.
Insofern ja, keine Ahnung.
Godot Vision. Interesting.
Also das glaube ich lohnt einen Blick, wenn man sowas machen möchte.
Mhm.
Genau, aber das scheint ja, okay, jetzt Support eher noch für Volumes,
also sozusagen für Objekte, bis man da wirklich so eine Umgebung hat.
Das wollen wir mal gucken.
Genau, also darauf musst du halt achten, also dein Fokus ist eben nicht die
perfekte Modellierung eines Objektes, dass dann möglichst realistisch und die
Oberflächentexturen sitzen, sondern
du willst eine Szenerie möglichst niedrigschwellig halt irgendwie bauen.
Das sind schon zwei sehr unterschiedliche Szenarien.
Okay, aber Unity scheint auch explizit einen Vision OS Support zu haben.
Ja, ich glaube Unreal Engine eigentlich auch, obwohl sich ja die Unreal Leute
und die Apple Leute so gar nicht mögen.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen so ein Problem. Ich weiß nicht, was ist denn so
die beste Engine? Weiß man das?
Die beste Engine ist immer wofür.
Genau.
Also ganz offen Offensichtlich gibt es mehrere davon, weil sie alle ihre Nische gefunden haben.
Die Unreal Engine ist halt die große AAA Game Engine, wo inzwischen halt wirklich
viele Spiele mitgemacht werden.
Ja, okay, ob die gut ist oder nicht, das muss jeder für sich entscheiden.
Aber das ist zumindest wirklich eine Hausnummer und ein fettes Ding.
Für deine Anwendung ist es eventuell ein bisschen over the top?
Also, wenn ich das alles noch richtig recalle und nach zwei,
drei Recherchen hier gerade.
Die Unreal Engine hat eine deutlich steilere Lernkurve als die anderen Sachen.
Dafür hast du dann quasi hinterher die beste Grafikqualität.
Aber es ist einfach so das Profitool, wenn es pixelperfekt alles sein muss.
So, die Unity Engine hat große Community, einsteigerfreundlich, viele Assets.
Damit kommt man sicherlich gut klar.
Und die Godot ist noch einfacher, wohl vom Einstieg her, noch weiter unten drunter,
ist aber halt in Sachen Grafikqualität dann sehr deutlich hinter der Unreal
und auch noch deutlich unterhalb der Unity.
Ja, das ist schon sehr, sehr so ein Independent, wenige Leute Game Engine,
wo du halt ein simples Spiel mit einer simplen Engine baust.
Ja, also von daher jetzt so Pi mal Daumen hätte ich gesagt,
guck dir vielleicht mal kurz Godot an und wenn du den Eindruck hast,
das ist irgendwie dann doch alles noch nicht so auf dem Niveau,
wie du es hättest, dann bist du wahrscheinlich bei Unity richtig aufgehoben. Unreal halte ich für.
Übertrieben.
Sind sinnlos.
Und die heißen Apple. Das geht ja gar nicht.
Sie haben sich halt mit Apple angelegt. Die 30 Prozent und so.
Dieser Epic-Chef, wie heißt er denn? Keine Ahnung.
Mal schauen.
Ja, wir sind ja ein bisschen von unserem Haus Einrichtungsthema ein bisschen weggekommen.
Aber ich könnte auch noch mal von meiner Reise berichten.
Ich habe ja auf dem auf meiner Fahrt durch Großbritannien,
Wisst ihr, was Großbritannien ist?
Ja, da war mal was. Die gehört mal zu Europa. Naja, so England.
Nee.
Wie?
Also ja, auch irgendwie, aber kennst du den Unterschied zwischen Großbritannien und,
den britischen Inseln und Irland und England und Wales und Fortschland und dem
Vereinigten Königreich.
Auf dem Festland interessiert es niemand. Das sind die Inselaffen und fertig.
Wir hatten es auch in der Sendung schon mal.
Naja, man muss ja konkret sein. Und ich war halt in Großbritannien.
Also nicht in UK.
Großbritannien ist die rechte Insel von den britischen Inseln.
Die große Insel.
Ja, die große rechte Insel, die größte und die deckt halt die Fläche von England,
Wales und Schottland ab.
Da war ich und ich war aber nicht in Wales, sondern ich war nur in England und in Schottland.
Also warst du nicht in ganz Großbritannien?
Nein, nur in kleinen Großbritannien.
Nordirland ist eine Reise wert, allerdings muss man eine gewisse Vorstellung
von Abenteuerurlaub haben.
Ja, naja, also ich hatte auch eine gewisse Vorstellung von Abenteuerurlaub und
habe mir einfach ein elektrisches Mietauto genommen.
Das war dann schon mal so eine Sache, weil ich wollte natürlich auf gar keinen
Fall einen Tesla zugeteilt bekommen und man hat ja immer so keine klare Macht
darüber, was man denn nun am Ende wirklich für ein Fahrzeug bekommt,
weil du kriegst halt das, was auf dem Hof steht und die anderen sind halt alle aus.
ich hatte dann allerdings,
Glück kann man das so sagen, naja ich habe dann ein BMW iX1 gefahren,
ehrlich gesagt ein Auto von dem ich vorher gar nicht wusste, dass es das gibt.
Was ist ein.
BMX? BMW iX1 die macht es einem auch nicht leicht also es ist,
ist auch ein merkwürdiges Fahrzeug Also fahren tun die sich immer gut,
aber wenn dann die Software kommt, dann wird es irgendwie ganz schauderig.
Also ich verstehe nicht, was bei BMW, was sie für einen Film fahren mit ihren
User Interfaces. Also es ist einfach...
Ich staune immer wieder, wie kompliziert man einfache Sachen machen kann.
Es ist nicht ganz so schlimm, wie man es annehmen könnte, aber es ist halt auch
noch beileibe nicht so gut.
Das sind Bayern.
Ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau, ich will jetzt auch nicht so sehr auf BMW schimpfen,
weil tatsächlich hatte ich am meisten Probleme mit CarPlay und hatte die ganze
Zeit irgendwelche Disconnects und habe geflucht,
weil dieses Fahrzeug natürlich nur Wireless CarPlay gemacht hat und nicht einfach
mal Kabel ran und dann ist es da und so.
nein, Bluetooth-Pairing, hier diese Nummer eingeben, ja, jetzt nochmal rechts
den Rahmen streicheln, warten Sie,
bis das Gerät die richtige Temperatur hat und dann tausend abfragen,
möchtest du all deine Kontakte auf dieses Auto kopieren? Nein, will ich nicht.
Auf gar keinen Fall. All diese ganzen Unsinn. Und wenn du dann mal durch bist,
dann hast du vielleicht halt auch wirklich mal CarPlay und dann find erst mal
wieder raus, wann dann jetzt irgendwie kannst du dann, wenn dann die Navi von
deinem iPhone drauf ist?
Warum kann man dann nicht mehr in die normale Navi rein? Warum kann man die nicht beide verwenden?
Das sind alles so Fragen, die jetzt hier auch nicht weiter interessieren.
Ich habe also mich ein wenig mit diesem Auto geboxt.
Ich muss aber eben sagen, zur Ehrenrettung von BMW,
ich hatte ja diese ganzen Connection-Probleme und musste mich permanent neu
connecten, dass kurz danach kam irgendwie iOS 18.4.1 raus mit dem Hinweis des CarPlay.
Die CarPlay-Probleme sind jetzt weg.
Ja, vielen Dank, gerade irgendwie zwei Stunden, nachdem ich das Auto wieder zurückgegeben habe.
Ja, das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Ja, tatsächlich jetzt mit CarPlay-Problemen oder was?
Ja.
Achso, okay, gut, it's real.
War mindestens zum Teil auch ein Apple-Problem.
Ja, okay, gut. Von daher nehme ich sie jetzt da mal raus, aber sie hätten ja
trotzdem einfach auch Wired CarPlay unterstützen können und dann hätte ich diese
Probleme unter Umständen gar nicht gehabt.
Das macht mein Auto und das ist eigentlich immer relativ zuverlässig.
Genau, das wäre auch für mich ein Kaufkriterium, wenn ich jetzt erwogen hätte,
dieses Auto zu kaufen, was ich nicht habe.
Anyway, ich war also mit diesem Fahrzeug unterwegs und naja,
da stellt sich dann halt immer wieder die Frage, okay, was ist denn jetzt die
Elektrofahrrealität in Großbritannien und die Fahrrealität in Großbritannien ist?
Auf der linken Straßenseite.
Auf der linken Straßenseite, ja auf jeden Fall.
Sie ist eigentlich, ich würde sagen, es ist genauso wie in Deutschland.
Mit anderen Worten, du hast genug Infrastruktur für Autos.
Du hast eine scheiß Infrastruktur, wenn es um AC-Laden geht.
Jetzt war ich nicht mit dem Motorrad unterwegs und auf AC angewiesen.
Aber während halt du an jeder großen Ladesäule, also ausnahmslos,
ich habe keine Ladekarte dabei gehabt oder so.
Ich habe natürlich die Autovermietung gefragt, haben sie einfach mal eine Mietwagen-Ladekarte,
die überall funktioniert?
Ich meine, warum haben die sowas nicht?
Haben die denn Tankkarten, die überall funktionieren?
Also Tankkarten, weiß ich nicht, ob die die haben. Das war aber,
sagen wir mal, auch noch nie jetzt wirklich ein Problem zu tanken und es ist
auch nie ein Problem fürs Tanken zu bezahlen.
Aber es ist sehr wohl ein Problem zu laden und fürs Laden zu bezahlen.
Zumindest in Deutschland.
Und es ist jetzt tatsächlich kein Problem gewesen zu laden und auch kein,
also weitgehend kein Problem gewesen zu laden und auch kein Problem dafür zu
bezahlen, weil ausnahmslos alle,
DC, also Gleichstrom, Ladesäulen in England, alle konnten mit Kreditkarte betrieben werden.
Piep, Uhr ranhalten, lädt.
Also es gab mal eine, da war es kaputt, aber sie hatte das.
Ich habe keine einzige Ladesäule in England angetroffen, wo ich nicht mit einer
Kreditkarte, direkt so mit der Apple Watch, irgendwie Apple Pay, zack, laden konnte.
Soweit Pluspunkte.
Haben die das da im Gesetz vorgeschrieben?
Das weiß ich nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall Realität.
Okay.
Und davon sind wir in Deutschland ganz weit von entfernt.
Aber hallo.
Ja, wovon allerdings Deutschland auch ganz weit von entfernt ist,
sind die Preise. Das ist nämlich so arschteuer in Großbritannien.
Was kostet das denn da?
Unfassbar. Also ich habe bis zu 1 Euro pro Kilowattstunde bezahlt.
Das schaffst du in Deutschland auch mit, wenn du die falsche Ladekarte oder
die falschen Anbieter doch schaffst?
Maximal 90 Cent. Mehr habe ich noch nie gesehen. Noch nie. 1 Euro auf gar keinen Fall.
Das ist eine Weile her, aber ich habe schon mal 1,20 Euro gesehen.
Ja. Ernsthaft? Okay, gut. Vielleicht sind die Zeiten schon wieder vorbei.
Aber die sind volatil, die Preise. Es passt sich immer mal wieder an.
Aber es war überall teuer. Also es war nicht so, dass ich auch mal bis zu einem
Euro kam und ansonsten war es die Hälfte. Unter,
90 Cent war irgendwie nichts zu holen. Also total blöd.
Ja. Was soll ich sagen?
Aber funktioniert hat es schon.
Es hat funktioniert. Man kriegt nicht unbedingt immer die Ladegeschwindigkeit,
die man so erwarten würde.
Was erwartest du denn?
Naja, das Fahrzeug kann 120, 130 Kilowatt.
Ja, aber?
Und die Ladesäulen konnten eigentlich alle so, wenn sie 150 konnten,
dann bin ich einmal bei 110 angekommen und ansonsten haben sie meistens so mit
75 geladen, also ungefähr die Hälfte von dem, was sie theoretisch könnten.
Und die 50 Kilowatt Ladesäulen, die haben bestenfalls so 35 gemacht.
Du kennst aber die typische Ladekurve eines Autos?
Ja, aber wenn das Ding so zu ein Viertel geladen ist...
25% kriegst du oftmals noch nicht das Maximum. Du musst weiter runterfahren auf 15 oder so.
Und dann bekommst du das Maximum an Ladegeschwindigkeit auch nur für ein paar
Prozentpunkte und dann geht die Kurve schon runter.
Das ist ganz normal. Machen alle Autos.
Ja, aber ist dann halt auch langsam.
Nee gut, ich meine oberhalb 80 Prozent wird es langsam, oberhalb 90 Prozent wird es sehr langsam.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar. Aber so in der Mitte irgendwann,
ich meine, das Blöde ist eigentlich, dass diese Ladesäulen einem einfach auch
keinen Dienst leisten in dem Sinne, als dass sie mal einem die Ladekurve anzeigen würden.
Nee, die Kurve nicht, sondern nur die gerade.
Was gerade passiert. Du stehst ja nicht eine Stunde daneben und schreibst ja
alle 10 Sekunden auf, was da jetzt gerade an Kilowatt angezeigt wird.
Aber es ist ja auch vollkommen unmöglich, auf so einem riesigen DIN A4 Display,
was sie da haben, was voll ist mit Werbung und sinnlosem Text,
vielleicht einfach mal die fucking Ladekurve anzuzeigen, damit man es weiß.
Aber nein, das ist alles nicht möglich.
Da kann ich aber mit dienen und zwar...
Schickt einem sowas dann nicht das Auto aufs Smartphone? Hätte ich jetzt irgendwie... erwartet.
Das Auto auf Smartphone. Oh ja, ich habe natürlich auch versucht,
mein Telefon mit diesem Auto zu paren.
Es gibt von Fastnet. Fastnet ist ein niederländischer Anbieter.
Gibt es auf dieser Seite, die ich da gerade gepostet habe, gibt es einen Überblick,
welche Autos welche Ladekurven haben, weil die tatsächlich,
die entsprechenden Daten,
da erheben und dann Kurven plotten. Und was hattest du, den iX1?
IX1, ich gucke auch gerade mal.
Der sieht so aus, der müsste etwas über 120 können, bis er ungefähr bei 40%
ist. Und dann geht er linear runter.
An einem 300 Kilowatt Charger, maximal 130. Ja, also das kann ich halt nicht
bestätigen, das hatte ich da irgendwie nicht.
Okay, gut, das kann am Charger liegen, das kann am Auto liegen.
Ja, was auch immer. Also ist auf jeden Fall nicht so begrenzt befriedigend.
Also Fastnet, Ladegeschwindigkeiten, diese Seite kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Wenn man Fragen dazu hat, was für ein Auto will man denn und wie schnell soll
es denn bitteschön laden können, da kann ich wirklich sehr empfehlen.
Machen die schon seit Jahren.
So, dann habe ich den anderen Härtetest gemacht und bin mit meinem anderen BMW,
mit meinem Moped, meiner CE 04, habe ich mal den Sport gemacht und bin mal in
eine andere Stadt gefahren, also in eine andere Großstadt, sprich nach Hamburg.
300 Kilometer zu überbrücken mit einem Fahrzeug, was so nominell 110,
120 Kilometer Reichweite hat, so theoretisch oder sagen wir mal ab Werk offiziell
bis zu 130, wie es so schön heißt.
Was aber sagen wir mal sehr sehr viele kleine Sternchen dahinter hat und dann
muss man unten in der Fußnote.
Wo der Rückenwind und der Mond steht.
Genau. Und die Temperatur und Gegenwind und naja, ich würde sagen,
es macht halt einfach sehr viel aus, wie man fährt.
Aber wenn man jetzt irgendwie über die Landstraße fährt und eh ein paar Stunden
unterwegs sein wird, dann will man ja auch nicht unbedingt 50 fahren. so.
Zumal eben...
Hypermiling ist ein Sport, aber...
Ja, das ist... Das ist kein Reisemodus. Man muss sich das natürlich schon überlegen.
Also natürlich gebe ich jetzt nicht Vollgas und fahre irgendwie die maximale
Geschwindigkeit, was bei dem Fahrzeug 120 wäre, weil dann ist der Akku halt
in Nukumanix alle und dann komme ich halt nicht weit.
Und dann, weil das Laden noch so viel länger dauert als das Fahren,
verzögere ich sozusagen alles noch sehr viel mehr.
Also man muss schon so eine Geschwindigkeit finden, die ein inakzeptabler Geschwindigkeit,
möglichst weit bringt, ohne dass man es zu sehr übertreibt, um dann die Pause
einzulegen und weiterzuschauen.
Und das Ding ist, mittlerweile findet man halt bei diesen ganzen Routenplaner-Apps,
die es mal gab für Elektrofahrzeuge, nicht mehr viel Freunde als Motorradfahrer,
weil man überhaupt erstmal eine findet, wo man sagen kann,
mich interessiert nur AC oder mein Fahrzeug ist ein Motorrad.
Hast du Pump versucht?
Ja, Pump ist das Einzige, was für mich überhaupt so halbwegs funktioniert.
Ich kann das bestätigen.
Auch nur so begrenzt, weil mittlerweile eben für Autos das Problem eigentlich weitgehend weg ist.
Ja, wenn man schnell laden kann.
Dann kann man an der Autobahn eigentlich auch immer alle 50 Kilometer einen Schnelllader finden.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht in Brandenburg, aber ansonsten schon.
Ja, aber wenn du jetzt von Berlin nach Hamburg fährst, dann könntest du einfach
an jeder Autobahnraststätte wahrscheinlich mittlerweile laden, oder?
Ja, zumindest an jeder zweiten.
Genau, und du brauchst dann eben auch mit den Reichweiten, die ein Auto hat,
musst du halt vielleicht einmal laden.
Ging mir so, ja. Ich war ja auch in Hamburg.
Aber für Zweiräder, was ja sozusagen so ein Sport ist, der komplett ignoriert
wird, weil erstens hat ja keiner ein elektrisches Motorrad.
Und warum haben die Leute kein elektrisches Motorrad? Weil keiner welche baut,
weil die Leute nicht danach fragen, weil es die Infrastruktur dafür nicht gibt.
Henne Ei, wieder von vorne, aber interessiert natürlich keinen Menschen,
weil Zweirad ist ja sozusagen so ein Nischenthema.
Aber da müsst ihr jetzt durch.
Ich habe es halt einfach trotzdem probiert. Und das fängt halt schon mal damit
an, dass ich eben nicht Autobahn fahren kann.
Obwohl es für mich ja eigentlich das Sinnvollste wäre, die Autobahn zu fahren,
weil da kann ich dann schön mich hinter ein LKW hängen und im Windschatten fahren.
Das hätte mir unheimlich viel gespart.
Also da hätte ich bestimmt eine Reichweite von 150 Kilometer erreicht.
Geht aber nicht, weil in Deutschland gibt es einfach keine AC-Ladepunkte mehr an Autobahnen.
Existiert einfach nicht.
Sie sind sehr selten geworden. Es gibt sie zwar noch, das muss man aber wissen,
wo sie sind. und dann muss man hoffen, dass sie auch frei sind.
Ja, vielleicht irgendwo in Baden-Württemberg oder so, aber zwischen Berlin und
Hamburg gibt es einfach genau keine.
Doch, es gibt so vereinzelte Raststätten, die haben noch so einen ollen Triple Charger.
Nein, keiner. Kein einziger, ich habe ja geguckt.
Ja, dann war es nach Süden. Aber sie sind sehr, sehr, sehr selten geworden.
Genau. Weil, braucht ja keiner.
Das ist natürlich Quatsch, aber naja, ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt nicht,
weil so ein AC-Lader kostet dann irgendwie auch nichts.
Das kann man auch nochmal hinstellen, aber existiert halt nicht.
Naja, wenn man jetzt ehrlich ist, dann ist AC-Ladung halt auch ein anderer Use-Case.
Also zumindest für Autos ist es ein anderer Use-Case. Das ist halt Marke,
ich bin in der Stadt unterwegs oder ich bin Laternenparker oder irgendwas und
dann stelle ich das Auto halt da vier Stunden hin und dann ist es wieder voll. Das ist so.
Ich weiß, oder man hat ein Motorrad.
Oder man hat ein Motorrad.
Genau, so. Aber so können die Motorräder halt dann da auch nicht fahren,
weil es gibt ja keine Ladesäulen.
Weil man die Ladesäulen abgebaut hat, weil man ja nur in Autos denkt.
Also das Ding ist, ich hatte ja vor meinem jetzigen Auto hatte ich ja eine Zoe
und die Zoe hatte tatsächlich auch nur AC-Laden,
was nicht nur fürchterlich langsam war, sondern halt auch genau zu dem Problem
geführt hat und das wurde ja immer schlimmer über die Jahre.
Ich habe das Ding ja sechs Jahre gehabt oder so.
War dann auch der Grund, das Teil dann irgendwann endlich abzustoßen,
weil ich es nicht mehr ertragen habe.
Meine Herangehensweise war immer gucken, wo liegen kleinere Städte auf der Strecke.
Dann fährt man von der Autobahn runter, fährt in irgendeine Kleinstadt,
was weiß ich, Lutherstadt Wittenberg zum Beispiel.
Und da gibt es dann relativ viele städtische AC-Ladestationen,
wo man sich ranklemmen kann und dann in Ruhe Mittag essen oder einen Kaffee
trinken oder irgendwie sowas.
Das geht dann schon, aber das ist halt nicht wirklich Langstrecke fahren,
sondern das ist dann mehr so verlängerte Spritztour, weil es dann auch wirklich
sehr schnell sehr lästig wird.
Genau. Meine Anwendung war, ich wollte nach Hamburg.
Mit einer Reichweite von 100 Kilometern, also effektiven,
also sagen wir mal, ich sage noch von der Temperatur abhängig,
von deinem Fahrstil abhängig, also 100 war so die Zahl, von der ich wusste,
die kriege ich auf jeden Fall hin.
Ich kriege unter Umständen noch 10 oder 20 obendrauf, je nachdem,
wie warm es noch wird, wie sehr ich darauf acht gleichmäßig zu fahren oder ob
nicht doch noch irgendwie ein Lastwagen vor mir fährt.
Also nochmal kurz zur Einordnung, die Distanz von Berlin-Hamburg ist so knapp 300 Kilometer.
Würde man ja sagen, zweimal laden und fertig.
Je nachdem von wo in Berlin nach wo in Hamburg, aber ja, so ungefähr.
Pi mal da um 300 Kilometer, das war so ein bisschen das Ziel.
Ich wollte jetzt mal kurz aufdröseln, was da jetzt noch für Faktoren mit reinkommen,
die sozusagen diesen ganzen Spaß zu einer echt anstrengenden Sache machen,
die dann dazu führt, dass ich den ganzen Tag brauche,
um diese Strecke zurückzulegen, was ein bisschen absurd ist,
aber ich wollte es halt einfach mal ausprobieren.
Das erste ist, dass ich gedrosselt bin natürlich durch meine Reichweite.
Das zweite ist, dass ich dadurch gedrosselt bin, dass ich natürlich am Ende
meiner Reichweite nicht automatisch eine Ladesäule vorfinde.
Sondern naja, wie ist es denn jetzt eigentlich mit dem Abstand und da fangen
dann auch schon diese ganzen Apps an total zu versagen.
Weil wenn ich sage, liebe App, ich möchte jetzt von Berlin nach Hamburg,
ja kein Problem, da fährst du einfach hier lang und da kannst du da laden,
kannst du da laden, kannst du da laden.
Aber sie zeigt mir natürlich nicht an, wo ich vorher vielleicht nochmal laden
könnte oder wo ich danach auch nochmal laden könnte, wenn ich da noch genug Akku habe und so weiter.
Also ich finde strategische und vor allem für eine dynamische Planung in dem
Moment vollkommen ungeeignet. Also musst du selber dir die Karte anschauen und
so habe ich dann ein sehr gutes Verständnis dafür bekommen, wo denn nun wirklich
eigentlich Ladesäulen sind.
Da sind natürlich dann auch noch die Ladesäulen, weil ich hatte jetzt gerade
wieder keine Ladekarte, wo ich mit meiner App laden kann und dann gibt es die
Ladesäulen, wo ich mit meiner App nicht laden kann, sondern wo ich vielleicht
mit irgendeiner anderen dusseligen App arbeiten muss.
Naja gut, ich meine man kann sich ein halbes Dutzend Apps runterladen und dann
ist man eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich habe mir auch eine halbe Dutzend Apps runtergeladen, bloß diese halbe Dutzend
Apps, die sind halt einfach, jede arbeitet komplett anders,
jede hat eine vollständige andere Vorstellung davon, wofür man sich jetzt wieder
registrieren muss, welche Daten man da alles ablegen muss, mit welchem Account.
Ich kenne das Problem, am schlimmsten war, dass sich irgendwie eine Runde Anbieter
eine White-Label-Lösung eingekauft haben,
die alle mit dem gleichen Authentifizierungsmodul gearbeitet haben und irgendwie
hat der Anbieter des Authentifizierungsmoduls das nicht hingekriegt,
die Apps auseinanderzuhalten.
Weswegen du immer das falsche Passwort gespeichert hattest irgendwie.
Und dann musste man sich eigentlich zum Einloggen immer irgendwie ein neues
Passwort schicken lassen per E-Mail und so.
Also das ist, ja, diese Apps, die sind, es gibt einige gute,
aber sehr viele scheiße Apps.
Und das ist aber, was du gesagt hast, das hat mich an Pump eigentlich auch immer am meisten genervt.
weil du sagst ihm ja, ich fahre jetzt los hab jetzt, was weiß ich, 85% State of Charge,
und dann sagt er, ja gut, da fährst du jetzt da und da und da ran dann hast
du noch 10% und dann lädst du da so, jetzt fährst du aber natürlich.
Real Kilometer und hast reale Verbräuche und dann ist es nicht so richtig einfach
zu sagen, okay nimm mal 3% von meinem State of Charge runter Oder jetzt,
weil ich habe mehr verbraucht.
Oder mach mal drei Prozent wieder drauf. Und dass er dann da automatisch neu
rechnet und sagt, okay, ich muss dir eine andere Ladesäule suchen,
fahr mal besser zu der hin.
Ja, oder zeige mir einfach von vornherein noch die anderen Optionen,
die du theoretisch auch noch anfahren kannst.
Weil es gibt ja auch noch andere Faktoren, warum du an einer Ladesäule nicht laden kannst.
Nämlich zum Beispiel, das hatte ich auf dieser Tour alles.
Die Ladesäule ist bei einem Autohändler, aber es war halt Ostermontag und der
hat dann halt zu und dann kannst du da nicht ran.
Ja, mit dem Motorrad vielleicht.
Nein, das Tor war zu und du konntest halt nicht ran.
Mit anderen Worten, ich habe drei, vier Ladesäulen angefahren,
die einfach schlicht nicht zugänglich waren an dem Tag. Sonst vielleicht schon.
Das ist ein guter Punkt. Ladesäulen bei Autohändlern würde ich sowieso inzwischen grundsätzlich meiden.
Ja, aber siehst du ja vorher nicht unbedingt immer.
Na doch, wenn du auf der Karte guckst und da ist auch gleichzeitig dort ein Autohändler.
Ja, das ist aber beileibe nicht unbedingt immer transparent.
Nicht immer, aber wenn es einem auffällt, würde ich die Ladesäule nicht anfahren.
Ja klar, wenn es mir auffällt, dann habe ich das dann auch dann nicht getan.
Aber selbst wenn das so ist, könnten sie ja mal ihre fucking Ladesäule einfach
trotzdem irgendwie zugänglich machen.
Anyway, das war auf jeden Fall ein Faktor. Der andere Faktor ist,
dass ich eben automatisch eine gewisse Sicherheit einbauen muss.
Und das reduziert ja quasi nochmal meine Reichweite nochmal extra,
weil ich quasi von meiner realen Reichweite eigentlich immer nochmal 20 Kilometer abrechnen muss,
die ich an Sicherheit brauche dass wenn die Ladesäule, die ich eigentlich erreichen
wollte, aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht funktioniert, ich da nicht bezahlen kann,
sie irgendwie abgeschlossen ist oder keine Ahnung,
dauerbelegt ist, kurz weil klar, als ich hingefahren bin, war sie frei,
aber dann kommt einer und dann lädt der dann halt eine Stunde und das ist dann
der einzige Port der funktioniert, dann stehst du da halt doof da Also muss
ich quasi nochmal 20 Kilometer in der Sicherheit haben,
weil es natürlich immer noch in Deutschland so ist,
dass du nicht in jedem Kauf eine Ladesäule hast und ehrlich gesagt, dafür habe ich...
bisschen wenig Verständnis, dass wir immer noch an diesem Punkt sind,
wo nicht zumindest mal mindestens so zwei Ports lade sollen.
Ich meine, wir reden hier von einem Drei-Phasen- Strom-Wechsel- Strom-Anschluss.
Ja, das ist jetzt kein, oh, da müssen wir aber noch unsere Infrastruktur verbessern,
weil sowas Merkwürdiges wie Drei-Phasen- Strom, das haben wir ja noch nie gesehen.
Naja, jetzt redest du natürlich wahrscheinlich vor allen Dingen von Brandenburg,
auch ein bisschen von McPom.
Da ist es tatsächlich nicht so verbreitet. Im Süden findest du es öfter,
die viel belächelte Bürgermeister-Ladesäule, die vor dem Rathaus steht,
weil der Bürgermeister muss ja seine eigene Ladesäule haben,
sonst ist er kein richtiger Bürgermeister.
Ja, ich kenne all diese Dinge.
Man gewöhnt sich auch dran anzugucken, dann in der App okay,
dieser Ladepunkt hat vier AC-Anschlüsse.
Das sieht doch gut aus. Da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass einer davon frei
ist oder funktioniert, beziehungsweise beides, relativ hoch.
Und dann siehst du so, nur ein AC-Anschluss, lieber nicht.
Also das ist so, ja, aber ich habe auch schon bei irgendeiner Molkerei geladen,
also das ist irgendwie, ja, die hatten so ein Besucherzentrum und dann hingen da halt zwei so Lade.
So Wallboxen an der Wand vom Parkplatz.
Da konnte man da laden. Also es gibt all diese Dinge, aber es ist die Nerven,
die man dann irgendwann nicht mehr hat, ich kann das total gut nachvollziehen.
Wie gesagt, deswegen habe ich auch die Zoe verkauft, weil ich einfach keinen Bock mehr drauf hatte.
Aber ich habe dann noch, also das waren nicht die einzigen Probleme, die ich hatte.
Das nächste Problem war, dass ich zu einem, das war dann glaube ich sogar meine
erste Ladesäule, die ich anfuhr.
Und da dachte ich so, Das ist ja ein Volltreffer. Ein niegelnagelneuer EDK.
Frisch auf den Acker gesetzt. 50% der Parkplätze sogar mit Solardach.
Also ganz moderne Zeug.
Da wäre ich ja Mist raus.
Zwei dicke, fette Ladesäulen, die also so richtig alles haben. AC und aber auch DC.
Und ich stecke mich da ran und kann bezahlen und funktionieren.
lade, geh zum Edeka, hau mit dem Brötchen rein, die Sonne scheint,
alles gut und dann komm ich so zurück und rück dieses Scheißteil irgendwie mein Kabel nicht mehr raus.
Normalerweise, wenn ich halt
bei mir das irgendwie Laden beende und so weiter, ja, stehst du dann da.
In meiner Verzweiflung hab ich natürlich dann erstmal diese Support-Telefon-Hotline
nicht gefunden, die sie tatsächlich irgendwo auf dieser Säule hatten,
aber in so Dreipunktschrift irgendwo so rechts unten irgendwie noch Mit einer
KI dahinter. Mit einer KI dahinter, genau.
Da habe ich dann irgendwann angerufen und gefragt, was das denn jetzt wieder soll.
Dann muss ich dann die Nummer durchgeben. Ja, ich muss jetzt mal die Ladesäule rebooten.
Ja, das war Handel.
Und wenn das nicht klappt, dann mit dem Kabel, dann fragen sie auch mal bei
Edeka, da sollen sie mal die Sicherung ziehen und wieder irgendwie reinschalten.
Dann müsste es eigentlich freischalten.
Das hatte ich noch nicht.
Hat ein paar Minuten rebooted und hat da noch tatsächlich das Kabel wieder freigegeben.
Aber ich dachte mir so, was ist jetzt, wenn ich an so einer Ladesäule stehe
und da ist dann irgendwie keine Support-Hotline irgendwie, die irgendwie so
an der Bürgermeister-Ladesäule...
Nee, aber du hast bei Ladesäulen eigentlich immer eine Support-Hotline und die
sind eigentlich auch immer in der Lage, die remote zu rebooten,
was sie wahrscheinlich auch relativ oft machen müssen, je nachdem,
was für ein Fabrikat das ist.
Und dieses also das hast du natürlich nur beim AC-Laden, wenn kein Kabel an
der Säule ist, was aber bei AC in der Regel nicht ist, dann hast du halt das
Problem, dass wenn die Säule das Kabel nicht freigibt, hast du halt,
das ist halt doof. Da hast du einen Scheiß.
Dann musst du dein 300 Euro Kabel da spenden, wenn du noch so viel weg bist.
Es gibt Ladesäulen, das sage ich jetzt nur unter vorgehaltener Hand,
die haben auch einen Notausknopf.
Das ist so die poor man's way, eine Ladesäule zu rebooten.
Gegen Treppen?
Ja, da drückst du den Note aus und dann machst du den wieder raus.
Die haken ja meistens ein und dann kann man sie mit Drehen wieder rausziehen.
Ja, und dann rebootet die Ladesäule.
Ja, die sind relativ selten, weil ich glaube, da gibt es zu viele Idioten,
die dann da einfach draufdrücken.
Wissentlich oder unwissentlich oder wie auch immer.
So, jetzt wollte ich noch irgendeinen Aspekt berichten, das hat mir wieder aus dem Tritt gebracht.
Und was sie auch nicht alle können, die Ladesäulen in Deutschland,
ist einmal zu sagen, wie weit die jetzt mit dem Laden sind.
Ich meine, da würde man ja mal erwarten, dass das irgendwie ein gelöstes Problem
ist, dass diese Apps, die in der Lage sind zu sagen, hier ist mein Geld,
bitte mach da Strom rein.
die wird ja über das Netz freigeschaltet.
Meine fucking App. Und dann ist diese Ladesäule nicht in der Lage zu sagen,
ich lade jetzt auch, so und so viel ist jetzt schon geladen oder ich bin mit dem Laden fertig.
Vollkommen unmöglich. Bei keiner einzigen Ladesäule gab es irgendein Signal,
dass irgendwas fertig ist.
Das konnte man nur ahnen, weil es in manchen Fällen, in manchen,
nicht in allen, In manchen Fällen, sie haben zumindest gesagt,
wie viel bisher geladen wurde, also wie viele Kilowattstunden reingeladen wurden.
Und wenn ich dann mir das sozusagen angeschaut habe und dieser Wert änderte
sich dann irgendwann nicht mehr so richtig, dann war es wahrscheinlich fertig.
Also das ist was, was Schnellladesäulen in der Regel besser machen,
weil die Kommunikation mit dem Auto ist so gut, dass das Auto sagen kann,
wie viel Prozent sind jetzt im Akku.
Das heißt, die Ladesäule selber kann auch anzeigen, wie viel Prozent Akku hast du jetzt.
Das funktioniert bei AC aber nicht, weil scheinbar ist das nicht Teil des Protokolls
oder so, das weiß ich nicht genau.
Aber ich wiederhole meine Frage von eben, das muss doch dir dein Motorrad sagen können, oder?
Das ist ja das andere Problem, da habe ich ja schon drüber geratet,
dass BMW irgendwie keine ordentliche Connectivity hinbekommt und das Motorrad
selber hat kein Internet.
Also du kannst das Motorrad nicht remote befragen, aber wenn du davor stehen
würdest, würde es auf dem Display stehen.
Ja klar, dann drücke ich auf den Knopf und dann sehe ich das ja,
aber der Witz ist ja, man will ja nicht immer zu der Ladesäule hinrennen,
man will halt vielleicht drei Straßen weiter sich irgendwo ins Restaurant setzen
und gucken, wie weit ist es denn noch und dann zack, jetzt bezahle ich mal und fahre weiter.
Also meine Herangehensweise an das Problem, das war auch eher so ein bisschen
workaroundig, ist, dass man hat es ja irgendwann im Gefühl, wie lange lädt denn
das Teil, wenn es wie leer ist.
und dann ist so üblicherweise alles länger als, also bei der Zoe war das so,
länger als eine Stunde laden bringt nichts.
Da ist sie zwar noch nicht voll, weil das letzten 10% nochmal eine Stunde brauchen,
aber man kann weiterfahren, weil man dann über 80 ist.
Ja, Rodi, aber ich brauche keine Strategien, wie ich damit kopen kann.
Ich möchte einfach nicht kopen. Ich möchte einfach, dass das funktioniert.
Ist denn das so viel?
Ja, da bist du hier falsch. Weil Deutschland ist hier einfach falsch.
Wie soll denn das was werden?
Vor allem, ich finde diese Missachtung von AC-Ladepunkten einfach eine Katastrophe.
All diese ganzen Verbesserungen, die jetzt kommen.
Du musst mit der Kreditkarte bezahlen können, da muss ein Kabel dran sein,
bla bla bla, alles muss irgendwie sein.
Es ist alles nur für Autos. Es ist alles nur für große Karren.
Und was könnte man für geile Fahrzeuge bauen für die Leute, wenn man halt einfach
dieses Casual-Laden mit AC einfach auch mal genauso convenient machen würde.
Allein zu sagen, in einer Stadt eine AC-Ladesäule.
Also erstens, jede Gemeinde muss eine haben.
Die müssen auch Laternen haben. Die müssen alles mögliche haben.
Die haben eine Feuerwehr, die haben ein Abflusssystem, keine Ahnung.
Die haben alles mögliche müssen die haben.
Sie müssen auch AC-Ladesäulen haben. Und diese AC-Ladesäule muss ein Kabel haben.
Das verstehe ich halt auch nicht. Wieso?
Bist du schon mal an eine Tankstelle gefahren?
Und hast einen eigenen Schlauch mitgebracht?
Hast du noch nie gemacht, oder?
Ja, aber Tankstelle ist auch Schnellladen. Wenn du jetzt zum Krauter mit dem
Container gehst, dann brauchst du auch deinen eigenen Schlauch.
Was? Zum Krauter?
Zum Krauter und einen Reservekanister kaufst.
Achso, ja gut, aber darüber reden wir ja nicht.
Naja, du hast natürlich recht.
Ja, aber dann würdest du sozusagen sofort eine neue Generation von Fahrzeugen enablen, die einfach,
kein Kabel mehr mitführen musst, weil diese Kabel sind teuer.
Also so ein Typ-2-Ladekabel, da legst du dreistellig hin. Und zwar ganz easy peasy.
200, 300 musst du mindestens investieren.
Genau. Und die sind auch schwer und groß und die musst du irgendwo verstauen.
Und damit fällt sozusagen eine komplette Kategorie von leichten Mopeds einfach weg.
Weil du eben dieses Kabel nicht
mitführen kannst, beziehungsweise das Mitführen so eine Pine ist. Na?
Ich habe jetzt zumindest, weil ich mache mir gerade darüber Gedanken,
also der Trend geht ja ganz stark zum Zweitelektromotorrad.
Das ist ja euch sicherlich auch schon aufgefallen.
Und ich weiß noch nicht so richtig, ob ich bei diesem Trend schon bald mitziehe
oder nicht, aber ich brauche einfach mehr Reichweite.
Das ist einfach erforderlich. Das Fahrzeug, was ich jetzt habe,
ist für die Stadt ganz wunderbar.
Sozusagen Spaß über Land haben will, brauchst du einfach mehr.
Du wirst mit 100 Kilometern nicht so richtig glücklich.
Nee, das muss man schon so eher in den 250 Kilometer Bereich einsteigen.
Sowas ist auch möglich, aber...
Gepäck ist natürlich gerade, wenn du mit dem Motorrad verreist, so ein kritisches Gut.
Und wenn du dann erstmal so ein riesiges, dickes, fettes Ladekabel immer noch
mitführen musst, um überhaupt laden zu können, das ist schon mal,
finde ich, sehr unangenehm.
und man hätte das problemlos, ich meine, du bräuchst genau ein Ladekabel pro
Säule und das wär's dann.
Stattdessen haben wir jetzt ein Ladekabel pro Fahrzeug.
Jeder hätte seinen eigenen Schlauch dabei, um an jeder Tankstelle auch wirklich
Sprittank zu bringen. Das ist ja sozusagen die Denke.
Und dann hab ich noch das spezielle Elend, ich muss mich ja natürlich absichern,
wegen all dieser ganzen eben aufgeführten Probleme, dass, wenn ich jetzt partout
keine Ladesäule finde, wo kriege ich deinen Strom her?
Aus der Steckdose.
Aus der Steckdose, genau.
Also hast du auch noch den Ladeziegel mit?
Ja, Ziegel, beziehungsweise da gibt es auch schon relativ elegante Kabel,
wo das sozusagen in diesem Typ 2 Stecker der Ziegel mit drin ist.
Sowas habe ich auch jetzt schon.
Also da gibt es schon relativ elegante Lösungen. Ich habe sogar noch eine elegantere Lösung gefunden.
Und zwar von der hervorragenden Ladekabelfirma Metron.
Metron?
Metron baut die geilen Ladekabel. Und Metron baut nicht nur die geilen Ladekabel,
sondern Metron baut auch mobile Wallboxen.
Und das ist wirklich cool.
Von welchem Produkt redest du denn?
Ich rede von einem kompakten, mobilen Ladeadapter, der sozusagen die Konversion
macht von Schuko auf Typ 2,
Buchse. Das heißt, ich habe ein Typ 2 Kabel, was ich für die normale Ladesäule
brauche, will aber nicht nochmal so ein 3 Meter Monster mitnehmen mit irgendwie dicken Stecker.
Stattdessen könnte man halt diesen mobilen Ladeadapter nehmen,
den steckt man dann an Schuko ran und dann kann ich das normale Kabel,
was ich ohnehin schon dabei habe, nehmen und habe dann dieses Problem auch noch...
Ja, solche Lösungen gibt es schon länger. Ich komme jetzt nicht auf den Namen,
da gab es mal eine deutsche Firma, die hat sowas sehr robust und in so eine
Metallzylinder verbaut.
Also ich kann über Metron nur das Beste berichten, das ist wirklich hervorragend verarbeitet.
Vor allem dieses System kann halt auch an einer CEE 16 Dose angeschlossen werden.
Die blaue Campingdose?
Nee, das ist die CEE 1, die eine Phase hat. Du kannst, wenn du einen dreiphasigen Anschluss hast,
wenn du irgendwo Drei-Phasen-Strom hast,
dann kannst du den da ran machen und machst sozusagen aus der Drei-Phasen-Steckdose
eine Ladesäule, wo du dann eben mit deinem Typ-2-Kabel rangehen kannst.
Das mal so als Lifehack. Interessiert jetzt wahrscheinlich keinen,
weil keiner Elektromotorrad fährt, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich kann euch nur sagen,
ihr verpasst was. Es ist so geil.
Motorräder habe ich ja nie verstanden. Ich wusste mal nicht,
was die Leute daran so finden, weil es so viele Dinge hat, die ich hasse, wie die Pest.
Lärm, Stink, schüttelt einen durch, schmierig, scheiße heiß,
Genau, schmierig, Öl, irgendwie Abgase, all dieser ganze Kack.
Und ich weiß ja, ich weiß, was Motorradfahrer dann immer sagen,
aber ich halte es halt alles für Unsinn.
Und ich finde halt, durch Elektroantrieb wird dieses Zweirad-Erlebnis überhaupt erst real.
Da muss man auch nicht schalten, zum Beispiel.
Mich musst du von Elektroantrieb nicht überzeugen.
Wie lange hast du jetzt gebraucht de facto bis Hamburg? Und warst du auf der
Rückfahrt schneller, weil du noch eine bessere Strategie hattest?
Also bei der Hinfahrt hatte ich, sagen wir mal, ohnehin einen geplanten Übernachtungshalt.
Von daher zählt das nicht so richtig.
Aber ich habe, glaube ich, die Rückfahrt sieben oder acht Stunden gebraucht
insgesamt, weil ich halt drei Ladestops hatte.
Ah, wie lange?
Stunde? Ja, so Stunde ungefähr, ja.
Also ich musste so drei Stunden reines Laden plus diese ganze Umschiffung der sonstigen Probleme,
bis das dann mal wirklich alles auch funktioniert und startet und so weiter finden.
Musste diese Ladeorte ja auch noch, teilweise musste ich halt irgendwie noch
die zweiten und dritten aufsuchen, also es gab so diverse Verzögerungen und
das Schlimmste war, bei der einen Ladesäule habe ich mich dann halt dran gesteckt,
bin dann essen gegangen.
Und dann hat die aber abgebrochen.
Und mir natürlich das nicht gesagt. Und ja, dann durfte ich nochmal woanders,
musste ich dann erstmal gucken, ob woanders eine funktioniert,
so wie man dann da bezahlt, weil die dann wieder mit der App nicht gingen und so weiter.
Also dann hat mich das sozusagen gleich nochmal so zwei, drei Stunden gekostet,
nur um irgendwie nochmal 100 Kilometer weiterzufahren.
Alles schon erlebt. Aber ein Teil des Problems ist schon auch dieses BMW-Motorrad.
Ein Teil des Problems ist, das Motorrad hat sich gegen gar nichts gewehrt.
Ja, na gut, aber ich meine, du willst natürlich schon eine App haben,
die dir anzeigt, wie viel Ladung du jetzt drin hast und die dir auch eine Push-Notification
schickt, wenn die Ladung abbricht aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Ja gut, aber das könnten die Ladesäulen halt selbst eigentlich viel besser machen.
Ja, aber dann hast du wieder das Problem mit,
App deines Zahlungsdienstleisters muss mit dem System des Ladesäulenbetreibers
richtig kommunizieren,
damit diese Daten auch in der App von dem Zahlungsdienstleister korrekt ankommen.
Ich habe das Problem, die haben das Problem, das müssen die natürlich lösen,
ich meine die wollen ja auch an mir verdienen.
Du hast das Problem, dass die das Problem nicht lösen.
Das ist überhaupt mein Problem, dass die anderen Leute nicht meine Probleme lösen.
Ja, süß du mal.
Ich prangere das an.
Hören wir mal zu den Fortschritten auf der Welt. Habt ihr mitbekommen,
was die Chinesen alles so angekündigt haben an Batteriewahnsinn?
PYD?
Mit den Ankündigungen ist das ja immer so eine Sache. Die müssen ja auch liefern,
aber sie reden ja schon von Massenproduktion.
Aber es ist wirklich, wirklich interessant, was in diesem Bereich gerade passiert.
Abgesehen davon, dass sie halt ihre LFP-Batterien permanent verbessern und verdichten
und irgendwie noch mehr Energie auf den gleichen Raum bekommen.
PYD hatte so eine komische hybride Batterie angekündigt,
wo sie die Batterie quasi Hälfte, Hälfte oder ein Drittel, zwei Drittel klassische
Technologie und irgendeine neue Technologie, die langsam lädt.
Nee, nicht Natrium, das war auch Lifepo, die langsamer lädt und dann kann man
angeblich 1500 Kilometer fahren.
Naja, aber ja, Natrium ist ja schon länger im Gespräch.
Keine Ahnung, kann man das jetzt kaufen oder kann man es nicht kaufen?
Ich glaube Natrium konnte man in kleinen Stückzahlen schon länger kaufen.
In China schon. In China gibt es sogar Autos, die da mit rumfahren.
Kleine Autos und so weiter, aber das ist generell, ich meine,
das wäre jetzt mal eine Chance noch gewesen für Europa und für Deutschland,
hier, nachdem man den Lithiumzug eigentlich weitgehend verpasst hat,
zumindest auf den Natrium-Train mal aufzuspringen.
Nein, also eigentlich sind die europäischen Kompanies in Nickel-Mangan-Technologie
relativ weit und holen da immer noch viel raus.
Das ist kostentechnisch glaube ich nicht ganz so. So Natrium-Batterie kostet
ja nicht viel, ist aber von der Energiedichte auch nicht besonders doll.
Also eine Natrium-Batterie würde ich mir in den Keller stellen,
aber nicht ins Auto schrauben.
Doch, die würdest du ins Auto schrauben, weil das ist nämlich jetzt genau das,
was sie auch noch mitbringen.
Also man darf jetzt zwei Sachen nicht verwechseln. Das eine ist,
wie verhält sie die Natrium-Ionen-Batterie im Vergleich zur Lithium-Ionen-Batterie?
Und das ist klar, sie ist schwerer, weil sie mehr Raum braucht,
weil mehr Atome und so weiter. Niedrigere Energiedichte.
Genau, hat aber dafür andere Vorteile, die halt die Lithium-Batterien so nicht
haben, wie zum Beispiel lädt auch
noch bei minus 20 Grad, was halt so eine Lithium-Batterie halt nicht tut.
Da musst du dann irgendwie eine Heizung einschalten, sonst kriegst du da keinen Strom rein.
Beziehungsweise du solltest da auch keinen Strom reinpressen bei den Temperaturen,
weil du dann die Batterie kaputt machst.
Genau und deswegen verhindert das, also die verhindert dann,
dass sie geladen wird und schaltet sich halt ab und wenn sie halt warm ist,
dann kannst du sie auch wieder laden.
Natrium-Ionen-Batterien kannst du halt auch noch laden bei Minustemperaturen
und vor allem kannst du sie auch betreiben bei Minustemperaturen und was CATL angekündigt hat,
ist, dass sie halt auch noch in diesen Batterien auch noch bei einem sehr niedrigen
Ladezustand noch sehr hohe Spannungen liefern können.
Also während die Lithium-Batterien halt dann auch immer schwächer werden gegen
Ende und dann so auslaufen und dann aus dem letzten Loch pfeifen,
hast du also hier noch eine sehr viel bessere Versorgungskurve,
bis das Ding dann halt auch wirklich mal leer ist.
Gut, tief entladen will keine Batterie werden, aber das nur am Rande.
Wir kommen gleich noch dazu.
Und die Besonderheit, die jetzt bei dieser letzten Ankündigung von CATL noch
mit dabei war, ist, dass sie jetzt vor allem die Natrium-Ionen-Batterie in einer
speziellen Variante als Ersatz für die immer noch sehr verbreiteten 12 Volt bzw.
24 Volt Bleibatterien pushen werden, weil sie da alle Features sozusagen haben,
die man eben auch braucht für eine Starterbatterie.
Also funktioniert auch noch, wenn es kalt ist, die sich aber eben fast nicht
entladen und die auch nicht kaputt gehen, wenn sie mal zu 50 Prozent leer sind,
auch nicht, wenn sie zu 10 Prozent leer sind.
Das heißt, es kann jetzt durchaus sein, dass die nächste Batterierevolution
aus China bedeutet, dass alle Bleibatterien durch Natrium-Ionen-Batterien ersetzt
werden. in den Starterbatterien, die ja auch in allen Lithium-Ionen,
Autos noch mit drin ist. Also auch ein Tesla fährt noch mit so einer Bleisäurebatterie
durch die Gegend. Absurderweise.
Fährt nicht damit, aber ja.
Ja doch, der fährt die die ganze Zeit rum. Die ist da drin. Er fährt nicht aus
dieser Batterie, aber startet, also die Grundversorgung sozusagen.
Die Bordelektronik wird davon Der Strom.
Den du brauchst, um deine eigentliche Batterie überhaupt erstmal anzusprechen
und die ganzen Scheiß zum Laufen zu bringen.
Die Relais freizuschalten.
Bleisäure, genau. Und das kann also sehr gut sein, dass das demnächst durch diese Natrium,
ich bin jetzt ein bisschen optimistisch auf Basis ihrer Ankündigung,
aber so liest sich das und es macht ja auch total Sinn, weil diese Technik eben
dafür ist und wenn die Preise halt dann auch so sind, dass sie mit den,
Bleisäure-Akkus mithalten können, wonach es aussieht, dann hast du zumindest
in LKWs demnächst diese Batterien.
Ich habe jetzt nur von vier 24 Volt oder 25, 6 Volt Batterien gelesen.
Kann aber auch sehr gut sein, dass sie das auch noch für die 12 Volt Variante auch noch mitbekommen.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Riesenmarkt, weil du quasi alle Autos auf der Welt
mal eben mit einer anderen Batterie ausstattest. Und zwar auch die Verbrenner.
Ja, finde ich bemerkenswert.
Ja,
gut.
So Ralf, du hast aber auch noch ein Autoproblem.
Ich habe auch noch ein gelöstes Problem.
Ein gelöstes Autoproblem.
Genau, wenn Wir wenden uns ab von diesem ganzen neumodischen Batterie-Elektro-Kram
und kommen wieder zu den alten Benzin-Verbrennern.
Die Älteren unter uns werden sich erinnern, vor einem Jahr ungefähr habe ich
hier in der Sendung mal rumgefragt, ob es da draußen eigentlich Spezialexperten
gibt für Autoschlüssel.
Die ihre Programmierung verloren haben und was man da eventuell irgendwie drauf
rumlöten, wie auch immer muss, um die wieder zu reaktivieren.
Und da gab es nicht so wirklich irgendwie eine Rückmeldung. Und der Hintergrund
war halt, wir hatten jetzt viel BMW gehört. Ich fahre aus Gründen eine alte
Mercedes B-Klasse von meinem Vater geerbt.
Ansonsten hätte ich mir niemals so ein Auto gekauft, aber jetzt habe ich es halt.
Und wir hatten zwei Schlüssel. Den einen Schlüssel, der funktionierte ganz normal
und den anderen Schlüssel hatte meine Frau. Und die fährt nur ganz, ganz selten ein Auto.
Und dort war also dann die Batterietiefen entladen.
Das, was wir gerade eben schon gehört haben, was man ja nicht möchte.
So, und was ich natürlich dann schon gemacht habe, ist Batterie halt irgendwie
austauschen. Und der Schlüssel funktionierte aber trotzdem nicht.
So, und dann bin ich damit dann zur Mercedes-Werkstatt meines Vertrauens gefahren.
die ansonsten eigentlich immer einen guten Job machen, nicht Mercedes selbst,
sondern halt so ein Budi, ihr kennt das und habt denen das Problem geschildert
und als erstes, haben sie denn schon mal die Batterie? Ja, ich habe die Batterie schon.
Ja, lassen sie mich mal machen.
So, die traut mir also nicht zu, dass ich es schaffe jetzt, also diese Batterie selber auszutauschen.
Du, wenn ich Mercedes-Händler wäre.
Würdest du das auch probieren. So gut, die also nochmal die Batterie ausgetauscht,
funktioniert ja trotzdem nicht.
Tja, dann guckte er mich schon ganz traurig an und meinte, naja,
das sei jetzt schon ein Problem.
Weil das dürften sie als Werkstatt gar nicht machen. Da jetzt also irgendwie
was mit dem Schlüssel programmieren und dort irgendwie müsste man einen Code
anfordern und alles ganz, ganz schwierig.
Da müsste ich schon jetzt in den Flagship-Store von Mercedes fahren.
Das ist so das Iq-Alenso-Tan-App von der Sparkasse freischalten.
Gut, dachte ich mir, gut, muss da halt irgendwie jetzt einplanen,
dass da halt irgendwie dann mal einen Tag irgendwo zu Mercedes fährst.
Achso, da habe ich erstmal verschiedene Mercedes-Läden durch Telefonieren.
Ich meine Berlin, da gibt es halt ein paar.
Oh, nee, das machen wir nicht. Da müssen sie wirklich in den Flagship-Store.
Wo ist denn der Flagship-Store?
Der Mercedes-Flagship-Store. Ich glaube, der heißt nicht so.
Das habe ich jetzt gerade erfunden. Aber er ist es de facto.
Den muss man wahrscheinlich mal gesehen haben.
Salzufer in Berlin, oder nicht?
Das ist ein Riesenkomplex. Genau, welches Ufer hast du gerade gesagt?
Salzufer.
Genau, also an der Spree ist das.
Da habe ich studiert in der Ecke.
Ja, es ist ein riesiger Glaspalast, wo ganz viele Leute rumlaufen,
die einem nichts über Elektroautos erzählen können. Das habe ich auch schon mal ausprobiert.
Flachschiff-Store hier.
Die können einem, wie sich gleich zeigen wird, auch zu anderen Dingen nicht viel sagen.
Das gibt kein Zweifel.
Also dieser Riesenkomplex, wenn man da reinfährt, das ist schon alles recht
eindrucksvoll, muss man sagen.
Vorne ist dann also so ein riesen Verkaufstower und Verwaltung ist da auch drin
und woran ich aber natürlich nur Interesse hatte, war dann der eigentliche Werkstattbereich.
So und auch dieser Werkstattbereich ist ein Riesengebäude und von außen ist
das Ganze schon verwirrend,
weil man fährt eben nicht in irgendeine Garage rein, sondern du fährst in gefühlt
halt ein Verwaltungsgebäude rein mit deinem Auto.
Da fährst du rein?
Da fährst du rein, genau. Ich habe jetzt gerade ein Bild im Chat gepostet.
Das sieht eher aus wie ein normaler Personeneingang.
Genau, es ist auch gar nicht so riesig groß, wahrscheinlich kommt man mit einem
SUV da schon noch auch so rein, aber es ist schon jetzt nicht ein riesiges Garagentor,
durch das man da fährt und du fährst dann halt in ein Glaspalast rein und dann,
vielleicht seid ihr da irgendwie weniger empfindlich, aber ich habe sofort Störgefühle,
wenn ich im Inneren von einem Gebäude mit dem Auto fahre, sowas macht man normalerweise nicht.
Und es sieht eben nicht aus, wie ich tucker jetzt mal zwei Meter in der Garage rein.
Also mit einem Verbrenner ist das komisch.
Mit einem Elektroauto hätte ich da keine Probleme mit.
Ich auch nicht.
So, jetzt kommt also quasi die nächste Phase. Ähm,
Jetzt könnte man sehen, ein Bild, wenn es hochgeladen ist, wo man dann also
an seine Service-Säule fährt mit dem Auto, die parken alle nebeneinander.
Oben drüber sind schöne Displays, wo die einzelnen Service-Stationen durchnummeriert
sind, von irgendwie 1 bis 10 haben die da und wo du dann eine Farbkodierung
hast, welche frei sind und welche nicht, weil das sieht man ja auch nicht mit bloßem Auge.
Dass dein Auto steht.
Dass dein Auto steht. Und dann,
ist es ja auch alles dann schon auch digital, das heißt also du gehst dann an so eine,
Digitalsäule, wo die dann also auch gleich irgendwie dein Auto auf Herz und
Nieren durchtesten können und dann gehst du rein in den eigentlichen Servicebereich,
was halt auch eher so aussieht wie eine Hotellobby.
Wartest dann da auch nicht lange, sondern wenn du dann da deinen Platz hast,
dann hast du also quasi auch garantiert, dass du sofort dann da deine Service-Person
hast und stehst dann also quasi dann da im Hotel mit deinem Auto, so vom Feeling her.
Also in Bezug darauf so Überwältigungsästhetik und irgendwie Eindrucksschinden,
das haben die da schon ganz gut drauf.
Also man hat ja schon einen sehr erhabenen Moment mit seinem Auto.
Das ist sehr anders als das, was man so in der Werkstatt kennt.
Und so der Preiszähler im Hinterkopf zählt auch schön hoch, oder?
Ja, passt auf.
Auch sehr erhaben. Sehr erhabener Preis.
So, ich den...
Dann dort also einem jungen, sehr motivierten, ich würde sagen so Mitte 20 war
der Service-Menschen, ich glaube der hatte auch einen Anzug an,
dann also mal ein Problem geschildert und er natürlich dann als erstes,
hier haben sie denn auch schon ein Problem?
Ja, wir haben schon zwei, dreimal die Batterie ausgetauscht,
das ist es wirklich nicht.
Oh, ja dann wird es schwierig, meinte er dann.
Ja, aber alle schicken mich hier zu Ihnen. Wenn jetzt jemand dieses Problem
lösen kann, dass dieser Schlüssel nicht funktioniert und ich brauche einen neuen
Schlüssel, dann sind Sie das doch jetzt, der dieses Problem lösen kann.
Ja, da müsste er jetzt erstmal schauen. Dann hat er halt erstmal irgendwie Daten
aus meinem Auto rausgelesen.
Die haben ihn aber nicht schlauer gemacht, weil da natürlich nur die Informationen
über irgendeinen Schlüssel drin zu finden waren.
und dann fing er an in seiner Support-Datenbank zu recherchieren und sein Gesicht
trübte sich immer stärker ein,
und dann meinte er, okay also ich weiß jetzt, was wir hier tun können und ich
habe eine schlechte Nachricht und eine sehr schlechte Nachricht für Sie.
Das fand ich schon mal eine interessante Kommunikationsstrategie.
Ich so, ja, sagen Sie mir zuerst die schlechte Nachricht. Das wird richtig,
richtig teuer. Es kostet 600 Euro.
Das war die schlechte Nachricht. Das ist die sehr schlechte.
600 Euro für einen neuen Schlüssel für mein Auto.
Ein Schlüssel?
Ein Schlüssel.
Also so ein Fernbedienungsschlüssel.
Genau, der hat eine Fernbedienung.
600 Euro. Und das ist was nicht schlecht.
Was ist, was um Himmels Willen ist jetzt die sehr schlechte Nachricht.
Es dauert leider vier Monate.
Oh, mein Gott.
Ich habe ein bisschen Mercedes.
Oh Gott, was ist denn alles? Ist der kaputt?
Ich wollte, ihr ahnt es, ich wollte es nicht glauben.
Da meinte er, die seien halt mit ihrem Service so voll gebucht und es ging jetzt
aber auch wirklich nur über die, aber wir könnten gerne diesen Bestellvorgang
jetzt machen und vielleicht wird es auch nur drei Monate dauern.
Warum, hat er das erklärt, was 600 Euro kostet an diesem Vorgang?
Das sei das, was das System ihm als Kosten für einen neuen Schlüssel,
der dann funktioniert, für mein altes Auto kosten würde.
Das ist so kriminell.
Da geht man doch gleich zur Polizei irgendwie mit dieser Information.
Bauen die da die halbe Elektronik aus?
Passt auf, es wird jetzt wirklich nicht besser.
Ich habe diese Geschichte lange vorbereitet, lange liegen lassen für diesen heutigen Anlass.
Für diesen Moment.
Für diesen Moment. Gut, also ich bin dann abgezogen und habe gesagt,
nein, mit 600 Euro und drei Monaten wären wir jetzt nicht handelsseilig.
Vier Monate.
Vier Monaten, ich wollte eigentlich nächste Woche in den Urlaub fahren und einen
Sicherheitsschlüssel haben.
Das löst jetzt hier mein Problem nicht. Wir brechen das hier mal ab.
Da hatte er dann auch großes Verständnis dafür. Also das war ein ganz netter
Kerl. Also an ihm hat es vielleicht gar nicht mal unbedingt gelegen.
Gut, ich dann also in den Urlaub gefahren, zu meinen Schwiegereltern,
habe meiner Schwiegermutter, wie ich das so mache, dann mein Leid geklagt.
Und die meinte dann hemmsärmelig, wie sie ist. Sie fragt einfach mal bei sich
in der Werkstatt, was sie dazu sagt.
Ich so, ja, die werden dir sagen, ja, haben sie denn schon die Batterie gewechselt?
Nein, bitte sag gleich, ja, die Batterie habe ich schon gewechselt.
So, sie dann trotzdem ihre Werkstatt kontaktiert und die Rückmeldung war dann
doch etwas diffus, die meinten, wieso, neuer Schlüssel, das sei schon klar,
der sei Tiefenentladung,
der sei nicht mehr programmiert auf das Auto, aber den könnte man doch wieder anlernen.
Okay, anlernen, ja, gut, bitte mehr Details.
So, gab es ja nicht, aber dann guckt man halt im Internet nach und dann findet
man in der Tat Seiten, natürlich nicht von Mercedes,
was man denn eigentlich tun muss, um einen Mercedes-Schlüssel selber wieder anzulernen.
Und das ist eine wirklich schöne Seite, die ich jetzt hier verlinke.
Oh, Motor Talk.
Ja, Vorsicht, komische Werbung und sowas alles. Also im Jahr 2021 hat er also
ein Dössaisos geschrieben,
dass er also das ganz exakte selbe Problem hat und stundenlang recherchiert
hat und er sei zu mehreren Lösungsvarianten gekommen, die angeblich funktionieren
würden und er hätte die mal durchprobiert.
Diese Varianten sind wirklich schön. Ich lese das jetzt mal vor.
Variante 1. Tür mit Zweitschlüssel öffnen. Hatte ich ja.
Anzulernen den Schlüssel 1 in das Zündschloss stecken und dort für eine Stunde belassen.
Nach einer Stunde auf dem Schlüssel 1 die Öffnen-Taste zweimal betätigen.
Das wäre also Variante 1 gewesen. Variante 2, gleiches wie Variante 1,
nur mit einmal 2 Stunden und einmal 8 Stunden.
Variante 3, Fahrzeug öffnen mit Zweitschlüssel, Schlüssel 1 auf den Rückspiegel,
Kamera richten und dreimal die Öffnen-Taste drücken, Schlüssel 1 in Zündschloss
stecken und auf Stufe 2 stellen.
Variante 4, Schlüssel 1 mehrfach ins Zündschloss bis zu 10 Mal stecken und abziehen.
Leider blieben alle diese Varianten erfolglos und so weiter und so fort.
Aber ich dachte mir, ja nun Gott, der hat das schon mal irgendwie herrecherchiert,
probier es da einfach mal aus.
Das bezieht sich jetzt konkret auf B-Klasse. Okay.
Genau.
Also genau dein Modell.
B-245, exakt mein Modell ist das. Irgendwie 14 Jahre alt oder sowas ist der jetzt.
So und habe ich mir diese Varianten halt angeguckt und habe versucht jetzt irgendwie
rauszukriegen, okay, acht Stunden warten jetzt, ob es klappt oder nicht,
finde ich jetzt ein bisschen doof.
Habe also die Mitte erst Variante 1 ausprobiert.
Halt, bevor du fortfährst, würde ich gerne kurz nochmal eine,
Wahrscheinlichkeitseinschätzung abgeben, was ich jetzt denke,
welche dieser Varianten plausibel klingen.
Ja, nur du.
Also Variante 1, also den Schlüssel ins Zündschloss stecken und eine Stunde
belassen und dann die Taste auf dem Schlüssel drücken. Würde ja bedeuten...
Wobei nicht klar ist, ob man ihn drinstecken lässt oder abzieht.
Möchte ich noch hinzu. Also da ist auch diese Anleitung hier etwas unpräzise.
Wenn, dann würde ich den Schlüssel da drin belassen.
Ja gut, aber die eigentliche Frage ist, ist das Auto in der Lage,
mit einem eingesteckten Schlüssel direkt zu kommunizieren?
Das ist ja sozusagen das, was das hier impliziert.
Und was tut das nach einer Stunde, was es nicht nach zehn Sekunden könnte?
Ich würde sagen, nein.
Nach einer Stunde ist es einfach, das ist einfach die Zeit,
die dann, wenn der eine Stunde lang hier drin ist, dann ist es auch deiner und
dann darf der das auch irgendwie so, würde ich das mal deuten.
Und das mit einmal zwei Stunden, einmal acht Stunden, diese Variante zwei,
da würde ich sagen, also wenn das erste wahrscheinlich ist, warum es dann so
kompliziert und so lang machen, weil wenn es wirklich ein Service-Ding ist,
dann ist es ja viel zu lange.
Also ich sage Variante 2 eher unwahrscheinlich.
Variante 3, Roddy, halte mal die Pferde kurz.
Schlüssel auf den Rückspiegel, Kamera richten und dreimal, ist denn da ein Infrarotsender
dran an diesem Schlüssel?
Ja.
Ein Infrarotsender? Ja. Hast du das mal mit einer Kamera gefilmt?
Nee. Also ein Empfänger ist da dran.
Im Schlüssel?
Der Schlüssel selber sendet Infrarot, ja.
Also was jetzt, empfängt oder sendet? Infrarot. Du musst den optisch,
der hat doch kein Infrarot.
Nee Gott, jetzt muss ich eben gucken.
Das ist doch ein Funkschlüssel.
Ja, richtig. Ich behaupte das Gegenteil.
Aber hier auf eine Kamera richten, kann ja nur Infrarot sein.
Ja, das ist Humbug auf jeden Fall.
Also entweder ist es Humbug oder Quatsch.
Ach so.
Was haben wir noch? Variante 4 zehnmal reinstecken und abziehen.
Also ich würde sagen, Variante 4 und Variante 1 sind so meine Kandidaten für,
wenn eine davon funktioniert, dann ist es eine von den beiden.
Das wäre jetzt mal so, also wenn. Es kann aber auch sehr gut sein,
dass keine davon funktioniert, weil offensichtlich hat ja der Forum-Schreiber
gar keinen Erfolg gehabt mit diesen Methoden.
So, ich hatte Erfolg, es hat funktioniert mit Variante 3.
Wirklich?
Der Rückspiegel.
Also er hat ja doch einen Infrarotsender.
Ja.
Hat er?
Hat er.
Hast du ausprobiert?
Ja. Das sieht man in der Kamera.
Jaja, der sendet also die ID quasi. Ja, der bringt das Brot.
Ja.
Okay.
Also was ich mir noch vorstellen kann.
Warte mal, warte mal, halt.
Das hat gereicht und Mercedes wollte dir 600 Euro für diesen Vorgang, den sie bestellen?
Ich meine, haben die eigentlich Kontakt zu ihrem Unternehmen?
Das steht doch in den technischen Unterlagen.
Tja, scheinbar eben nicht.
Oh Gott, oh Gott.
So und das Mercedes, das irgendwie...
Bist du da hingefahren? Ich würde da hinfahren und den einfach auf den Tisch pinkeln.
Ja, ich meine, das ist doch eine Frechheit.
Ja, natürlich.
Ohne Ende. Also entweder ist es eine Frechheit oder ist es ein Dokument ihrer Dummheit.
Die können dann aussuchen, ob du sie anpickelst oder auslachst.
Also, vielleicht bin ich da jetzt ein bisschen schräg gewickelt,
aber ich bin eigentlich saurer auf meine eigene Werkstatt.
Weil die müssten sowas wissen. Das sind die, die Alltagsprobleme irgendwie auf dem Tisch haben.
Ja, aber ist das eine Mercedes-Spezial-Werkstatt?
Die heißen sogar Sternwarte.
Ah, okay. Da kannst du auch hinpinkeln.
Denen habe ich eine Mail geschrieben in der Tat.
Tatsächlich ist da vorne ein Infrarotsender eingebaut.
Es ist interessant. Ich frage mich,
ob das Ding noch irgendwelche Wireless Charging Coils oder so drin hat.
Sprich, wenn du den Schlüssel einsteckst, ob er dann vom Auto Strom bekommt.
Das könnte nämlich diese für Stunde bla und so weiter drin lassen,
erklären, weil dann vielleicht noch Dinge in dem Schlüssel geladen werden.
Da ist bestimmt eine ganz normale CR2032 Batterie drin.
Aber es gibt vielleicht auch eine Variante, wo ein Akku drin ist oder so.
Also das kann natürlich auch sein, der dann irgendwie geladen wird.
Aber ja, also die Front-Facing-Camera vom iPhone, die kann Infrarot anzeigen,
die auf der Rückseite nicht.
Die haben einen guten Infrarot-Filter drin.
Die Frage für mich ist halt so ein bisschen, was lernt man jetzt so daraus?
Also erstens, das scheint ja schon ein wirklich sehr, sehr ungewöhnlicher,
seltener Fall zu sein, dass irgendjemand seinen Zweitschlüssel irgendwie zwei
Jahre nicht benutzt. Das finde ich schon mal erstaunlich.
Dass das ein seltener Fall ist? Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein seltener Fall ist.
Ja, aber dann, also ihr glaubt ja nicht wirklich, wie viele Leute ich auch abtelefoniert habe.
Und keiner hatte auch nur Anlernen als Stichwort für dieses Szenario,
was ich klar beschrieben habe. Das müssten die doch dann wissen aus ihrer Praxis.
Nein, ich glaube, was das eigentliche Problem ist, und zwar,
das habe ich neulich in einem YouTube-Video gesehen, wo das mal jemand rausgefunden hat.
Die Frage ist ja, wie ist die Kommunikation zwischen Schlüssel und Auto?
So, früher war das halt ein einfacher Code, den du mit einem einfachen Replay-Attack
dann auch verhindern, also auch auslösen konntest.
Also du hast ausgelesen, was schickt der Schlüssel und konntest später zum Auto
hingehen, das gleiche normal schicken und das Auto ging auf.
So, dann haben die Firmen angefangen, rotierende Schlüssel zu verwenden.
Das heißt, der Schlüssel hat sich gemerkt, welchen Schlüssel habe ich verwendet.
Nach einem Algorithmus wurde ein neuer Schlüssel generiert und dann wurde der nächste geschickt.
Das Auto wiederum protokolliert natürlich mit, was ist der letzte Schlüssel,
den ich gesehen habe, den akzeptiere ich nicht mehr.
So, wenn du jetzt lange genug nur einen der Schlüssel benutzt,
dann fällt der andere Schlüssel aus der Rotation raus und das Auto erkennt nicht mehr,
dass der Tastendruck auf dem anderen Schlüssel noch gültig ist,
beziehungsweise wenn er sich tief entlädt, kann es halt auch sein,
dass der Zähler wieder bei 1 ist.
Das halte ich für wahrscheinlich an der Stelle.
Aber das muss doch Mercedes alles wissen. Dann kann es dir halt passieren,
dass du den auch nicht mehr verwenden kannst.
Es sei denn, du drückst ihn 3000 Mal und dann bist du wieder in dem Fenster, wo es wieder geht.
3000 Mal habe ich den definitiv nicht gedrückt.
Naja, aber du weißt, was ich meine.
Jaja, verstehe das schon.
Und dadurch, dass du...
Die Sache mit dem Spiegel, keine Ahnung, das kommt mir schon.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass der Schlüssel, der tief entladen war,
ein komplett leerer Schlüssel ist, den du einem beliebigen Mercedes anlernen kannst.
Unklar.
Sondern ich glaube eher, dass der immer noch mit der eigentlichen Schlüsselanlage
gepaert ist, sondern dass er nur halt aus dem Sync rausgefallen ist.
und du ihn durch diese Spiegel-Dingster-Aktion das Auto wieder darauf gesynkt
hast, dass der Schlüssel jetzt wieder an der Stelle ist und das Auto es dann wieder akzeptiert.
Also das würde auch hier von Haley Facts im Chat das Security-Problem geben,
weil jetzt nach meiner Variante müsstest du halt einfach nur mit einem generischen
Schlüssel ankommen und könntest damit halt mit dieser Geschichte quasi jeden
beliebigen B-Klasse dann vom Parkplatz fahren.
Wie alt ist das Auto?
Naja, wenn es aufgeschlossen ist.
Wenn es aufgeschlossen ist. Ja, gut, also die Frage ist, ja,
genau, du musst ja ans Schlüssel.
Naja, also du musst ja schon aktiviert sein. Ich meine, rein zufällig ist mir
irgendwie heute Morgen beim YouTube-Verklicken irgendwie so ein YouTube-Short
vorgeworfen worden, wo tatsächlich so ein.
AdAccess Denied Car Keys Account, ja, also auch so viel Spezialisierung gibt
es an der Stelle schon kaum noch überraschend.
So ein irgendwie, ja, Fahrzeugschlüssel ist nicht mehr richtig gepaart.
Typ fährt mit seinem kleinen Laster als On-Demand-Service vor und löst das Problem in 10 Minuten.
Indem er halt hier an den Diagnostik-Port geht. Ich weiß nicht,
um was für ein Fahrzeug es jetzt hier geht, aber der hat irgendwie so eine ganze
Kiste voll mit Schlüsseln mit so generischen Smart-Car-Keys und so weiter.
sucht sich da irgendwie den passenden raus und geht dann halt mit so einem Spezialgerät an den,
Diagnostikport und geht dadurch ein paar Menüschritte durch und dann paert er
irgendwie den neuen Schlüssel und so weiter. Also das ist sozusagen,
vermutlich bei allen Fahrzeugen gibt es so eine Prozedur, weil es ist doch vollkommen irre.
Also wirklich, ich würde den Leuten, ich würde denen ja so einen Einlauf geben
da im Salzufer. wenn du da hinfährst, ich komm mit.
Das ist einfach, verstehst du, dass die sich, also die müssen dir eigentlich
ein neues Fahrzeug mitgeben.
Ja, also so eine Peinlichkeit.
Bitte Mercedes hier irgendwie, was ist ihr Claim?
Wir haben das Auto erfunden und alles. Ja, geht scheißen.
Also wirklich.
Tja.
Naja, vielleicht müsste ein Techniker einfliegen, der das kann.
Der die Secrets überhaupt wissen darf.
Das ist einfach, das muss die technische Datenbank hergeben.
Das muss jeder da auf dem Hof wissen, wie das funktioniert.
Das können die mir nicht erzählen, dass das irgendwie alle fünf Jahre mal passiert.
Das passiert wahrscheinlich permanent. Die haben Millionen von Autos auf der Straße.
Ja, das ist halt der Punkt, den ich nicht verstehe. Wie gesagt,
meine eigene Werkstatt wusste es nicht.
Und ich habe, bevor ich zu denen hinfahre, weil das ist einfach mal ein bisschen
weiter weg von mir, habe ich halt drei andere,
Original-Mercedes-Werkstätten antelefoniert und keiner von denen hatte dieses
Stichwort anlernen und kommen sie vorbei und da probieren wir durch und wird schon.
Sondern nee, das können wir nicht. Das geht nur im Flagship-Store.
Tja, aber ich habe jetzt zwei voll funktionsfähige Schlüssel alles gemacht.
Die 600 Euro klingt wirklich so, als würden sie irgendwie das Authentifizierungsmodul ausbauen,
neues Authentifizierungsmodul einbauen und die beiden Schlüssel,
die dazu gehören, mitliefen.
Und du solltest mal gucken, ob du bei Mercedes sozusagen einen unprogrammierten
Schlüssel für irgendeinen erträglichen Betrag erwerben kannst.
Dann kannst du nämlich noch einen dritten Schlüssel machen. Als Backup.
Nicht, dass ich es bräuchte, aber ja.
Backup braucht man immer erst.
Wenn es zu spät ist.
Genau.
Tja, Deutschland, deine Autonation.
Aber jetzt haben wir einen neuen Verkehrsminister und alles wird super.
Ja, was haben wir denn für einen? Wer ist denn jetzt Verkehrsminister?
Ich habe es auch noch nicht mitbekommen.
Wird schon so eine Nase sein.
Ist es CSU oder CDU?
Zum Glück endlich mal.
Hör auf, die Laune war gut.
Ich formuliere es andersrum. zumindest nicht CSU. So, das war der Satz der...
Ja, was denn sonst?
Also C, C, D, U ist es. Aber wer... Müssen wir jetzt mal gucken.
Was sagt ihr, das ist...
Ah, wo ist denn ihr Kabinett? Kabinett im Erz, ging doch gestern alles rum.
CDU-Politiker Patrick Schnieder, er organisierte Demos für den Autobahnbau.
Nun wird er Verkehrsminister. Da wird ja alles gut.
Genau, ja, ja.
So, so, Herr Schnieder.
Ja, Kulturstaatsminister wird ein Verleger. Das wird auch interessant,
der bisher Fokus gemacht hat.
und die Welt und sowas alles.
Das wird eine lustige Kultur, glaube ich, die wir da kriegen.
Eine lustige Kultur? Also wenn das solche Torfnasen sind, wie jetzt hier die
CDU in Berlin an den Start gebracht hat, die versagen ja auch wirklich hier auf ganzer Linie, oder?
Ja, vor allem sind sie so reaktiv und keine Ahnung.
Okay, lass uns nicht mal politisch.
Ja, das lassen wir jetzt.
Nee, nee, nee. Wo wir schon bei Fails sind. Komm, dann mache ich jetzt kurz
den Rant über Apples Image Playground.
Dass er sowas überhaupt benutzt.
Ich habe es halt ausprobiert, weil es hat mich interessiert. Was ist das?
Das ist irgendwie so ein Programm, da kann man halt Bilder mitmachen,
indem man da Keywords reinschmeißt.
und naja, da sagt man Katze, kommt eine Katze bei raus, das ist jetzt irgendwie
nicht so nicht so fürchterlich spannend eigentlich.
Interessant ist eher, was nicht geht. Also du kannst zum Beispiel sagen,
ich will eine dünne Katze haben, dann kriegst du eine dünne Katze.
Also Katze, komm mal dünn, das ist eine dünne Katze. Wenn du jetzt sagst, ich will eine Katze.
Eine dicke Katze, dann ist das Bodyshaming.
Dick, das geht nicht. Wenn du sagst, ich will eine Katze, die ist fett, das geht wieder.
Okay.
Also offensichtlich ist dieses eine Wort in einem...
Ist in einem Film, na ja, dicke Katze. Ah ja, dicke Katze scheint zu gehen. Doch.
Also zumindest das Wort dick ist wohl im Spam-Filter hängen geblieben bei denen.
So und dann habe ich noch weitere Dinge probiert und dann wurde es immer merkwürdiger.
Dann wollte ich eine Maus haben.
Dann sage ich Maus und dann sagt er mir, er möchte aber gerne jetzt noch ein
Foto haben. Eine Person auswählen.
Du kannst also eine Maus nicht machen.
Tim probiert das gerade live. Fahre fort, indem du eine Inspiration für die
Person in deinem Bild wählst. Eine Person aus.
Eine Inspiration für die Person in deinem Bild.
Und das, obwohl ich eigentlich noch eine Maus haben wollte.
Wieso denn? Was denn für eine Person? Ich wollte eine Maus haben. Dicke Maus.
Du, du, ja, egal. Komischerweise braucht man ein Menschenfoto.
Wenn ich jetzt sage Ratte, Ratte geht ohne Bild von einer Person.
Obwohl eine Ratte und eine Maus jetzt so vom Aussehen her jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
so unglaublich unterschiedlich sind.
Tatsache, das ist ja bekloppt. Was soll das denn?
Ich versuch's gerade mal mit etwas mehr.
Du musst es nochmal löschen, was du da hast. genau, mach mal die Maus weg,
dann hast du nur noch die Ratte und jetzt hast du eine Ratte.
Kann das irgendjemand erklären?
Also ich habe jetzt einfach mal ein Bild von mir ausgewählt,
da macht er jetzt halt so einen pseudolustigen Cartoon von mir mit Katzenohren.
Mäuseohren meinst du?
Wahrscheinlich, genau, Mäuseohren, genau, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich also irgendwie so ein,
Ausnahmefall, den sie da genommen haben nach dem Motto, wenn die Leute Maus
tippen, dann wollen sie selber als Maus aussehen.
Ich verstehe das ja für ihr komisches Genmoji oder wie sie das nennen,
also wenn man sozusagen jetzt für eine Person da ein Bild wählt,
aber warum muss man hier eine Person angeben für eine Maus, so ein Quatsch.
Ja, habe ich auch nicht verstanden.
Hast du noch was anderes gefunden, wo man das braucht?
Ja, aber das habe ich jetzt nicht aufgeschrieben. Ich habe noch mehr Tiere durchprobiert
und es gab noch einige andere Tiere, also Hund geht ohne Person, glaube ich.
Dicker Hund, ist ja ein dicker Hund.
Dicker Hund.
Dicker Hund will auch eine Person.
Diese Beschreibung kann nicht verwendet werden.
Das ist ja ein dicker Hund.
Ja, und dann gab es so ein paar Sachen, die hat er halt überhaupt nicht hingekriegt.
Also ich habe es mit einem Capybara versucht. Capybara kannte er nicht.
Fetter Hund. Fetter Hund geht, aber dicker Hund geht nicht.
Ja, ist wie bei der Katze. Also dick scheint echt ein verbotenes Wort zu sein bei denen.
Also selbst Hund alleine geht bei mir jetzt hier auch nicht.
Oder er ist jetzt gerade irgendwo festgefahren.
Es kann sein, dass du die Keywords noch hast von den anderen Versuch.
Ja, dann müsst ihr mir doch die anzeigen, damit ich sie löschen kann.
Dafür haben sie ja auch eine GUI.
Ja, dafür gibt es irgendwo da oben diesen Fertigknopf, glaube ich.
Also was es nicht gab, zum Beispiel das Capybara, kannte er gar nicht.
Ich sage dicker Dobermann.
Und dann habe ich mal in der Wikipedia nachgeguckt, auf Deutsch heißt Capybara
eigentlich Wasserschwein.
Aber wenn man Wasserschwein eingibt, dann macht er ganz komische Dinge.
Also es ist, es ist, äh, ja.
Bei Wasserschwein?
Also es sieht nicht nach einem Capybara aus, sagen wir mal so.
Nee, es sieht mehr nach einem Wildschwein aus.
Was so leichte Mausanmutung hat, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Vielleicht hat er die dicke Maus da reingemischt.
Also ich habe jetzt fetter Hund Berlin Fernsehturm gemacht.
Da kommen aber eigentlich ganz brauchbare Sachen aus. Das ist also ein ersichtlich
dicker Hund vor einem erkennbaren Berliner Fernsehturm.
Manchmal hat der Hund den Turm so aus dem Kopf raus, aber da sind dann drei
Türme. Dann hat der Turm mal noch so ein Zwischendeck.
Für einen Dobermann muss ich auch nur eine Person auswählen. So ein Unsinn.
Okay, das ist unbrauchbar. Also ich glaube, dieser ganze...
Oh, ich kriege zwei Fernsehtürme.
Dieser Apple-Intelligence-Kram ist wirklich...
Ist schon peinlich.
Es ist eigentlich unbrauchbar. Es ist komplett peinlich. Es ist ein totales Non-Feature.
Ich meine, wir haben uns ja hier irgendwie, als das angekündigt wurde,
hier vor einem Jahr ja auch so ein bisschen gefragt, okay, wo geht da die Reise
hin? Und ich dachte mir so, naja, die werden ja wohl schon irgendwie...
Naja, wir hatten uns damals mit Max gefetzt und man muss zugeben,
Max hat schon recht behalten.
Also das, was Apple da jetzt...
Max hat ja nur gesagt, es kommt nicht. Es wird nicht fertig.
Das war ja sein Punkt. Nicht, dass es nichts...
Ja, gut, aber ich meine, wenn du dir... Auch dieser Image-Playground,
das kannst du eigentlich als fertig bezeichnen.
Nein, das ist es ja auch nicht, aber das wusste man ja nicht und das ist ja
in dem Sinne auch ein bisschen was Neues für Apple, dass sie so ein Main-Feature-Ding,
Wie dieses Apple Intelligence, also sozusagen so hier unser neues Betriebssystem
oder nicht nur eins, sondern sozusagen unsere komplette Garde von Betriebssystemen auf allen Devices,
jetzt neu mit AI und wir nennen es auch noch Apple Intelligence und mischen
sozusagen auch unseren Namen mit rein.
Und dass das offensichtlich alles gegen die Wand gefahren wurde und sie in ihrer
Einschätzung darin, wie bald sie das wie gut hinbekommen,
komplett daneben gelegen haben,
sagt einerseits ein bisschen was darüber aus, wie es Apple gerade geht. Auf der einen Seite.
Viel zu gut.
Und auf der anderen Seite, naja, nicht so gut. Weil ich meine,
das ist ja im Prinzip eine Abkehr von ihren bisher gelebten Prinzipien.
Also sie haben zwar ab und zu auch mal was angekündigt, was dann nicht sofort da war.
Aber dann haben sie sich halt herangesetzt und haben halt ganz viel Energie reingesteckt.
Und dann war es halt irgendwann fertig. Also sie konnten,
sagen wir mal, die klassischen Features, die wir bisher immer gesehen haben
in Betriebssystemen, das war etwas, das konntest du mit etwas Kreativität und
viel Fleißarbeit am Ende dann auch hinbekommen.
weil mehr oder weniger klar ist was der Weg dahin ist der ist vielleicht steinig
und schwierig und lang aber er ist klar während bei diesem ganzen AI Kram,
speziell jetzt mit es ist sicher und ich meine dicker Hund ich weiß nicht was
sie verhindern wollen aber sie wollen halt irgendwas verhindern Dickpics natürlich.
Ja, okay, gut, stimmt. Was halt absurd ist irgendwie.
Und klar, das kann man irgendwie auch verstehen aus ihrer Perspektive,
nur die Einschätzung war ja, wir werden das schon irgendwie hinbekommen.
Und das Problem ist, bei so einer Technologie, wo du eigentlich am Ende nie
sagen kannst, was jetzt eigentlich genau das Neuron ist, was hier die falsche
Abzweigung genommen hat, was die falsche Gewichtung in diesem Model war.
Dann ist es halt wahrscheinlich auch einfach unmöglich, hier irgendwelche Versprechen
zu machen. Also ich weiß nicht.
Ja gut, aber hätten sie die Versprechen auch nicht machen dürfen, ganz ehrlich.
Gar keine Frage, sie hätten das so nicht machen dürfen, aber sie haben es getan
und das ist nicht gut und vor allem ist da halt viel Energie reingegangen und
viele andere Sachen, die vielleicht mal dringend nötig wären,
die ich ehrlich gesagt viel lieber gesehen hätte als diesen Quatsch,
naja, die sind halt irgendwie auf der Strecke geblieben.
Also mal so Bugs fixen zum Beispiel oder sowas, das wäre ja mal ganz geil.
Einfach mal die Scheiße stabil machen mal wieder.
Ja, also ich finde es underwhelming.
Ich finde es halt natürlich auch irgendwie kacke, dass die paar Features,
die sie jetzt wirklich gebaut haben, die wirklich praktisch sind,
dass die halt jetzt nicht kommen, wegen der Auseinandersetzung mit der EU.
Vielen Dank, EU, an der Stelle.
Ich hatte das ja mal in der Beta, ich weiß nicht, hast du auch mal so zwischendurch
so eine Beta installiert? Also ich hätte mal diese,
15, 4 Beta laufen gehabt, also die developer-Beta von macOS.
Habe ich drauf bei mir, ja.
Hast du immer noch drauf?
Ja, aber ich habe generell immer die Dev-Beta drauf bei mir.
Also als ich in... Und hast du iPhone-Synchronisierung?
Geht nicht.
Als ich in Vietnam war und die Beta fuhr, ging das.
Also ich durfte das mal testen.
Ja, aber das wird dann mit wieder irgendwie...
Es wurde im Release dann wieder kassiert, es war dann weg, aber ich hab's halt
zumindest mal eine Weile benutzt und das ist halt ein geiles Feature. Das hätte ich gern.
Stattdessen gibt's nur diesen Quatsch und wegen der unklaren Regelungen mit
diesem Digital Markets Act gibt es halt jetzt die geilen Features gibt es halt
alle nicht. Und das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile so weitergehen.
Aber auf meinem iPhone kann ich jetzt endlich wieder Menschen finden.
Wir nennen uns, das ist aus Südkorea und war darum irgendwie 150 Euro günstiger,
aber hatte dann halt so die Privacy Security,
Einschränkungen auch von Südkorea und die konnten sich irgendwie zehn Jahre
lang nicht mit Apple einigen über,
das Find My Feature, wie man das irgendwie mit südkoreanischem Recht zusammenbringt
und da ging es schon vor ein paar Monaten rum so, die hätten jetzt eine Einigung
erreicht und es würde jetzt kommen und seit dem letzten Update,
geht es einfach so. Immerhin.
Kaum macht man es richtig, funktioniert es auch gleich.
Dieses eine Person auswählen, das macht mich wahnsinnig. Ich habe gerade Alien
gesagt, einen relativ uninteressanten Alien. Okay, Alien auf einem Pferd.
Hat er hingekriegt, der Alien sitzt auf einem Pferd. Sag ich,
Alien auf einem Pferd vor dem Todesstern.
Was sagt er? Fahre fort, indem du eine Inspiration für die Person in deinem Bild wählst.
Fahre fort, indem du eine Inspiration wählst.
Was ist denn das für eine Sprache auch? Also ich muss auch sagen,
das schmerzt einfach wirklich.
Okay, hier ist jetzt weder ein Alien noch ein Pferd drauf. Immerhin ein Todesstern.
Apple, bitte macht einfach, ich will einfach nur einen geilen Computer haben.
Ich brauche diesen ganzen Unsinn nicht.
Also ich weiß auch nicht genau, ich kann sie ja irgendwie verstehen.
Die ganze Welt hat jetzt irgendwie nach AI geschrien, Aber normalerweise haben
sie sich ja eigentlich immer ganz gut dagegen gewehrt, das zu tun,
wonach alle schreien. Aber hier haben sie wirklich mal nachgegeben.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht müsste es ja eigentlich bedeuten, dass sie den Wert gesehen haben.
Und das hatte ich ihnen zugetraut, dass sie in den Anwendungen die AI potenziell
eröffnet, die Anwendungen sehen, die wirklich sinnvoll sein können.
Und okay, Textzusammenfassung.
Also ich weiß nicht, mein Leben hat es jetzt nicht um 180 Grad gedreht,
dass jetzt so ein Summary von einer E-Mail angezeigt wird in der Notification,
dass ich irgendwie mit einem Blick schon sehen kann, wenn die Notification kommt,
was so in etwa der Inhalt dieser E-Mail ist.
Ich würde sagen, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen besser, als wenn er nur das
Subject anzeigt, aber wenn das alles ist,
ansonsten weiß ich nicht, gibt es überhaupt irgendein AI-relevantes Feature
in den Apple-Betriebssystemen, wo wir jetzt sagen würden, wenn das jetzt ausgeschaltet
ist, dann würden wir es sofort vermissen?
Also die Kategorisierung von E-Mails fand ich ganz gut.
Das habe ich sofort abgeschaltet.
Die funktioniert bei mir ganz brauchbar.
Bei mir auch, aber hat Google auch gefüllt seit 15 Jahren.
Was kategorisiert die denn bei dir?
Na, wichtig und Shopping und Community.
Forengeschichten und Werbung.
Ja, das ist schon.
Und wie benutzt du das dann?
Ich schalte das ein und dann sehe ich die Liste der E-Mails.
Und 90% der Zeit arbeite ich nur im Wichtig-Ordner. Das habe ich aber vorher
schon per Hand gehabt, indem ich VIP,
diese VIP-Funktion ganz massiv nutze und alle
anderen e-mails eigentlich mehr oder weniger ignoriere weil
alle leute das e-mail ist sowieso überhaupt nicht mein medium die leute wissen
dass sie mich über chat und dms und mastodon und sonst wo erreichen und nicht
über e mail und die wenigen dinge die ich noch per e mail irgendwie brauche
die habe ich alle in vip kontakte gepackt und die gucke ich mir regelmäßig an alles andere.
Du hast gefragt, welches Feature ich benutze.
Ja, ja, ich grübel gerade, ob ich der AI-Zutrauer einzuschätzen,
was für mich wichtig ist. Und da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Sagen wir mal so, ich habe mein E-Mail-Postfach etwas ausufern lassen und habe
schon lange nicht mehr konsequent auf viele Newsletter unten abbestellen gedrückt.
Insofern ist es ganz gut, dass diese Klassifizierung halbwegs in der Lage ist,
Mails, die tatsächlich in einen Newsletter auch gehören, da auch reinzutun.
Also das ist schon die Sachen, die ein bisschen interessanter sind,
als wichtig zu kennziffern, kennzeichnen.
Naja, gut. Ich würde sagen, wir sind durch, oder? Keine Themen mehr.
Ja.
Wir bemühen uns mal um einen nicht ganz so nach hinten geschobenen Termin für
die nächste Sendung. und gucken wir mal, wie viel Erfolg wir damit haben werden.
Und ja, mir fällt jetzt nicht mehr so richtig viel ein.
Das war jetzt eine Sendung des Wehklagens. Wir hatten irgendwie nur gemeckert. Ein Meckeronkel.
Dann müssen wir nächstes Mal was Positives.
Genau, nächstes Mal machen wir wieder was total Positives.
Wo bleibt das Positive?
So sieht es nämlich aus. Stimmt's?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Gut, dann können wir ja mal hier Outro machen. Die schöne Musik.
Und die begleitet euch jetzt hinaus zum nächsten Podcast, der in eurer Liste
ist. Und Freakshow kommt auch bald wieder.
Und da freut ihr euch jetzt am besten schon mal drauf. Wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall auch.
Und sagen bis dahin. Tschüss und bis bald.
Tschö.
Freut euch gefälligst. Tschüss.